JERRY I'M GONNA CALL THE
COMMITTEE TO ORDER AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. OF WHEN WE GET A
FULL QUORUM I WILL LOCK. WILL
CALL THE QUORUM BUT UNTIL THEN
WE CAN'T MAKE MOTIONS.
BUT WE WILL START A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THE FIRST PERSON IS
SANTIAGO.
AND THEN COBBLER GYRO YES THERE
YOU ARE CAMANO.
ALRIGHT.
OUR SHOW WELCOME ALL TO THE
HEARING AT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE. I'D FIRST LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE OUR MELISSA MELENDEZ
AS OUR NEW MEMBER AND ALSO AS
VICE CHAIR. WE SERVED TOGETHER
AS CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
FOR AWHILE AND IN NOW PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND. WE COULD ALWAYS
AGREE TO DISAGREE AMIABLY AND
DIVERT IMMENSE RESPECT.
OUR FOR.
MS MELENDEZ AND.
HER.
CURRENT TAKE READY AND THE
REASON THAT SHE SHE VOTES THE
WAY SHE DOES AND. ARE. JUST I'M
VERY GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
SO.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KABBAH GYRO.
I AM LET'S OH YES FIRST THEY
HAVE TO KNOW THAT ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT. WAS
PULLED BY COMMITTEE FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA AND WILL BE HEARD.
NEXT WEEK ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND.
WE ALSO HAVE TO BILLS THAT ARE
CORRUPT OPPOSED TO CONSENT OF
THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE SOLACE.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT CHEN
AND WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. A
WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL BE VERY
SHORTLY I WILL BRING THOSE CHU
WOP.
I WANT TO THANK.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN TODAY
FOR FILLING IN FOR US AGAIN I AM
VERY GLAD THAT TO IN YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE LET. THAT YOU ARE HERE
AND THAT TAKING THE TIME TO BE
WITH THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALRIGHT.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. DAHLE ARROW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIFTY THE SMALL SYSTEM
WATER AUTHORITY ACT OF. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS IDENTIFIED
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED WATER
SYSTEMS STATEWIDE THAT
CHRONICALLY SERVE CONTAMINATED
DRINKING WATER OR CANNOT PROVIDE
THE RESIDENTS A RELIABLE WATER
SERVICE.
DO DO IN ADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE THEY LACK LOCAL
FINANCIAL MANAGERIAL OR
TECHNICAL RESOURCES.
A VAST MAJORITY OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE SMALL RURAL SYSTEMS THAT
TYPICALLY SERVED LESS. THAN A
HUNDRED UP THEN TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND THERE WAS NEVER A
BETTER TIME TO RECOGNIZE THE
CRISIS.
IN THIS SYSTEM THAN DURING THE
DROUGHT WHEN WE HAD THE SYSTEM
AFTER SYSTEM FAILURE AND.
PEOPLE THAT WERE REALLY RELIANT
ON BOTTLED WATER IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO GET THAT THEIR WATER
NEEDS MET.
NOTHING IN CURRENT LAW WOULD
PRECLUDE AN UNDERPERFORMING
WATER SYSTEM FROM CONSOLIDATING
EITHER VOLUNTARILY OR TO THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. MANDATED CONSOLIDATION
PROCEDURES AS OUTLINED IN S. B.
EIGHTY EIGHT OR S. B. FIVE FIFTY
TWO. HOWEVER CONSOLIDATIONS ARE
COMPLEX.
AND.
KOMPLEKS TO EXECUTE A MUST
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE NATURE OF THE
REGION AND THE SITUATION THAT
HAS RESULTED IN THE SYSTEM
FAILURE.
TRADITIONAL CONSOLIDATIONS MUCH
RICK MUST RELY ON A LARGER HOST
AGENCY TO FACILITATE THE
CONSOLIDATION. THE LARGER SYSTEM
MUST ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
CONSOLIDATION DOES NOT IMPACT
ITS EXISTING CUSTOMERS.
AB TWENTY FIFTY
PROVIDES A SOLUTION BY MERGING
SMALL NONCOMPLIANT WATER SYSTEMS
INTO A LARGER MORE ROBUST PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEM THAT CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IMPROVED ECONOMIES
OF SCALE.
STREAMLINED MANAGERIAL FUNCTIONS
ENHANCED FINANCIAL CAPACITY AND
THE MERGE SYSTEMS WILL BE FORMED
AS INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
AND PROVIDED WITH NEW INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL FINANCING
OPPORTUNITIES AND INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY INCLUDED. INCLUDING
AN ELECTED BOARD OF DIRECTORS
THE NEW AUTHORITIES WILL BE
SCALED TO A SIZE TO DEVELOP.
COORDINATE OUR CONTRACT THROUGH
LOCAL REGIONAL AGREEMENTS THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE TO
TREAT CONTAMINATION ISSUES. THIS
IN TURN WILL LEAD TO MORE
SUSTAINABLE WATER SYSTEMS THAT
CAN EFFECTIVELY DELIVER SAFE.
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AB TWENTY FIFTY ESTABLISHES A
ROADMAP FOR THE CONSOLIDATION OF
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS AND DOES NOT
RELY ON A LARGER HOST AGENCY
WHICH IS IMPORTANT. AS MANY OF
THE SYSTEMS MAY NOT BE ADJACENT
TO A LARGER SYSTEM THEY'RE
PRETTY MUCH SPREAD OUT
THROUGHOUT REAL RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
STATE BOARD WILL NOTIFY THE
CHRONICALLY NONCOMPLIANT SYSTEMS
THAT THEY ARE IN VIOLATION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. EACH
SYSTEM WILL BE PROVIDED WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE.
IF A PLAN IS NOT APPROVED BY THE
STATE BOARD THEY WILL NOTIFY THE
LOCAL THAT COUNTY LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION OR LAUGH
GO.
THAT CHRONICALLY NONCOMPLIANT
SYSTEMS WITHIN THE COUNTY WILL
BE DISSOLVED AND CONSOLIDATED
INTO ONE IT INTO AN AUTHORITY.
WITH ME IN SUPPORTOF AB TWENTY
FIFTY TODAY ARE DON GILBERT
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA MUTUAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AND PAUL
RODGERS GENERAL MANAGER EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
A MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DON
GILBERT REPRESENTING WELL WE
ALLOW FOR MINUTES.
.
USUALLY TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
RICHARD ON GILBERT REPRESENTING
AT CMU WAY CMU AIDS MEMBERS.
PROVIDE WATER TO SEVENTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS.
AND.
AS PROGRESSIVE SOLUTION
ORIENTED AGENCIES.
THOSE MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS REGULAR
ACCESS TO SAFE AND RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER. AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIFTY WHICH IS A SMART AND
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION. TO A
STRUGGLING WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE.
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY OF A
WATER SYSTEM ROOM REQUIRES
TECHNICAL MANUFAKTUR AND
MANAGERIAL AND FINANCIAL
CAPACITY OTHERWISE KNOWN AS TMF.
TECHNICAL CAPACITY MEANS HAVING
ADEQUATE DRINKING WATER
RESOURCES INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TREATMENT.
MANAGERIAL CAPACITY MEANS HAVING
HIGHLY QUALIFIED PERSONNEL TO
OPERATE THE SYSTEM AND FINANCIAL
CAPACITY MEANS HAVING SUFFICIENT
REVENUE.
TO COVER CAPITAL COSTS
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
AND AS WELL AS BEING CREDIT
WORTHY AND HAVE ACCESS TO
FINANCE.
NOT ALL WATER SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE TMF THESE SYSTEMS
ARE THOSE THE ONES THAT ARE
CHRONICALLY NON. AND AS A RESULT
THEY DON'T PROVIDE RELIABLE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO THEIR
RESIDENTS.
THE EPA HAS CONCLUDED THAT THE
MANAGERIAL CAPACITY COMPONENTS
OF THIS TMF FORMULA IF YOU WILL.
IS WHAT ALSO ENABLES TECHNICAL
AND FINANCIAL SHORT COMING IN
ENABLES A AGENCIES TO OVERCOME
TECHNICAL AND FINANCIAL
SHORTCOMINGS COMINGS AND BE
PROPERLY OPERATED. SO THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
AB TWENTY FIFTY IS A BIG PART OF
THE SOLUTION IT ESTABLISHES AS
THE AUTHOR SAID A SMALL LITTLE
SMALL WATER SYSTEM.
AND IT DOES THIS BY CREATING A
LAUGH CHO DRIVEN PROCESS.
IN WHICH ALL NON COMPLIANT WATER
SYSTEMS CAN AGGREGATE TO BECOME
ONE FUNCTIONAL WATER SYSTEM.
THIS PROVIDES IMPROVED ECONOMIES
OF SCALE.
LARGE A LARGER RATE BASE
STREAMLINED AND MORE ACCURATE
AND ITS AREA FUNCTIONS MINUTES I
IS THERE ANOTHER SPEAKER.
YES OKAY IMBIBE JUST WRAP UP
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
FOR. IT PROVIDES IS VERY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITIES AB
THROUGH ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND
FOR THAT REASON WE THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD AS ONE TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX FOR A LARGE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR QUIRK MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE ON PAUL JONES
GENERAL MANAGER OF EASTER
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT WHICH
IS AN AGENCY THAT PROVIDES WATER
WASTEWATER RECYCLE WATER
SERVICES FOR ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. UP OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST TWO DECADES
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
INVOLVED IN SEVERAL WATER
AGENCIES CONSOLIDATION CENTER
RESULTANT. RESULTED IN
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE RELIABILITY
AND SERVICE. HAVE ALSO BEEN
INVOLVED IN A CONSOLIDATION OF A
PRIVATE WATER SYSTEM THAT HAD
BEEN SERVING CONTAMINATE WATER
IS SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER FOR SMALL
STRUGGLING SYSTEMS
CONSOLIDATIONS WITH LARGER HOSTS
AGENCIES CAN BE EFFECTIVE BUT
EVEN THOSE CONSOLIDATIONS
BETWEEN WILLING PARTNERS CAN BE
VERY COMPLICATED. I AB TWENTY
FIFTY CERTAINLY UNIQUE BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES A NEW CONSOLIDATION
MECHANISM.
WHERE MULTIPLE CHRONICALLY
FAILING SYSTEMS ARE DISSOLVED
AND THEN REFORMED INTO LARGER
COMPETENT AGENCIES THAT HAVE
TECHNICAL MANAGER OWN FINANCIAL
CAPABILITIES? A ACCESS.
TO TAX EXEMPT INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING IMPROVED ECONOMIES OF
SCALE. HERE OF THE THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE SYSTEMS.
THAT ARE IN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD'S
DATABASE IS BEING CHRONICALLY
NONCOMPLIANT. EIGHTY THREE
PERCENT OF THEM SERVE LESS THAN
A THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE FOUR
HUNDRED SERVICE CONNECTION SO
THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE ARE JUST
VERY DIFFICULT TO REALIZE. THAT
COURSE AB TWENTY FIFTY ADDRESSES
THIS BY COMBINING THE SYSTEMS AT
A COUNTY OR SUB COUNTY LEVEL.
BUT FINALLY I'D LIKE TO MENTION
A COUPLE OF THINGS WITH RESPECT
TO THE BILL BUT TO ENSURE
OVERALL ACCOUNTABILITY AB TWENTY
FIFTY. BUILDS IN A POST
FORMATION OVERSIGHT PROCESS WITH
AN INDEPENDENT REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE START UP IN
FINANCIAL HEALTH OF THESE NEW
SYSTEMS AND THAT'S DEVELOPED IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE STATE
BOARD. STRAIGHT TREASURERS
OFFICE AND LAUGH CHO SO WE
BELIEVE.
THROUGH THIS BILL THEIR BEER A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS AND THAT THE NEW SMALL
SYSTEM WATER AUTHORITIES WILL
COMPETENTLY DELIVER. SAFE
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES IN NEED.
ENDS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO OTHERS SHOT IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
LARA PART IN BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF RIVERSIDE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
AND CAN YOU ON HIS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
BROWN GERVASI CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MAUREEN O'HARA REPRESENTING THE
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CURIOUSLY BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
HECTOR FERNANDES ON BEHALF OF
THE REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY OUT
WE HAD THE HOUSE SUPPORT AN
ADMIN POSITION.
KATHY COLLARD METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROLYN JENSEN WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DID YOU SPEAK UP
FOR GET A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE CAROLYN JENSEN WITH
KP. ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THAT'S A LOSS ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
AND THE SANTA ANA WATERSHED
PROJECT THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST HUNDRED
AYE JOGO THE CLOCK A GROUP ON
BEHALF OF LONG BEACH WATER
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMONSENSE APPROACH.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND
TO THANK YOU.
TODD MAINLY WITH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD ARM ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
THERE BEING NONE OUR QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
YES MISS VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SO.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AYE I VERY MUCH
LIKE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS BILL BY I HAVE A
COUPLE OF PROBLEMS TO.
RELATIVELY MINOR AND AN WHEN IN
THE BIG PICTURE AND ONE IT'S
VERY MAJOR TO ME.
.
FOR SOME REASON THE BOARD
MEMBERS OF THESE NEW DISTRICTS
ARE GOING TO BE PAID NEARLY
DOUBLE THAN OTHER MUNICIPAL
WATER BOARD MEMBERS.
ACCORDING TO MY ANALYSIS I'M
NOT SURE WHY THAT IS.
YOU GUYS ARE SHAKING YOUR HEADS
NOW SELL. YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT TO BE THE CASE.
NO NO I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT TO
BE THE CASE AT ALL.
NOT SURE WHY WHY THAT'S COME UP
IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
OKAY.
I AM.
THREE YEARS TO PAY BACK.
THE ORIGINAL OWNERS.
CORRECT.
THREE YEAR THREE YEARS TO PAY
BACK AND THAT'S.
.
I'M WONDERING WHY IT'S THE IT'S
NOT SEEN AS A LONG.
JEFF THEY WAS OUR CONTEMPLATION
GIVEN THE MAKING IT. EVEN A YEAR
LESS THAN THAT EARNED. YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M IT THIS THIS IS ON.
I THINK THE CONCEPT BEHIND THIS
IS THAT ALL OF THESE ARE NON
COMPLIANT WATER DISTRICTS ARE.
UP FINANCIALLY STRAPPED LEAGUE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE.
UNCONTAMINATED A DRINKING WATER
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME AND SO WHAT
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO IS GIVE
THEM ENOUGH TIME TO BE ABLE TO.
GO THROUGH THIS CONSOLIDATION
PROCESS.
GET A NEW BOARD OF DIRECTORS ON
BECAUSE THERE THERE WILL BE A
CHANGE OF LEADERSHIP.
HIRE THE STAFF THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED TO BE ABLE TO NOW
BECOME COMPLAINT WITH STATE LAW
AND WE WANT TO GIVE THEM ENOUGH
TIME TO BE ABLE TO PAY OFF ANY
DEBTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE DOING
THAT THAT THAT. THE PROCESS AND.
PART OF THAT PART OF THE
BENEFIT OF DOING THESE
CONSOLIDATIONS ISN'T THERE
REALLY IS STATE MONEY IT AT THE
WATER BOARD FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT THESE PARTICULAR
WATER. DISTRICTS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE OUR WATER ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
THERE. THAT.
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
THEN THEY DON'T HAVE THE STAFF
THAT ONCE THEY IF THEY COULD GET
A GRANT THAT COULD ACTUALLY
EXECUTED SO WE ANTICIPATE THAT.
THAT THAT IT'S THE BITS THE M..
THAT THE NEW BOARD.
HIRING NEW STAFF AND BRINGING
THE MOM BOARD IT MAY TAKE THEM
AWHILE TO BE ABLE TO PAY.
THEIR OBLIGATIONS BACK AND
FRANKLY IF THEY CAN GET IT DONE
IN ONE OR TWO YEARS THAT'S GREAT
BUT WE DON'T WANT IT SET THEM UP
FOR FAILURE IMMEDIATELY BY
HAVING THEM PAY FOR SOMETHING
THAT THEY. ON THIS VERY
DIFFICULT.
THAT'S A THOUGHT.
OKAY.
.
I STILL THINK THREE YEARS IS A
LONG TIME DEBT BUT I I GET WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT I THINK
FLY IN THIS BILL FOR ME IS THAT
THERE'S NO VOTER APPROVAL
REQUIRED FOR ISSUING THESE BONDS
AND I FIND THAT VERY
TROUBLESOME.
WHICH IS WHY I CANNOT SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY I'M I'M NOT SURE
IF THERE'S ROOM FOR NEGOTIATING
ON THAT BUT. I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT IF IF THE RATE
PAYERS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
GOING TO BE PAYING FOR THESE
BONDS THAT THEY HAVE A SAY IN
WHETHER NOT THOSE BONDS ARE
ISSUED AND I THINK IF THEY HAVE.
CONTINUED OVER THE YEARS HAVE
BEEN DELIVERED.
CONTAMINATED WATER NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER IT THEY
WOULD CERTAINLY WANT TO PAY INTO
THOSE IMPROVEMENTS SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO. TO ISSUE THESE
BONDS WITHOUT VOTER APPROVAL AM
I I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY COULD I
USE THE REFERENDUM PROCESS IF
THEY WEREN'T SATISFIED WITH THIS
BUT THAT IS PUTTING THE BURDEN.
ON THE RATEPAYERS AT THE BACK
AND RATHER THAN PUTTING THE
BURDEN ON THE WATER DISTRICT AT
THE FRONT AND WHICH I THINK
MAKES MORE SENSE OUT.
.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOLLOW.
DO YOU HAVE OF WATER DISTRICTS
OF THIS TYPE IN YOUR ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
I DO I HAVE VIA.
YES I DO.
OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
IT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ALRIGHT.
I WILL SAY THAT I THINK THAT
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BELT
TO MOVE FORWARD.
I NOTE THAT THE WATER AGENCIES
IN THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
WERE BY AND LARGE IN SUPPORT.
ARM AND I THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PARTICULAR WE HEAR
FROM THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS SOME
OF WHICH ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
BE PART OF THIS CONSOLIDATION.
SO I'M MERGING AND I VOTE AND
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED.
WILL ASK FOR MOTION AND WILL GO
AHEAD WITH GETTING THE VOTE. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
HIS THINK ALIGNMENT YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALRIGHT NEXT IS SANTIAGO.
AND IF NOT THEN CALDERON
.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO
LIST ALL INGREDIENTS ON THE
LABELS OF PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC
PRODUCTS.
EXCEPT FOR THOSE PROTECTED BY
TRADE SECRETS
TO PROVIDE OPEN INFORMATION FOR
CONSUMERS LINE WORKERS AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
UNDER CURRENT LAW PROFESSIONAL
COSMETIC PRODUCTS.
THOSE USES LAUNCH ON A DAILY
BASIS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO BE
LABELED.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY APPLY THE
EXISTING INDUSTRY LABELING
REQUIREMENT FOR RETAIL COSMETIC
PRODUCTS.
PROFESSIONAL COSMETICS.
WHILE RETAIL BECAUSE MARRIAGE
ARE SOLD TO THE PUBLIC FOR
LIVESTOCK CONSUMPTION
PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC PRODUCTS
ARE USED BY SALON WORKERS FOR
UPWARDS OF EIGHT HOURS A DAY.
RESULTING IN MANY CASES OF ACUTE
DISAPPEAR HEALTH SYMPTOMS.
AB IS TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
GIVE SALON WORKERS AND CONSUMERS
THE ABILITY TO VIEW INGREDIENTS
AND OPEN WAY. THAT IS ALREADY
STANDARDIZED CROSS OUR FOOD HOME
PRODUCTS AND RETAIL COSMETICS.
SINCE MY INTRODUCTION OF THIS
CONCEPT LAST YEAR WE EVER KNEW
MOVED ALL OPPOSITION AND IT
PROBABLY PROCEED THE SUPPORT.
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND IS FOR
THOSE REASONS MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
I'M WITH ME TODAY I'VE CATHERINE
PORTER POLICY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NIELSEN
COLLABORATIVE. MANDY THE PERSON
WITH THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL AND YET WHEN I LICENSE
MANICURES FROM OAKLAND.
VERY GOOD.
US OF THE WITNESSES I HAVE FOUR
MINUTES AND.
PLEASE YEAH GO AHEAD.
ASSISTS HELLO YEAH. THANK YOU.
I'M CATHERINE PORTER POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY NOW SLUNG COLLABORATIVE
WERE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. WORK
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND JUSTICE AND WORKERS
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS AND ALSO
INDIVIDUAL NAIL SALON WORKERS IN
OWNERS MOST OF WHOM ARE
VIETNAMESE IMMIGRANT WOMEN OUT.
OF REPRODUCTIVE AGE
EVERY WORK DAY FOR LONG HOURS
NAY ALLEN HERE SALON WORKERS YOU
SOLVENTS GLUES POLISHES
STRAIGHTENERS ANOTHER BEAUTY.
CARE PRODUCTS CONTAIN CHEMICALS
KNOWN OR SUSPECTED TO CAUSE
CANCER IN REPRODUCTIVE
RESPIRATORY NEUROLOGICAL OR
OTHER HARM. AND THESE EXPOSURES
ARE EXPERIENCED ON TOP OF THOSE
FROM THEIR OWN DAILY USE OF
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS SUCH AS
SHAMPOO AND LOTIONS.
OTHER MANUFACTURERS ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO LIST INGREDIENTS ON
THE LABELS OF COSMETICS SOLD AT
THE RETAIL LEVEL.
LEADS RETAIL LEVEL THEY HAVE NO
SIMILAR LEGAL OBLIGATION IT
COMES TO PROFESSIONAL COSMETICS
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL
FILL. AND IMPROVE THIS LABELING
POLICY GAP BY REQUIRING THAT
MANUFACTURES LIST INGREDIENTS
SOME PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC.
CONTAINER LABELS WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE A YES VOTE ON AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN BIRDS MAY BE AWAY
ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL THE COSMETICS
INDUSTRY. AND PROD SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL LAST YEAR WHEN MISTER
KALRA INTRODUCE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE I BELIEVE IT WAS. A
WE WERE IN A DIFFERENT POSITION
IN THIS COMMITTEE WE WERE
ACTUALLY POSTS THAT BELL.
BUT SINCE THAT TIME WE WHEN WE
WORKED WITH THIS OFFICE TO CRAFT
A BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR
IDENTICAL WRECK REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE'RE ALREADY REQUIRED. TO
DISCLOSE FOR OUR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS AND THEREFORE WE ARE
VERY PROUD TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
TODAY.
I'VE REITERATED THIS THE LAST
ME THAT WE WERE AND IT IS NOT IN
CITY INSIGNIFICANT THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS HERE IN SUPPORT.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CRAFT
A REASONABLE PROPOSAL WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A NEXT.
LOOK AT THE KNOWN EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS DEEPLY.
I BELIEVE GREAT DICK TO UNITE
THE X. RAY FROM VIETNAM A BILL
THOUSAND FLY.
I WORK ACE THE MANY THEORIES.
FNC NELSON LOW IT OPEN. AND I
ALSO LEAVE IT OPEN.
I HAVE GOT IN DOUBTS THAT ON FOR
TEN YEARS.
ATHLETIC LOOKING DENOUNCE THE
LOANS BECAUSE I HAVE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. MEMBERS IN THAT
BUSINESS.
AND KNEW I COULD BLOW NO SKILL
BOODLE A WATCH UP.
WHEN I DECIDED.
THE BE A MANY THEORIES.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT EVERYDAY I
WOULD WORK WITH HOW FOR
CHEMICALS.
I AM NOT SOME WEIRD ICED USE ME
WE'RE GONNA ESTABLISH QUORUM
WHILE I STILL HAVE FOUR MEMBERS.
SO LET ME DO THAT AND THEN MOVE
BE GLAD TO HEAR YOU FINISH.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
QUIRK.
HERE QUIRK HERE.
MELENDEZ LENDERS HERE
ARAMBULA.
GROW.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HEAR MORE A TO CHEER
MATTEUCCI HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU AND.
.
LET'S SEE I I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE SO WE
COULD. GET THIS ARE GOING AND
GET THIS DONE. I WANT TO SAY
THAT.
RIGHT NOW MEMBERS ARE
PRESENTING BILLS THROUGHOUT THE.
THE BUILDING AND SO IT'S VERY
HARD TO GET EVERYONE HERE TODAY
PLEASE CONTINUE WITH YOUR.
TESTIMONY YOU HAVE.
A COUPLE MORE MINUTES.
AND QUIRK SOME GUYS AYE EXPERIAN
DEBTS.
THE. RIGHT SHE'S.
WHAT THREE EYES THE M. EVEN
COMPARABLE BREATHING WHICH MAY
BE RELATED BILL NO PRODUCTS?
I USE.
AN INGREDIENT LIST ON THE LEVEL
OF A PROFESSIONAL COST ME PICK.
LARRY.
NOW PUBLISHED
HOUSE ME WHEN A CUSTOMER ASKS.
WHAT THE PARTY'S COMPANIONS?
I CAN'T JUST STROLL THE LABEL TO
THE CUSTOMER.
IF I GET SPEAK.
APPLE USING A PRODUCT AT WORK.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
IF I CALL CHAU ADDUCTOR. BELLIES
UP INGREDIENT ON THE BOTTLE
STILL DUG UP THE COULD FIEGER
AROUND WHAT.
WRONG WITH ME.
NOW IS THE NOW OWNERS AND LOOK
CLOSE LIKE ME AND LET ME LONG
ANDLAW. ALLOW HOW BILL PRO
THANK HOUSE THEY'LL WAS.
FROM TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
PROFESSIONAL COST ME PICKS.
A FIFTY BILLION BRILLIANT
INFLAMMATION.
IS THAT A POP THEM FOR US TO DO
THAT FINALLY. AS THE PAW.
AB. BILL SEVEN SEVENTY PHI BE
CLOSE LONG WORKERS.
DESERVE A TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THE
PRODUCTS WE USE EVERYDAY.
LATEST REVOLVE YES.
ON A. B..
BILL SEVEN SEVEN FIVE.
THANK AND THANK THE LOVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OTHERS IN SUPPORT
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSSESS AND
US POSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS AUTUMN OGDEN SMITH
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK AND PROUD
SUPPORT.
FUNNY ANG WITH THE COUNTER WHERE
SUPPORTIVE OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS SARAH FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
ADAM RAN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IT'S CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX FELONIES
FELONIES GROUP ON BEHALF OF
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POLIO ARMY
HAVE IT SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE COMFORT OF
PRODUCTS STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
JERRY HEXUM BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO ADVOCATES IN OF A WITH THE
SENATE FROM BERMAN HEALTHY IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME LANGUAGE AND. I AM.
I M. OF MAYBE COOLEY.
NAIL LUCY SALON IN A PLAN.
I PRODUCT.
A BAY SEVERAL SUB BUTTON TRY
LEUKEMIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAT WITH ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES
AND SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS TO THREATEN THAT I AM
AND WHAT I LIKE RECRUITED AT
LANCE HILLEL ACT. OUT IN THE
OPEN AND IT LIKELY TO ASH BOUGHT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICTORIA ROME
WITH NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
HI I MEAN ENTRANCE AND I OWN A
COUPLE NON TOXIC NOW SWANSON
SACRAMENTO AND ME IN MY PLACE IS
PART THE SPOKE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA VAN FLEET
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
BILL OUT LEO ENVIRONMENT WORKING
COULD NOT SEE HERNANDEZ THAT WE
HAVE THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR.
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD.
.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OUR
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE.
THAT HAS CON HERE'S SUPPORT NOT
JUST TODAY.
BUT THE WORK HAS BEEN DONE OVER
THE PAST. A YEAR OR MORE.
BLACK WOMAN FOR WELLNESS BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS
WOMEN'S VOICES FOR HELP AND OF
COURSE COMPANY HELPING US LONG
COLLABORATIVE AT SPONSORS. AND
MISS PORTER SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
WORK THAT SHE'S DONE WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE.
BUT THE COLLABORATION WITH
INDUSTRY FOR A HOME WITHOUT HER
SUPPORT AND WORK AS WELL AS.
MANUALLY HERE FOR PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL.
YOU KNOW HAVING A ONE EIGHTY
WHERE WE HAD INDUSTRY OPPOSED TO
NOW HAVING INDUSTRIES PORT ON
THE HAPPY BECAUSE WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER.
AND I WANTED WITH THE ONE I
THINK THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF
LAST YEAR AS WELL AS THIS YEAR
FOR MAKING THAT POSSIBLE AS WELL
AND FINALLY TO THE WORKERS.
BOTH A CHECK IS HERE AS WELL AS
OTHERS THAT FROM AROUND THE
STATE AT THAT OF.
SPOKEN TO US AND SAY CENTERS
THEIR STORIES AND THEIR SUPPORT
IT MEANS LOTS I RESPECT GASTRO
AYE VOTE THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
SIR CHAIR. ALRIGHT AND I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THEME MANICURISTS I
DON'T HAVE A MOTION.
WE GIVE OUR THAT'S RIGHT YOU
MOVED IT. ALRIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NINE AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE KALRA.
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
WHY QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE ARAMBULA?
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
MOTOGP PUT A TO CARRY THE OF
THREE.
ALRIGHT WHEN WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS I'M SURE WE'LL BE
GETTING IT OUT THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I'M. MISTER SANTIAGO I
THINK IS STILL NOT HERE THE NEXT
PERSON IS A MISTER FONG.
AND LA I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING.
WITH THE STAFF YOU BOUGHT US A
REAL PROBLEM. AND I THINK WE'VE
GOTTA. SOMETHING THAT I HOPE
BECOMES A REAL SOLUTION AFFECTED
AS CHAIR.
I THINK MR MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL HELL BE ACCEPTING
THE MINUTES REFLECTED THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
BOB AND AGAIN MISTER CHAIR I
GREATLY APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN YOUR GUIDANCE ON THIS
MATTER. AB TWENTY SIX OF SIX WAS
STREAMLINED A HAZARDOUS WASTE
PERMIT RENEWAL PROCESS FOR
FACILITIES THAT HAVE NO
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES. AND PLACES
CAPS ON PERMIT FEES DEPENDING ON
THE TYPE OF FACILITY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC AND
SUBSTANCES TO CONTROL HAS BEEN
FACING A SEVERE BACKLOG THE
PROCESS FOR THE FACILITY
PERMITS.
IN PARTICULAR ANNUAL PERMITS
AS A RESULT MANY FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN OPERATING UNDER EXPIRED
PERMITS.
UP.
ADDITIONALLY THE COST TO RENEW
THESE FEES HAVE SKYROCKETED
CREATING UNCERTAINTY FROM
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS AS WELL
AS PRIVATE INDUSTRY A IN MY
DISTRICT THE NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION CHINA LAKE. IS ONE SUCH
CASE.
A TITLE LIKE IT'S OUR NATION'S
PREMIER RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT
TEST AND I WOULD CONSIDER FOR
EXISTING AND FUTURE WEAPON
SYSTEMS.
IT UP.
BUT THIS INSULATION IS PARAMOUNT
FOR NATION'S SECURITY HIS
FREQUENT USE BY OUR ALLIES
AROUND THE WORLD. FOR THE PAST
SIX YEARS CHINA LAKE HAS BEEN
OPERATING WITH AN EXPIRED
PERMIT.
THIS IN SPITE OF THE FACT THAT
THE MISSION OF CHINA LAKE HAS
NOT CHANGED IN THE FACILITY HAS
MAINTAINED FOR COMPLAINTS.
BUT CERTAINLY TRAVIS AIR FORCE
BASE HAS BEEN SEEN ITS COSTS FOR
RENEWAL PERMITS GO FROM THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO OVER
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A NEARLY TENFOLD
INCREASE EVEN OF THE FACILITY.
HAS NOT MADE ANY MAJOR CHANGES
AND HAS AN EXEMPLARY COMPLAINTS
RECORD.
THIS BILL CREATED STREAMLINED
AND MARK FISHER PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR FACILITATOR LAKE AND
TRAVIS AIRFORCE BASE.
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THE
GREAT WORK WE'VE DONE ON THIS
BILL WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE ULTIMATELY
HAVE A VIABLE SYSTEM THAT
ENABLES FACILITIES TO HANDLE
WASTE. WITH THE HIGHEST DEGREE
OF PROTECTION FOR THE PUBLIC AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.
I WITH ME TODAY TO SATISFY
SUPPORT IS RENTAL FRIEDMAN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE US DEPARTMENT THE NAVY
SOUTHWEST DIVISION.
ALRIGHT.
FOUR MINUTE SHOWER TO REACH
UNLESS YOU WANTED DIVIDED UP
DIFFERENTLY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD CHAIR QUIRK
MEMBERS I AM RANDALL FRIEDMAN
AND I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
SEVEN MILITARY HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA.
EACH OF OUR PERMITTED FACILITIES
INCLUDING THE ONE IN THE AUTHORS
DISTRICT PERFORM VITAL FUNCTIONS
TO SUPPORT OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
MISSION.
THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
INVITED US TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION ON OUR EXPERIENCES
WITH OUR EFFORTS TO RENEW OUR
HAZARDOUS WASTE PERMITS.
IN DOING SO WE TALKED ABOUT THE
NEED FOR A PROCESS ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT THE AMENDED
VERSION OF THIS BILL DIES.
AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE.
OF THE CONCERN PLAN COULD BE
SUPPORTED MORE BROADLY.
IT ENSURES THAT A FACILITY ONLY
QUALIFIES FOR THIS PROCESS IF IT
HAS SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION. TO
YEARS PRIOR TO EXPIRATION. HAS
HAD NO SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES IN
OPERATIONS HAS HAD NO
OUTSTANDING COMPLIANCE ISSUES
AND HAS NOT HAD SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC CONCERNS.
THIS BILL INCENTIVIZE IS GOOD
BEHAVIOR.
MANY HAVE COMMENTED THE
ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE PROCESS
IS BROKEN.
COMMITTEE STAFFS PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS PROVIDE A STRATEGY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN THE TNC.
TO REWARD GOOD COMPLIANCE WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
GOOD. THE GOOD ACTORS TO PROCEED
IN A STREAMLINED FASHION WHILE
ENABLING DGSE TO FOCUS THEIR
ATTENTION ON MORE COMPLEX AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY CHALLENGING
FACILITIES.
I WOULD ADD HERBS TO THEIR AD
STAFF ANALYSIS TRAVIS AIRFORCE
BASE IS CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF RENEWING THEIR APPLICATION.
AND IS CONTINUING WORK WITH DTS
SEE ON A REVIEW OF THEIR COST
ESTIMATE. IN CONCLUSION THAT
DEPARTMENT DEFENSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE ALICE'S WE THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US.
X..
TO CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CHRIS MAUER ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
HARBORS TO SAFETY CLEAN WHICH
TOGETHER OWN AND OPERATE
FOURTEEN FACILITIES PERMITTED IN
CALIFORNIA. ADJUST TO ECHO
MISTER FRIEDMAN'S COMMENTS.
I THINK THAT THAT THE BILL AS
PROPOSED HE MEANT IT IS A GOOD
FIRST STEP MOVING FORWARD.
TOWARDS OUR.
A REJECTING SOME FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY BACK INTO THE.
PERMITTING PROCESS YEAH I
APPRECIATE. MR FUNG'S LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IN YOUR LEADERSHIP AS
WELL MISTER CHAIR I KNOW WE'VE
HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS OVER
THE PAST YEAR ON THIS ISSUE AND
I KNOW IT'S AND WE.
WE'VE CONVEYED YOU THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT DAT A ISSUE FOR OUR
FACILITIES SO OF A URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD. OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JEAN IRVINE REPRESENT WASTE
MANAGEMENT OTHER LICENSEES.
IT'S UNLIKELY MY CLIENTS AVAIL
THOUGH INVOKE THIS BUT IF WE
CAN.
CONSERVE RESOURCES IN ONE AREA
AND CONCENTRATED IN THE HARDER
PERMITS
PERHAPS WE ALL BENEFIT SO WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN.
JOHN KEPT HIM Q. CAP CAN ASSIST
IT'S ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
SENSATIONAL SINCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AT A RALLY WITH
CAL CHAMBER WE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
VERY GOOD.
ALL OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS IN ON RACE POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. AYE WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED.
THAT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW. A
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITY
APPLICATIONS TO BYPASS NORMAL
DTS HE REVIEW ON A VERY. SHORT
TIME FRAME.
THE EXISTING BACKLOG OF THE
PERMITTING MAKES A NINETY DAY
REVIEW.
PROCESS AND WHAT WE'VE CHANGED
THAT.
IT'S NOT A NINETY DAY REVIEW
PROCESS.
A PROCESS NOW THAT WE'VE AGREED
TO IS FOR THE GOOD ACTORS WHO
HAVEN'T HAD PROBLEMS.
THAT IF THEY SUBMIT A.
TOM
TWO YEARS IN ADVANCE THEY SUBMIT
THE RENEWAL.
THE AGENCY THEN HAS UP UNTIL SIX
MONTHS PASSED THE RENEWAL.
TO.
APPROVE IT. NOW CLEARLY.
IF.
THEY HAVEN'T GONE ALL THROUGH
ALL THE PROCEDURES THERE WOULD
THEN BE A LAWSUIT.
SO THEY ARE DEFINITELY.
IF THEY'RE GONNA FINISH THEY
HAVE DO IT RIGHT.
JUST SAINTS OF THE NINETY DAYS
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY THERE.
THE DIFFICULTY WITH THAT WAS
THAT EVEN IF FOR NINETY YEARS IF
THAT'S NOT DONE RIGHT.
PERMIT ISN'T GONNA STAND
SO WE ASSUME THAT.
A PERMIT WILL BE DONE CORRECTLY
AND WE'RE GET BASICALLY GIVING
PEOPLE TWO AND A HALF YEARS NOT
NINETY DAYS SO IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT. THAN THE ORIGINAL
BELL THANK YOU SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OTHER REMAIN THE SAME
ARM WHEREBY WHEN YOU ALLOW.
WHEN YOU ALLOW DTS CD OR YOU
FORCE THE TSC TO APPROVE A
PERMIT WHEN IT DOESN'T ACT IN A
TIMELY FASHION THE LOSE IN THAT
CASE ARE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
LIVE BY THESE FACILITIES.
WE NEED THOROUGH REVIEW IN EVERY
CASE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT DTS
HE HAS A PROBLEM
WITHIN WITH MAKING TIMELY
DECISIONS.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT A.
THAT THIS BILL.
ADDRESSES THE RIGHT PROBLEM
ON.
SO.
WE WOULD URGE THAT THERE BE MORE
CONSIDERATION ON HOW TO
INCENTIVIZE DTS  TO MAKE
TIMELY DECISIONS.
INCLUDING AND UP TO AT AB
ABOARD AN APPEALS MORE THAT CAN
REVIEW THESE TYPES OF DECISIONS
THAT THEY'RE NOT MADE IN A
TIMELY FASHION. BUT SIMPLY
ALLOWING A A FACILITY PERMIT TO
BE GRANTED WHEN DTC FAILS ACT IN
A TIMELY FASHION. AGAIN DOESN'T
NECESSITATE ARM OR OR REQUIRE
THE COMPLEX TECHNICAL REVEAL
ALWAYS TO BE COMPLETED AND
THAT'S THE CONCERN IS WENDY
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE THE TIME
TO DO THAT FOR WHATEVER REASON
AND MAINLY YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU
CAN SEE. HAS SOME PROBLEMS ARM
YOU KNOW WE STILL NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT REVIEW IS BECAUSE
IS IS COMPLETE ARM AND THAT
COMMUNITIES NEARBY THESE
FACILITIES ARE COMPLETED. I'M WE
ALSO. HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE AT
CAP FOR THE COSTS
ON THAT PROVIDES A WINDFALL TO
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES
WHEN WE SAY THAT. DID YOU SEE
CANNOT CHARGE OVER CERTAIN
AMOUNT I AGREE THAT YES YOU HAVE
TO BE MORE CONSCIOUS OF. A OF OF
ITS COSTS IN CONTAINING THOSE
BUT BY PUTTING AND. AN ABSOLUTE
CAP ON YOU EXIT PASS THE COST
ONTO THE TAXPAYERS WINDY TSC
DOES INEVITABLY ARM HAVE COSTS
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN THE CAP
PROVIDED IN THIS BILL.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNA
BASKETS I'M HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ARMS TO SLIDE CENTER
DEATHLY ONE ALLY MY COMMENTS TO.
THAT WHICH IS STATED BY INGRID
BUT ALSO LOOKING FORWARD TO
REALLY CONTINUE THIS COMPETITION
IF THE BILL MOVE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE I'M GIVEN THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS TO HAVE TO REALLY
LOOK AT A COMPREHENSIVE REFORM.
NOT JUST LOOKING AT A
SPECIFICALLY THE CAPS OR THE
APPLICATION PROCESS OF PERMITS
HAVE PERMITS ARGUMENT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT THERE'S A LOT OF MORE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
IN THERE'S OTHER BILLS IN THE
SKY IN THIS HOUSE THAT WE'RE.
WORKING WITH AND ALSO IN THE
SECOND HOUSE SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THE STUFF.
VERY GOOD OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
A MORENO ON BEHALF OF CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE REASONS
STATED EMPHASIZED BY THE
SPEAKERS AYE WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
I HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT WHAT THE
SENATE FROM BERMAN HEALTH BE
POSSIBLE.
LEAVE THAT BADLY BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ANDREA ENTERWITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN OPPOSITION
.
ALL RIGHT.
WHICH IS HAVING BEEN HEARD.
OF WE WILL THEN.
ASK IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
I MISSED FONG AYE.
HAVE QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE.
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
GROUPS.
.
IT LOOKS LIKE A.
THE PERMITS WOULD BE OBTAINED
APPROVED ACTUALLY THAT'S NOT THE
CASE IT WOULD NOT BE DEEMED
APPROVED WE GIVEN THE DEADLINE
BUT IT'S NOT DEEMED APPROVED.
IT WAS A LIMITS ACCEPTED YEAH
AND SO IT DOES NOT SEEM TO
PROVE.
IT THE PROCESS WILL CONTINUE IF
IT HAS TO.
BUT WE'VE GIVEN THEM THE
DEADLINE WITH THE HOPE THAT THEY
WILL MAKE.
BUT THERE WOULD BE NO POINT EVEN
IF YOU MADE IT NINETY NINE
YEARS.
OF DEEMED APPROVED BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T FOLLOW THE PROCESS.
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO GET UP
BEING SUED AND THE PERMIT ISN'T
WORTH THE PAPER IT'S WRITTEN ON.
SO THERE IS NO DEEMED APPROVED
ON BUT WE'RE GIVING THEM THE
DEADLINE.
AND WE'RE HOPING THEY'LL MEDIA
WE WE WHEN YOU GIVE THIS TO
PEOPLE IT'S.
IT GETS THEM EXCITED.
SO THE OTHER QUESTION WAS ABOUT
THE FEES THERE IS A NUMBER IN
HERE.
ARE WE ARE NOT EXPERTS ENOUGH TO
KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING ON
THAT. OTHER WILL BE A CAP AND I
THINK THAT IS FAIR OF THAT
NUMBER IS GOING TO BE DETERMINED
WHEN THE BILL IS IN
APPROPRIATIONS ARE WELL MISTER
CHAIR I'M I'M READING FROM THE.
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS HERE IN IT.
TALKS ABOUT PROVIDING FOR A
PERMIT TO BE DEEMED APPROVED
THAT IS NO LONGER AB THAT'S NO
LONGER GO OKAY HAVE YOU EVER
FIVE I CAN REFER YOU TO PAGE SIX
OF THE CAMINO HOUSES YOU'LL DEAL
NOTICED THE AMENDMENTS. ON PAGE
THREE WE STRIKE TWENTY EIGHT TO
FOUR LINES TWENTY TO FORTY WE'VE
INSERTED BY THE AMENDED THE
AMENDMENTS PROVIDED BY THE
COMMITTEE YEAH.
I HAVE TO ADMIT.
MUST SHARE I'M NOT SURE WHAT
I'M VOTING ON HERE AND I MAY
HAVE TO TING OF THAT'S OUR.
I. I CAN ASSURE YOU DEEMED
APPROVED EVEN IF IT WERE IN THE
BILL WOULDN'T WORK.
BECAUSE IT WOULD JUST GO TO A
LAWSUIT CHAU THAT'S WHY WE TOOK
IT OUT I CAN ASSURE YOU OF THAT
THAT THERE THERE'S A THERE IS A
STREAMLINED RENEWAL APPLICATION
PROCESS. A BUT IT A BUT THE MEN
THAT WAS THE MINUTES WERE
PROVIDED BY THE COMMITTEE.
SHARE.
ALRIGHT YOU CAN DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION GO AHEAD I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MISTER FINE
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AS A NAVY VETERAN I
WANT TO THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR SAVING THIS BILL FOR WHEN I
ARRIVED TO THIS COMMITTEE.
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
I THINK IT SEEMS THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION AS TO HOW BEST
TO IMPLEMENT THIS TYPE OF POLICY
IN THE AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO STRIKE HIM ADD. A
REASONABLE BALANCE I THINK I'M
WITH THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION AND THE NEEDS OF THE
NAVY AND SOME OF THE SITES I AM
SO WITH THAT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO MAKE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SECOND.
ALRIGHT IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED. OF ANYONE ELSE
ALRIGHT MR FUNG YOU MAY CLOSE AS
WELL THINK THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAIR FOR THE WORKING AS WE
CONTINUE FORWARD I CHECK THE
* WHEN I GO. YES SO.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF.
A REAL PROBLEM.
AND WE DIDN'T FEEL THAT THE
FIRST SOLUTION WOULD WORK WE DO
HAVE SOMETHING WHICH WE BELIEVE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY AS
THEY LEARN MORE ABOUT IT.
WILL FIND ACCEPTABLE AGAIN
DEEMED APPROVED IS OUT.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS THE%
PROCESS HAS TO FINISH
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE.
WE GIVEN THE DEADLINE BUT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT SAYS IT
SCHEME TO PROVE BECAUSE IT WOULD
MAKE NO SENSE.
ARM ON THE OTHER HAND BY GIVING
THE DEADLINE BY HAVING THE.
GOOD ACTORS.
GO AHEAD AND JUST TO SPEAK TO
CHINA LAKE WHEN I WAS AT
LAWRENCE LAB WE WORKED WITH THEM
IN DEVELOPING HIGH EXPLOSIVES.
THEY ARE SHIP SHAPE
AND YEAH YEAH SOMEONE LIKE THIS
I HAVE GREAT FAITH FAN AND IF
ANYONE CAN USE THIS PROCESS IT
SHOULD BE CHINA LAKE.
THAT BEING SAID.
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY SIX ZERO SIX UPON. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE.
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I
BUT IT'S WHAT SHE.
USUALLY FOR
WE HAVE THREE.
ALRIGHT WHEN WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS.
WE WELL I BRING THE BILL UP
AGAIN THANKS YEAR.
I WISH MISTER SANTIAGO.
SO GOOD TO SEE.
ROOM.
MY SEAT MATE.
ASSEMBLY MEN ARE SANTIAGO YOU.
.
SHALL GO FORWARD.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
I'D LIKE TO BE BRIEF THAT'S OKAY
OF THE CHAIR.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU THIS IS AN EXTENSION
OF OUR WORK ON EXCITE.
AND THE CLEANING OR I OF THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES ARE WE
SEEK TO APPROPRIATE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS A TO DO THE PARK
WHERE HE'S A WHICH WAS NOT
CAPTURED THE ORIGINAL HUNDREDS
ANY SIX NINE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
DO TWO YEARS.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR OF YOUR
COMMITTEES UP HELP ON MAKING
THIS A BETTER BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
THAT.
VERY GOOD.
OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BILL WILEY O. ENVIRONMENT
WORKING GROUP MEETING GET AN
OFFICIAL OF LETTERING AND
SUPPORT BUT WE WILL BE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AS WE ALL KNOW THE PROBLEMS THAT
SIDE ON THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY PACKS.
THANK YOU. BOB OTHERS IN THE.
SUPPORT THERE BEING NONE ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT ARM QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
FORGET.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
SIR YOU MAY CLOSE ARE EXPECT
LESS FOR MY VOTE.
EXCITED BEEN ONE OF THE WORST
DISASTERS WE'VE EVER HAD.
THIS BILL. WOULD HELP CLEAN UP
AREAS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
INCLUDED.
I CONSIDER IT THERE ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE
THIS FORWARD TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE SANTIAGO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
BUT TO CHANGE.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
SIR FOR VOTES AND GRADUATION
JUBILANT TAP.
FIRST ONE OF THE DAY.
ALRIGHT.
A WEEK THEN HAVE MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
AS AN ALUMNI OF THIS COMMITTEE.
WELL LA WE'LL GIVE YOU SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND IF
I MAY SAY I MISS ALL YOU VERY
DEARLY. BUT I HAVE SOME WITHOUT
BEEN MORE THE FIRST BILL MY
POSITION AND
RICHARD DO A MUCH BETTER JOB.
WAS CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR A TIME EIGHTY TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT AUTHORIZED
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO STEP SHOULD
GRANT PROGRAM.
RIGHT FUNDING TO PROPERTY OWNERS
FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF CORRODED
OR LET CONTAINING PLUMBING AND
SERVICE LINES ADVERSELY IMPACT
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS. IN
RECENT YEARS THERE HAS BEEN A
REPORTS OF DISCOLORED. AND LET
CONTINUE PIPES AND FIXTURES IN
PRIVATE HOMES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WATER OFFICIALS SAID THE PROBLEM
WAS CAUSED BY AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH SOME AREAS
HAVING WATER SAMPLES TEST
AT LEAD LEVELS ABOVE FEDERAL
THRESHOLD LEVELS.
AND NEED CORRECTIVE ACTION.
FOR CITIES WORK WITH PROPERTY
OWNERS TO ENCOURAGE CHANGES
THEIR PLUMBING WHEN THEY FOUND
THE SOURCE TO BE DISCOLORATION
THERE ARE FEW TO NO PROGRAMS.
EMPLACED ASSIST PROJECTS AIMED
AT IMPROVING WATER QUALITY ON
PRIVATE HOMES.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE FOR.
ESTABLISHED A PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
DANGEROUS WATER CONDITIONS
AND HOMES THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AS ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORK WITH ME
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
VERY GOOD.
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAILY
COVERAGE OF WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND WERE
ALSO HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE. SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IN THIS BILL
THOUGHTFULLY CREATES A PROGRAM
THAT ALLOW PEOPLE TO NOT ONLY
AFFORD SOMETHING THAT'S A HUGE
COST PERSONALLY. BUT ALSO ALLOW
THEM TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES TO
STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITY SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
OUR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD.
I WANT NOTHING ELSE.
THOUGHT YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECT RATS PRIVATE.
ALRIGHT THE DIFFICULTY HERE IS.
THAT THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
MONEY. I WILL WORK WITH YOU.
I TO FIND A WAY TO GET THAT
MONEY. I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. AND DAD LETS
TALK ABOUT.
WHETHER WE TRY TO GET THE MONEY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND OR SOME
SPECIAL PROGRAM I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THIS GO
FORWARD SO I THAT'S MY PROMISE
TO YOU.
OBVIOUSLY I'M RECOMMENDING AND
I.
ALRIGHT CHAIR.
THANK YOU ALL AND WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B.
TO SEVEN TO EIGHT CHEN. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
I.
ARAMBULA I'M.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
BUT IT'S A CHEAP.
WHAT'S A GI
THAT'S FOR.
CONGRATULATIONS YOU ARE OUT AND
WILL GET ADDITIONAL PEOPLE.
I'M SURE SUPPORTING IT AS TIME
GOES ON.
THANK YOU VIDAK THANK YOU.
A.
TIME FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CAN I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
MELENDEZ AND A SECOND BY MISTER
MERRETT YUCHI.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B. TWO FIVE
FOUR ONE SALAS IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WITH RECOMMENDED
CONSENT.
ALSO ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN. AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT CHEN IS
DO PASS AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
WITH RECOMMENDED CONSENT.
QUIRK.
WHY QUIRK I?
MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I.
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
WHAT AT SEARCHING?
WHAT A TO GI SO HAVE FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR?
VERY GOOD.
.
LET'S SEE MISS LOW MOAN I
BELIEVE IS NEXT AND THEN MISTER
DALI.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEMOND.
THINK HERE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE WOULD
PROVIDE LIABILITY PROTECTION FOR
OUR OWN HOMEOWNERS WHOSE HOMES
ARE CONTAMINATED WITH LEAD BASED
PAINT.
THIS WOULD ALLOW HOMEOWNERS TO
SEEK DAMAGES FOR CLEAN UP OR
OTHERWISE IMPLEMENT THEIR OWN
CLEANUP WITHOUT FEAR OF
LIABILITY LAWSUITS. EXPOSURE TO
LEAD TO LEAD THE CAN SERIOUSLY
HARM A CHILD'S HEALTH. EVEN A
SLIGHT ELEVATION IN BLOOD LEVELS
CAN REDUCE IQ AND SENT
DEVELOPMENT MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
ARE BEING DIAGNOSED AND EX BEING
EXPOSED TO LEAD IN THEIR HOMES
THROUGH AGING LEAD BASED PAINT.
INCREASING THEIR RISK FOR DAMAGE
TO THE BRAIN AND NERVOUS SYSTEM
SLOWED GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
LEARNING AND BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS
HEARING AND SPEECH PROBLEMS.
IN TWO THOUSAND A COMPLAINT WAS
FILED IN ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST THREE MAJOR
PAINT MANUFACTURERS THAT FOUND
THE FORMER LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROMOTING LEAD PAINT FOR USE IN
HOMES DESPITE THEIR KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE PRODUCT WAS HIGHLY
TOXIC.
IN SPITE OF THE COURT'S FINDING
THE PAINT MANUFACTURERS ARE
PROPOSING AN INITIATIVE FOR
NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
STATEWIDE BALLOT THAT WOULD
RELIEVE PAIN MANUFACTURES OF
VIABILITY. AND DO THE ACTIONS BY
MULTIPLE COURTS AND PUT THE SOUL
FINANCE RESPONSIBILITY ON
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS FOR
CLEANUP. LEAD CONTAMINATED
PAINT.
IF ENACTED THE INITIATIVE WOULD
COST TAXPAYERS THREE POINT NINE
BILLION. AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
THREE WILL ENSURE THAT
HOMEOWNERS HAVE LEAD BASED
PAINT.
THAT HAVE LEAD BASED PAINT
CANNOT BE SUED BY THE LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURERS IT ALSO. ENSURES
THAT THE LEAD PAINT AND PAINT
MANUFACTURERS REMAIN AND WILL
STILL BE LIABLE FOR THEIR LEAD
CONTAMINATION REGARDLESS OF
FAILURE.
OR PASSAGE OF THE INITIATIVE
BASED ON THE JUDGMENT OF THE
COURT THE SEEMS TO BE A
REASONABLE PROPOSAL. WITH ME
TODAY IS BILL ALLEY GOOD WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
TO SPEAK ON THE TEXAS TALKS JUST
TALKS
IT'S CITY. ASPECTS OF LET.
I BILL ALLEY OPEN WITH EWG THAT
WERE NOT FORMALLY LISTEN IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT WE WILL BE ALONG
WITH OTHERS IN A COALITION. THAT
ARE.
WORKING AGAINST THE INITIATIVE
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REFERENCE TO END OF FOR A
PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT IS OUR
AYE.
OF SIN NOT HAVE A SYNOPSIS IN
YOUR.
ANALYSIS FOR THIS BILL
INCLUDING ONE BY THE CHAIR.
WE ARE OF A.
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS PACKAGE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT LED TO AN
ANY LEVEL. IS HIGHLY TOXIC IN
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
ACCORDING TO SEVERAL.
ESTABLISHED HELP ORGANIZATIONS.
DE INITIATIVE THAT.
THE MEMBERS TALKING ABOUT IS
INTERESTING IN THAT IT WOULD SAY
THAT IT REDEFINES LEAD IS NOT A
PUBLIC NUISANCE WHICH IS
EXACTLY.
THE TERM OF ART THAT THEY LOST
ON IN COURT SO THAT'S ONE THING
WE'RE FIGHTING AGAINST AND THEY
WANT TO SAY THE HOMEOWNERS CAN
BORROW MONEY TO CLEAN UP LEAD
WHEN THEY BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
GET OFF THE HOOK.
THE PACKAGE OF BILLS INCLUDING
THIS ONE WILL HELP ENSURE THE
HOMEOWNERS ARE PROTECTED IN
TERMS OF LIABILITY. AND WE GET
THE MONEY GOING IN FLOWING TO
CLEAN UP THIS HISTORIC LEAD
PROBLEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR OUR NEXT WITNESS.
IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DON KEPT HE WITH MCCUE
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE HOMES
WITH INTERIOR LEAD BASED PAINT
HAVE BEEN BEEN PROPERLY
MAINTAINED AN INTACT HAVE NOT
BEEN CONSIDERED HAZARDOUS.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF A RECENT
COURT RULING ALL HOMES WITH
INTERIOR LEAD BASED PAINT ARE
NOW DEEMED PUBLIC NUISANCE AS
WAS NOTED. BETWEEN THE COURT
RULING AND THE PROVISIONS OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE CMT IS
CONCERNED THAT WERE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE
DONE THE RIGHT THING. LAYERING
THE COURT CASE DEMAND SUCH HOMES
WITH US PUBLIC NUISANCES WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT OF THREE THAT WOULD MAKE
SUCH HOMES HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITES.
IS CONCERNING AS WE DON'T
BELIEVE IT HAS ANY BENEFIT FOR
HOMEOWNERS IN FACT SEE MTA'S
HIGHLY CONCERNED THAT ACTUALLY
EXACERBATES AND ORDER IT ALREADY
PROBLEMATIC SITUATION.
FOR MANY FAMILIES HAVE PROPERLY
MAINTAIN THEIR HOMES THEY WILL
BE DOUBLY PENALIZED BY THE COURT
RULING AND ITS IMPLICATIONS AS
WELL AS AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE
D. MEAN THEIR HOME A HAZARDOUS
WASTE SITE.
WELL THE BILL INTENDS TO PROVIDE
LIABILITY PROTECTION FOR THESE
HOMEOWNERS RUFF'S HOUSE HAVE
SUCH HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE HOMES.
IT IS AT THE SAME TIME
DECIMATING PROPERTY VALUES FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE SPENT THEIR LIVELIHOODS
TRYING TO AFFORD A HOME IN AN
ALREADY COSTLY I'M STATE FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
FURTHER WHAT ABOUT THE LANDLORDS
AND THAT A CHECK I AM HAVE NOT
PROPERLY MAINTAINED THEIR HOMES
AND PREPARE THEIR PROPERTIES AND
WORKFARE WHO ARE FAILING TO DO
SO WHO IN FAILING TO DO SO. ARE
ACTUALLY THE REAL PROBLEM
EXPOSING THE RANCHERS TO
PROPERLY MAINTAIN LEAD BASED
PAINT. AB TWENTY DOES THREE AND
THE LIABILITY PROTECTION WILL BE
EXTENDED TO THOSE NEGLIGENT
LANDLORDS AS WELL AYE WHICH
RAISES ADDITIONAL CONCERNS.
ULTIMATELY SANTEE BELIEVES THAT
THE COURT'S FINDING OF PUBLIC
NUISANCE AS A HOST OF NEGATIVE
IN CHALLENGING IMPLICATIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA. BUT AB
TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE YOUTHS
PERFORMANCE YOU'VE USED ABOUT
THREE MINUTES I'M WRAPPING IT
DOES IDEA I. OBESE MEN WANNA
HEAR FROM YOUR WITNESSING HERE
CMJ LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DIALOGUE ABOUT A GOOD
SOLUTION NOT TO THE CONCERNS OF
THE LEGISLATURE BUT MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU.
I WILL MAKE UP FOR LOST TIME IN
HIS LIFE REMARKS QUITE SHORT
AGAIN ANTHONY SAMPSON. OUT HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SO OUT I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE ALL OF THE
UNDERSTANDING NOW THAT WE HAVE A
A DECISION ON RECORD. THAT
DECLARES ITS PUBLIC NUISANCE THE
HOMES WITHIN THE ELEVEN
JURISDICTIONS.
SUBJECT TO THE SENATE CAR CLARA
COUNTY CASE.
AND SO WHAT WE ARE NOW GOING TO
SEE WITH THIS LEGISLATION AS
MISS KEPT HE POINTED OUT IS THAT
THOSE HOMES AS SUBJECT TO THAT
CASE IN ADDITION TO EVERY OTHER.
HOME IN CALIFORNIA WITH LEAD
BASED PAINT WOULD BE.
DECLARED A SUPERFUND SITE.
WITHIN THE LAW.
SO IT'S.
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS
COMMITTEE NEED THAT'S THE
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER THAT.
THE REMEDIATION EFFORTS THAT
WILL BE DONE PURSUANT. TO THE
CASE AS PUBLIC NUISANCES AT THAT
ON TOP OF THAT HAVE DTS SEE.
HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER REMEDIATION
FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT SIXTY PERCENT OF. HOMES
BUILT BEFORE NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ARE PRESUMED TO HAVE LEAD
BASED PAINT.
IS THE TYPE OF PUBLIC POLICY
THAT WE WANT TO PURSUE
PARTICULARLY WITH ALL THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND ELSEWHERE. WITH
RESPECT TO TSC HAVING.
TROUBLE MAINTAINING ITS CURRENT
A SUITE OF SUPERFUND SITES
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ARM GO AHEAD MR MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU I OF.
HAVE QUESTIONS TO THE OPPONENTS
I MEAN. MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
BILL IS AT THIS.
THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF THE BILL IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE HOMEOWNER
IS NOT HELD LIABLE. FOR THE.
LEAD PAINT MANUFACTURERS KNOWING
USE OF THEIR PRODUCT AND HOMES
BY.
DON'T SEE.
A GUY I DON'T REALLY.
HERE EITHER OF YOU ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE.
SO THE BILL I AM DOES CERTAINLY
SPEAK TO LARGELY THE LIABILITY
FACTOR FOR HOMEOWNERS BUT
ADDITIONALLY AS THE WAY THE BILL
IS CONSTRUCTED IN AND AROUND.
THE HAZARDOUS GUYS SUBSTANCE
ACCOUNT ACT ALSO IN DOING SO.
DESIGNATES THESE HOMES ALLIES
HAZARDOUS WASTE SUPERFUND SITES
AND SO IT'S THE COMBINATION OF
THE PUBLIC NUISANCE COURT
RULING.
AT THAT ALREADY IS BECAUSE IT IS
BASICALLY DEEMING THOSE HOMES A
PUBLIC NUISANCE YOU UP ON TOP OF
THAT THE FACT THAT.
UNDER THIS BILL AYE THOSE HOMES
WOULD ALSO BE CONSIDERED
SUPERFUND SITES SO FROM A
HOMEOWNER PERSPECTIVE AS WELL
YOU'RE ALSO HAVING IMPLICATIONS
FOR PROPERTY VALUES.
AND.
AN INTERN AS WELL WITH
HOMEOWNERS HAVE MEAN LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS PERHAPS YOU KNOW
THERE'S A CONVERSATION TO BE HAD
AROUND NEAR THE SUBSET OF
HOMEOWNERS WHO'VE DONE THE RIGHT
THING. PEERING COMPASS SEEN
EVERYONE INCLUDING LANDLORDS WHO
HAVE MAY HAVE BEEN NEGLIGENT AND
ULTIMATELY OVERLAIN ALL OF THIS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOMEOWNERS
AND WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE THEIR
HOMES DEEMED SUPERFUND SITES.
AND EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE BEEN
PROP DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT IN
TERMS OF PROPERLY MAINTAINING
THEIR HOMES MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S NO CHIPPING IN ON THE
WALLS OF THE OF THEIR PAINT. AND
WHAT HAVE YOU SO THE COMBINATION
OF ALL OF THAT BUT THIS BILL IS
NOT MAKING HOMES A SUPERFUND
SITE DOES THE COURT. DECISION
AND SO THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT HOMEOWNERS ARE
NOT HELD LIABLE.
SO THOUGH QUIRK HE SAYS I
UNDERSTAND IT ACTUALLY DEEMS ARE
THE HOMES PUBLIC NUISANCES I
WHICH IS SEPARATE AND APART FROM
JEANNINE AND MANKIND SUPERFUND
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES WHICH
UNDER THE CONSTRUCTED THIS BILL.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
BILL ACTUALLY DEALS WITH THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE SUPERFUND
COMPONENT. PUBLIC NUISANCE
PIECES A SEPARATE PEACE DEALT
WITH BY THE COURT SO IT'S TWO
SEPARATE COMPONENTS. THAT WHEN
PAIRED TOGETHER EXACERBATING THE
CHALLENGES FOR HOMEOWNERS
RELATIVE TO PROPERTY VALUES AND
IMPLICATIONS FOR ABOUT SO WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE DISCUSSION
RELATIVE TO KIND OF LIABILITY
PROTECTION. ON IT IT'S NOT JUST
THE CONCERNED AT THE CHALLENGES
WITHOUT IT'S ACTUALLY THE FACT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSE
IT IS WASTE SITES NOW. RELATIVE
TO THESE HOMES AND AS WE KNOW IN
CONSUMERS AND HOME PRICES ARE
NOT.
AT FOUR DOUBLE IN MOST PARTS OF
THE STATE AND SO WHEN YOU'RE
LAYING ARENA PUBLIC NUISANCE
DESIGNATION FOR THESE HOMES.
WHICH IS ALREADY GOING TO
INEVITABLY IMPACT HOMES HOME
VALUES AND IMPLICATIONS FROM
THAT. AS WELL AS ON TOP OF THAT
LAYER IN THE FACT THAT THESE
WOULD NOW BE SUPERFUND SITE
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES EUROPE
FURTHER COMPOUNDING THE FACT
THAT THE HOMEOWNERS VALUE IN
THEIR HOME. WHEN THEY GO TO SELL
THEY HAVE TO REPORT THAT AS PART
OF THERE'D BE TERMS ANOTHER SALE
AND THAT'LL IN INEVITABLY IMPACT
OKAY ABOUT LET ME JUST INTERVENE
HERE. SO THEY ALREADY HAVE TO
SAY IF THEY HAVE LEAD PAINT.
THEY AREN'T WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
IT'S BEEN DECLARED A PUBLIC
NUISANCE WHAT THE BILL IS DOING
IS SAYING THAT. THE HOMEOWNERS
NOT RESPONSIBLE.
I IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS THE SUPERFUND FOUGHT
SITE AT THIS POINT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWPOINTS. THIS IS
GOING TO JUDICIARY NEXT IN
SHOULD I GO OUT THE COMMITTEE.
ARM THE LEGAL IMPLICATIONS OF
THAT CAN BE DEALT WITH IN
JUDICIARY WE DO NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN THIS COMMITTEE SIDE
RATHER NOT. RATHER YOU YOU TOO
CAN JUST AGREE TO DISAGREE AND I
CAN WAIT FOR JUDICIARY TED TO
GIVE US THAT.
IF THEY ARE SUPERFUND SITES I'M
SURE THAT THE AUTHOR WILL WILL
DEAL WITH THAT AT THE TIME.
SO WE WILL WE WILL LEAVE THAT UP
TO THEM.
OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE MUSLIM ON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
VERY GOOD CHAU ARM.
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
WE PROTECT THE HOMEOWNERS
I HAVE HEARD YOUR CONCERNS FROM
THE OPPOSITION. AND DOES
CERTAINLY IF IF THEY'RE VALID
THESE ARE THINGS THAT THE AUTHOR
MUST ADDRESS.
AND.
.
TO ME.
THIS IS IT. YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
PASS THIS BILL NOW TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS.
AND DOES SO I WILL BE OUR JEANNE
AND I VOTE I'D LIKE A MOTION
FROM THE.
FROM THE MEMBERS.
MOVED BY MISTER MURATSUCHI
SECONDED BY.
MISTER HOLDEN.
ALRIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY DECISION I DO
PASS AND ONTO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY A MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM TEN AB TWO EIGHT
ZERO THREE LIAM ON. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSING RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELINDA SNOW ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDING MY.
BUT IT'S A CHEAP.
RIGHT SEARCH.
FOR TWO.
ALRIGHT YOUR BILL IS OUT WE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
ARE WE HAVE THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER MISTER DALI.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ARE.
AND STAFF.
.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL I MISS YOU
FROM MY DAYS ON THIS COMMITTEE.
THE MESSAGE THAT IS GREAT TO
HAVE ELEVEN THAT ANOTHER LAN
THIS WITH THIS TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL
THE.
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TWO RELATING TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE LITHIUM ION BATTERY
RECYCLING IN YOU AND REUSE.
THERE APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND THAT BIG VEHICLES
ON CALIFORNIA ROADS CURRENTLY
AND THAT NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO
CLIMB TO WELL OVER FOUR MILLION.
BY.
BY TWENTY THIRTY.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S NEW PLAN
MEMBERS A THAT'S A LOT OF NEW
BATTERIES.
A LITHIUM ION BATTERIES ARE SAID
TO HAVE A LIFESPAN OF A BETWEEN
TEN AND TWENTY YEARS WELL THAT
SOUNDS GOOD IT'S A LOT THAT IT'S
NECESSARY TO KNOW THAT THE HOLES
THE REST THE STORY.
SURE BATTERIES CAN LAST LONG IF
IT'S A FULLY CHARGED IT REMAINS
IDLE.
HOWEVER E. D. BATTERIES ARE
COULD HILLY CHARGED IN DEPLETED
EVERY TIME.
YOU DRIVE ONE.
IF YOU USE THE LIGHTS RADIO
WINCHELL Y. PROJECTS THAT
YOU'RE.
IT TAKES EVEN MORE A LIFE AWAY
FROM THE BATTERY THERE ARE MORE
THE MORE YOU CHARGING DEPLETE
THEM THE SHORTER THE LIFESPAN
BECOMES.
A MORE REGIONAL AVERAGES ABOUT
SEVEN TO TEN YEARS.
REGARDLESS OF THE LIFESPAN WE
STILL NEED TO TO HAVE A PLAN OF
DISPOSAL THESE BATTERIES SO WE
DON'T END UP WITH AN
ENVIRONMENTAL NIGHTMARE. AT LIKE
WE'VE HEARD IN THE. PAST COUPLE
BILLS WITH THE EXITE SITUATION.
EVEN KNOW EXCITED WITH A
MANUFACTURING PLANT.
IT'S STILL A A GROSS EXAMPLE OF
WHAT CAN HAPPEN IF WE DON'T HAVE
A PLAN AND I WANTED JUST TO TAKE
pREMEMBER. WHEN THE STATE PASSED
THE MTB  WHICH WAS TO HELP.
.
A CLEANER AIR WHILE CONTAMINATE
OUR GROUND WHAT THE SAME TIME.
AND THIS IS THIS BILL IS ALONG
THE SAME LINES OF WHY WE HAVE.
MINING RECLAMATION NATURAL USED
UP SULFIDES THAT DUMPED INTO
RIVERS BECAUSE WE DO NOT
MINDING.
.
SMART LAWS IN CALIFORNIA SO UP
MEMBERS I JUST SIMPLY ASKING FOR
A PLANT AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
TWO WILL TASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXICS SUBSTANCE CONTROL CAL
RECYCLED AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND OTHERS TO IDENTIFY
APPROACHES FOR THE REUSE AND
RECYCLE OF ELECTRIC LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES.
AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY.
IT FURTHER REQUIRES DGSE TO
DEVELOP A GRANT PROGRAM TO AID
THESE PROGRAM PROGRAMS AND CAL
RECYCLE DEVELOP A PROCESS FOR
CONSUMERS TO PROBABLY DISPOSE OF
THESE BATTERIES.
I LIKE TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING I
GRABBED IN THE HALLWAY.
HOW?
WHICH IS.
WHAT WE DO FOR RECYCLING
REGULAR BATTERIES THAT WE USE
EVERY DAY AND FLASHLIGHTS
CELLPHONES IN THE LIKES?
AND IT WILL BE HARD TO PUT A.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE IN THAT TO
CONTAINER AND BY THE WAY WE
DON'T HAVE.
A PLAN AND IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING WE KNOW THAT TO WE CAN BE
MOVING. UP FORWARD WITH THE
BATTERY STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA A
IT QUITE FRANKLY A LOT OF FOLKS
THINK WE CAN OFFSET THE GRID
WITH THE TIME USE OF BATTERY SO.
THIS IS A PROCESS TO START AFTER
GOING OUT TO A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO WITH ALL THESE BATTERIES. AND
WHAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL.
.
THE LIKELIHOOD IS OF SOMETHING
HAPPENING CONTAMINATE OUR
ENVIRONMENT SO I WOULD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
VERY GOOD NOT ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WELL I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
AS MUCH AS I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANKS FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD IN FOR BRINGING THE
VISUAL AIDS I LOVE THAT WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE SHOWN. A COMMITTEE
SO THAT'S GREAT.
AYE YOU.
YOU KNOW YOU HEAD ON OF REALLY
IMPORTANT SUBJECT THAT PERHAPS A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO GOT ABOUT
WHICH IS THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE ALL THESE BATTERIES
AND WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
THEM.
AND IT'S MAKES SENSE TO ME TO
TREAT THEM THE SAME WAY AS WE
TREAT THOSE TYPES OF BATTERIES
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S AND WHAT
KIND OF LEADING THE CHARGE OF
GETTING MORE PEOPLE WITH
ELECTRIC. VEHICLES OUT THERE AND
THEN WHAT WHAT HAD TO DO IT
THEMSELVES NO WE DON'T WANT
OTHER EXCITED I SITUATION
CERTAINLY SO AM I PLEDGE EFFORTS
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR THE
BELL AND WITH THAT I WILL MOVE
THE BILL.
VERY GOOD.
.
OTHER ITS JOB WAS MOVED AND
SECONDED ALREADY. UP THAT'S OK A
AT THE QUESTION ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
MISTER DALI.
DISRESPECT OUT FOR MY VOTE
MISTER CHAIRMAN RIGHT ARM I
THINK THE VICE I'M LOOKING FOR
CO AUTHORED BY THE WAY TAL YES.
I THINK THE VICE. MAY TEAR.
A.
SO FIRST OF ALL ARE I THINK THE
VICE CHAIR I ABSOLUTELY HATE IT
ON ON THE NAIL ON THE HEAD. AND
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD NOW IN THE
SAY. YOU KNOW A LOT OF THEIR
BILLS ARE BROUGHT TO US.
OUR THIS IS A BILL THAT DATA NO
OUTSIDE GROUP BROUGHT TO YOU YOU
BROUGHT IT. FORWARD YOURSELF I
HAVE MENTIONED SPEC FOR THAT.
MISTER CHANG I'M TOLD HAS A
SIMILAR BILL I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT
IT YET HOPEFULLY THE THREE FOUR.
LEASE THE TWO OF US AND YOU AND
MR TANG AND ANY OTHER CO
AUTHORS.
CAN GET TOGETHER I WILL ALSO
NOTE THAT HE HIM HE BEING CHAIR
OF BUDGET IS LIKELY TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE MONEY. ARE TO
ACTUALLY STUDY THIS PROGRAM SO
WE HAVE LESS OF A PROBLEM GOING
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS.
SO ALL IN ALL THIS CAN BE A WIN
WIN WIN AND WE CAN GET A LOT
DONE HERE.
I AND I'M REALLY EXCITED TO GO
FORWARD.
ALRIGHT ARE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
AND I WILL ASK THE SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO
VALLEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE.
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
BUT I TO CHEAT.
MATTEUCCI HIGH
CONGRATULATIONS SIR THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU.
I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY
WAITING OFFERS AUTHORS.
OF MR GARCIA IS NEXT IF HE COMES
OTHERWISE I'LL TAKE WHOEVER
COMES FIRST.
THEN.
WELL THE FIRST THING I WOULD
LIKE TO DO IS JUST FOR THE BILLS
ON CALL. OUGHT TO GO THROUGH
THOSE NOW
TO SEE IF WE CAN GET THEM OUT.
SO WHEN WE GO FOR THE BELLS ON
CALL FIRST.
WOMEN GOING ORDERS.
THESE OF THE BILLS ARE ON CALL.
ITEM ONE A. B.. TWENTY FIFTY
GLORIA DON'T.
NEED STILL NEEDS.
A MOTION AND A SECOND ON THIS
BILL
ALRIGHT.
MOTION BY MISTER HOLDEN.
SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN.
ALRIGHT MANY CHECKS SO ITEM ONE
AB TWENTY FIFTY CABALLERO THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO YOU'VE GOT ME I.
OKAY IT SAYS PLEDGES I'M SORRY
KIRK I'VE BACKWARDS. YEAH BUT IT
BUT WE'RE ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
WHAT?
FOR ONCE.
ALRIGHT.
AND THEN THE OTHER BILLS ON
CALL.
VERY GOOD.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE KALRA. THE VOTES AT
THREE ZERO.
I DON'T WANNA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I SELECT ZEALOUS OUT
ZERO.
BILL IS OUT.
NUMBERS.
THE VOTES AT THREE ZERO. THIS IS
ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY SIX SO SIX.
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT.
ALRIGHT WE STILL NEED ONE THEN
ON.
HOW THAT MESSIAH FONG SPELL
OKAY?
THIS IS ITEM THREE. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE SANTIAGO THE
VOTES AT FOUR ZERO. ARAMBULA.
PEROT.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
FIVE.
VERY GOOD THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT CHEN.
VOTERS AT FOUR ZERO ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
FIVE ZERO PARENT GETS UP TO FIVE
ZERO MISTER BECAUSE SHE IS HERE
WE SHALL PROCEED THINKING WAS
CHAIRED COLLEAGUES. AB TWENTY
SIXTY AT BATS WATER PAYMENTS.
FOCUSES ON TWO SPECIFIC AREAS OF
ENSURING THAT.
.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR WATER
GENCIES.
ARE NOT TIED UP WITH THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS HE'S AND
ENSURES THAT THAT WE CAN USE THE
DOLLARS OFFICIALLY AFFECTED AND
EFFECTIVELY. COULD DRESS SOME.
A CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER IS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT THAT'S
THE. GIST OF THE BILL WE HAVE
SOME FOLKS HERE THAT WILL TALK
SPECIFICS.
RESPECT HE HAS FOR RIVAL.
ALRIGHT DEL IS MOVED AND
SECONDED.
ALRIGHT THOUGHT WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU OF MY
NAMES ARE NEWMAN I'M THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR.
AT RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION THAT WERE BASED ON
MY SACRAMENTO AND SERVE THE
THIRTEEN WESTERN STATES AND
DEVELOPING.
WATER AND WASTEWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND DROUGHT
THE WEST.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES THAT FACE.
CHALLENGES AND AND GETTING
PROJECTS DONE.
AND AND BEING ABLE TO PAY.
I ENGINEERING FIRMS AND OTHER
CONTRACTORS ON TIME AND AND CASH
FLOWING THAT ADVANCED.
PAYMENT WHILE THEY'RE WAITING
FOR.
.
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE STATE.
AS THIS BILL WOULD HELP.
ALLEVIATE THOSE THOSE PROBLEMS
AND WE HAVE.
SMALL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
COMING TO OUR US TO.
BORROW MONEY ON A REGULAR BASIS
WHILE THEY'RE WAITING.
REIMBURSEMENT FROM STATE
PROGRAMS OUT BECAUSE THEY GRANT
FUNDS TO START COMING OUT FAST
ENOUGH AND.
AGAIN THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS
TO ENSURE THAT ALLEVIATE THAT
CASH CRUNCH FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT THAT
THE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE.
THE INTENDED BENEFICIARIES OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THEM.
THE WAY THEY WERE DESIGNED.
SO BATTERED YOUR SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JESSIE SNYDER AND WITH SELF
HELP ENTERPRISES FROM. OUTSIDE
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WE SERVE
THE EIGHT COUNTIES OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WITH MANY OF THE
SAME SERVICES AS DOES OUR CA
SEAT NAMELY AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS WELL AS SUPPORT FOR DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY.
A WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN MANY PROJECTS.
BE DELAYED AT MORE DIFFICULT
THAT THEY NEED TO BE.
ORDER COMPLETELY DERAIL BECAUSE
OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES
TO RECEIVE PAYMENT FROM THE
STATE. WHICH OF COURSE
ULTIMATELY MEANS THAT A SMALL
WATER DISTRICT OR SEWER COMPANY
IT WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
CONTRACTORS TIMELY AND I'D SURE
I DON'T NEED TO EXPLAIN TO ANY
OF YOU. THE CONTRACTORS DON'T
LIKE THAT VERY MUCH YOU CAN
DISCOURAGE THEM FROM WORKING
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES ON SUCH
PROJECTS IT CAN EVEN AND UP IN
THE WALKING OFF THE JOB WHICH OF
COURSE RESULTS IN ADDITIONAL
LEGAL COSTS AND. A WHOLE
MOUNTAIN OF PROBLEMS AND WE
WOULD REALLY LOVE TO SEE
COMMUNITY PROJECTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE FOR THE SMALLEST POOREST
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE. ON BE
PAID IN A TIMELY MANNER SO AS
ALREADY MENTIONED THE THE FOLKS
WHO NEED THESE PROGRAMS THE MOST
CAN REALLY BENEFIT FROM THEM. AT
THANK YOU EVERITT PERJURE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
KRIS CONNOR PRISON THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND SPORT.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION SUPPORT.
GREAT.
.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SIR YOU MAY CLOSE I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THAT
STAFF WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL.
ALRIGHT WELL AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
BEING SO COOPERATIVE.
.
SOME BILLS JUST MAKE YOU FEEL
VERY GOOD AND YOU KNOW I COME
FROM AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE THESE
HUGE WATER DISTRICTS.
THEY CAN PAY THEIR FOLKS.
ARM THIS IS THIS IS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE AN EXTREMIST AND.
I THINK THAT HELPING.
PEOPLE IN THESE DISTRICTS IS ONE
OF THE REASONS WE'RE HERE SO
THANK YOU FOR BILL BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY YOU CAN CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWENTY SIXTY EDUARDO GARCIA. DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
I
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
BUT IT'S A CHEAP.
THEREFORE.
FORTY HAVE FOR CONGRATULATIONS
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON.
ALRIGHT.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE HAVE ANY
OTHER AUTHORS CHAU WELL NOW OAK
WELL LET'S JUST FINISH THE JOB.
THE OTHER ANY OTHER BILLS THAT
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE FOR VOTES.
YEAH ALRIGHT TO ALL OUR BILLS.
EXCEPT FOR A MISTER FARMS ARE
OUT SO FAR AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO VOTE ON
THEM.
THEREFORE IT IS TIME FOR OUR
KIDS ARE AROUND.
ARE A PINCH HITTER.
MISS FRIEDMAN TO GO FORWARD.
YEAH.
DID YOU HAVE A REASON THING THAT
WE DID YOU WANT TO GO THERE.
WELL IT'S FINE OKAY.
THANK YOU CHAIR QUIRK IN MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE CHAIR HAS STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR HELP WITH THIS BILL.
MEMBERS YOU ALL HAVE A COPY OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REFERRED.
OR REFERENCE IN THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS BEFORE YOU EVER HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS AT
THIS TIME. AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
EIGHT SIX TO CREATE A PATH FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO FOLLOW WHEN THEY
ARE INJURED BY WATER
CONTAMINATION THAT IS CAUSED BY
A CONSTRUCTION DEFECT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW AN
INDIVIDUAL TO BRING A CLAIM
WITHIN TEN YEARS OF DISCOVERING
THAT SUCH WATER CONTAMINATION
BECAUSE THEIR INJURY. UNDER
CURRENT LAW A PERSON THAT IS
HARMED AS A RESULT OF THE
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT CANNOT
PROCLAIM AND LESS THEY DO SO
WITHIN TEN YEARS OF THE
COMPLETION OF CONSTRUCTION.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF A STRUCTURE
BUILT IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
BEGINS LEACHING TOXIC CHEMICALS
INTO THE GROUNDWATER EVER NEARBY
NEIGHBORHOOD IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
ANYONE HARMED BY THAT
CONTAMINATION WOULD BE UNABLE TO
BRING A PERSONAL INJURY CLAIM
BECAUSE THE CONTAMINATION
OCCURRED TWENTY YEARS AFTER THE
STRUCTURE WAS COMPLETED.
THIS TEN YEAR TIMEFRAME IS
UNWORKABLE AN ARBITRARY GIVEN
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF WATER
CONTAMINATION IT CAN TAKE YEARS
IF NOT DECADES FOR SOME
CONTAMINANTS TO REACH AND
CONTAMINATE THE GROUND WATER
SUPPLY. THE LATENT NATURE OF
WATER CONTAMINATION SHOULD NOT
BE USED AS A COVER TO EXCLUDE EX
EVADE LIABILITY CALIFORNIA'S TO
CREATE A RICH A ROUTE FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND. INJURED BY
WATER CONTAMINATION TO RECOVER
FOR SUCH HARMS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD A WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON BECAUSE JONES THE
CIRCLE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY EIGHT TODAY.
THERE ARE LAWS IN PLACE TO
ADDRESSED AT CLEANING UP OF
CONTAMINATED WATER AND THERE ARE
LAWS TO DRESS UP PERSONAL AYE
THAT PERSONAL INJURY CLAIMS BUT
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED
THERE IS A GAP IN THOSE LAWS. UP
REGARDING THIS AND WORKABLE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
UNDER AB TWENTY SIX FORTY EIGHT
IMAGE WILL COMPARING A PERSONAL
INJURY CLAIM.
AFTER DISCOVERY THE
CONTAMINATION BROTHER THE
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT A THAT
CREATED THE WATER CONTAMINATION
AYE THIS WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO
GET THEIR DAY IN COURT AND OUT
BE COMPENSATED FOR THE HARMS IT
OCCURRED TO THEM. ATWATER
INTIMATIONS NECESSARILY A LATENT
OUR PROBLEM.
WE DON'T DISCOVER IT RIGHT AWAY
AND IT CAN TAKE YEARS TO HARM
PEOPLE I ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
SOMETHING THEY'RE JUST DRINKING.
OVER TIME.
SO DO THIS BILL WILL BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS GIVE
PEOPLE A DAY IN COURT I'M AND I
DID ALSO JUST WANT TO MENTION
WHERE THERE'S GOING TO BE BIGGER
FOCUS ON GROUNDWATER OUT WAS
THIS IMMIGRANT WATER MANAGEMENT
ACT PASSED AND WE'RE GONNA BE.
TRYING TO RELIEVE WE'RE GONNA BE
SEEING A LOT MORE THESE
CONTAMINATION ISSUES.
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT AS
THESE ISSUES ARE OR DISCOVER
WITH MORE FREQUENCY OUT WE ALLOW
FOR PEOPLE TO RECOVER FOR A THE
HARMS AGAINST THEM OUT WE URGE
AYE VOTES DAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LOW THE SENTRY VENTURA WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET A LETTER IN ON
TIME FOR THIS COMMITTEE HEARING
BUT WE DO SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
BECAUSE THEN WE ARE IF THERE'S
NO WARRANT SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR
FROM OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
.
A HALF FOUR MINUTES HAVE
PROBABLY TO EACH UNLESS YOU WANT
TO DIVIDE IT UP DIFFERENTLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS AARON CARRERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
INTENT BEHIND THE SPELL AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE BUT. AND AS OF
NOW WITH THE BILL IN PRINT OUR
LEADERSHIP IS DETERMINED THAT
THIS BILL IS A HOUSING KILLER WE
HAVE. GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THIS BILL WOULD PLAY OUT.
IN REALITY IN WHICH WE WORK
STRUGGLING TO REALLY IDENTIFY
EXACTLY THE DEFICIENCY IN
CURRENT LAW.
TO PREVENT PERSONAL INJURY
CLAIMS TO PROCEED BASED ON WHAT
WATER CONTAMINATION WE'D YOU
KNOW. IN NO WAY IS MEANT TO SAY
THAT WE DON'T THINK WATER
CONTAMINATION IS A PROBLEM.
BUT THERE'S CURRENT A CODE
SECTION THREE FORTY POINT EIGHT
OF THE CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE.
WHICH ALLOWS.
A GREAT LENGTH OF TIME FOR THE
DISCOVERY OF THE CUP WATER
CONTAMINATION THERE'S NO TIME
LIMIT. ON DISCOVERING THAT YOU
HAVE AN ILLNESS OR AN INJURY.
THERE'S NO TIME LIMIT.
TO DISCOVER THAT BECAUSE OF THAT
AND THERE'S NO TIME LIMIT ON
DETERMINING WHO'S TO BLAME. AND
THEN THERE'S A TWO YEAR STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS AFTER THAT POINT.
A FILED THE LAWSUIT
SO WE WE FEEL THAT THERE IS
EXISTING LAW SUFFICIENT ENOUGH
TO COVER THESE CLAIMS. A WE DO
INTEND TO KEEP WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE BUT AT THIS POINT
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IT. AS BEING
VERY DETRIMENTAL TO THE HOUSING
INDUSTRY DURING A THE HOUSING
CRISIS AT WORK CURRENTLY FACING.
MY NAME IS JERRY HERMAN I
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES.
.
INSERTION OF THE WORD PERSONAL
IS HELPFUL BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE LAW
DOESN'T APPLY TO PERSONAL INJURY
CASES NOW.
SO IT'S MERELY A I THINK
CODIFYING PERHAPS THE MARTINEZ
CASE.
WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE USE
OF THE EXPRESSION WATER
CONTAMINATION.
IS THAT IT ANY LEVEL.
.
AND IT COULD INCLUDE NATURAL
CONTAMINANTS.
DOES THIS IN ANY MANNER DISPOSE.
OR REDUCE THE CAUSATION.
I DON'T THINK IT DOES BUT IT
RAISES A HOST OF ISSUES THE
EXPRESSION WATER CONTAMINATION.
MAY OR MAY NOT INCLUDE.
SUBSTANCES THAT WE TYPICALLY
THINK OF AS HAZARDOUS.
PUT TOXIC IT'S JUST
CONTAMINATION SO I THINK THE
BILL NEEDS CONSIDERABLE
REFINEMENT AND THEN LASTLY AS
ALWAYS IS THE CASE.
WITH THESE TYPES OF STATUTES I
WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE ARE
NOT REVIVING ANY.
BECAUSE OF ACTION THAT HAS
OTHERWISE EXPIRED.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE BUT I NEED
TIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REFLECT. TO REFLECT ON THAT.
SO ON ON THAT BASIS IN THE
ABSENCE OF CONSIDERABLE
REFINEMENT WERE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
UP PLEASE STAY ARM AT THE YET WE
MAY HAVE QUESTIONS.
OF SO.
THERE BE NO OTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OUT QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT UP LET ME CONFIRM WITH
STEVE CONFER WITH STAFF FOR A
MINUTE AND THEN I'LL ASK YOU TO
CLOSE
.
ALRIGHT I'M YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA TOOK VERY
QUICKLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED FIRST
I APPRECIATE.
I THE OPPOSITION FOR WORKING
WITH US AND COMING HERE WERE
VERY COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS YOU HAVE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THE BILL WOULD OF FACTS
ARMED RESIDENCES. I I CAN'T
THINK OF TIMES WHEN A
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT CAUSES WATER
CONTAMINATION FROM A RESIDENTS.
USUALLY THESE COME FROM THINGS
LIKE STORAGE TANKS THAT ARE
HOLDING TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT
KIND OF THING.
SO. I THINK THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO EXAMS RESIDENCES
PERHAPS OR TO JUST CLARIFY WHAT
TYPE OF CONTAMINATION WERE
TALKING ABOUT AYE I JUST IT'S. I
I WOULD NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
KIND OF CONTAMINATION IS
POSSIBLE FROM THE HOUSE AS
OPPOSED TO PROMINENT AUSTRAL.
YOU KNOW FACILITY YOUR LANDFILL
THAT SORT OF THING.
SO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT.
OTHER ISSUES SUCH AS WHAT IS
THAT WHAT TYPE OF CONTAMINATION
WE CAN CERTAINLY NARROW THAT
DEFINITION AND MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S NON AMBIGUOUS.
THERE ARE SOME CURRENT.
CASE LAW WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO
DO IS TO CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN VERY AMBIGUOUS IN THE
LAW HAS STRUGGLED AND THEY'VE
ALSO.
DEALT WITH THIS IN DIFFERENT
WAYS.
TO THE POINT WHERE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE HAD CONTAMINATION THERE'S
ONE CASE THAT INVOLVES A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT DISCOVERED THAT A
LANDFILL BECAUSE OF OTHER
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT TITLE.
REACHED ONTO THEIR PROPERTY HAD
USE VERY UNUSUAL FIND REALLY
CREATIVE WAYSOF GETTING RELIEF
BECAUSE THE LAW WAS SO ONE. SO
I'M THAT'S WHAT WE SEEK TO DO IS
TO REALLY CLARIFY THE LAW TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE DO HAVE A
COURSE OF ACTION IF THEY'VE BEEN
HARMED. BECAUSE OF A
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT AND BECAUSE
OF THE NATURE OF WATER
CONTAMINATION THAT'S WHAT THE
STATUTE NEEDS TO BE EXTENDED
SOMETIMES IS CONTAMINATION AND
IT TAKES A NUMBER OF YEARS TO
ACTUALLY FIND OUT WHERE THE
CONTAMINATIONS EMANATED FROM.
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
THE OPPONENTS UNTIL THEIR
SUPPORTERS AND. ASK FOR YOU TO
ALLOW US TO A CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS VEY IMPORTANT TOPIC
ALRIGHT YOU.
I DIDN'T THINK WE HAD A MOTION
YET.
ALRIGHT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
TO THE OPPOSITION ARE AYE
CLEARLY HEAR A DESIRE TO WORK
WITH YOU ARE YOU CAN ALSO WORK
WITH MY STAFF ON THE QUESTIONS
OF DEFINITION. OF.
WE'LL JUST MAKE SURE I MISTER
URBAN THAT THAT'S TAKEN CARE OF
AND FOR THE BUILDERS ARE CLEARLY
SHE WANTS TO WORK WITH YOU. AND.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP WE
WELL SO HOPEFULLY AS SHE AS SHE
HAS SAID YOU CAN BE SUPPORTERS
IN THE AT.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WE'VE CLOSED AND I DOUBT YOUR I
ASK ANYONE FOR QUESTIONS CASE I
HAVEN'T.
I ASK OKAY.
THEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM SEVEN.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY EIGHT
FRIEDMAN. THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REEF REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
QUIRK.
I QUIRK.
MELENDEZ.
MOVEMENT IS NOT VOTE
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
WHEN I TO CHANGE.
CURRENT ORBIT WAS OUT.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW THIS IS.
AT.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
VERY GOOD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
IF YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE WHICH
BUT WE START WITH.
I START WITH THE LOWEST NUMBER.
WOULD BE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWO.
JULIA.
OKAY THIS IS THE ANTI COAGULANT
VALUE THIS.
MEG.
BOB PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
REGULATIONS ENACTED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION TO MINIMIZE.
HARM FROM ONE SUBSET OF
RODENTICIDE STE SECOND
GENERATION ANY ANTICOAGULANT
RATHER THAN SITES.
HAVE PROVEN INEFFECTIVE AS
NECROPSY DATA.
PERFORMED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND OTHER SCIENTISTS HAS
DEMONSTRATED. THAT UNNECESSARY
POISONINGS CONTINUE TO POSE A
RAMPANT THREAT TO WILDLIFE AND
PASS.
THE USE OF RODENTICIDE BY
LICENSE PEST CONTROL APPLICATORS
STILL ALLOWS RODENTS TO CONSUMER
DENNIS SITES AND THEN POISON
UPPER LEVEL PREDATORS WHICH WILL
RESULT IN CONTINUE DEATHS OF
WILDLIFE AND PETS MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN EXPERIENCING. IRONICALLY
THIS UNINTENTIONAL POISONING
DECREASES CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY
TO CONTROL RODENT INFESTATION.
BECAUSE IT KILLS THE NATURAL
PREDATORS THAT FEED ON RATS MICE
AND OTHER RODENTS AND DECREASES
NATURAL RODENT CONTROL
STRATEGIES.
RODENTICIDE ALSO POSE AN
UNREASONABLE RISK TO WILDLIFE.
EPA'S ECOLOGICAL INCIDENT REPORT
DOCUMENTS ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE RESIDUES IN TWENTY
SEVEN AVIAN SPECIES AND
SEVENTEEN MAMMALIAN SPECIES.
POISONINGS AND DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED
IN NUMEROUS SPECIES SUCH AS
EAGLES HAWKS
FALCONS.
AL'S BOBCATS MOUNTAIN LIONS AND
EVEN THE IMPERILED SAN WORKING
IN KIT FOX AND NORTHERN SPOTTED
OWL.
PROBLEM IS SO SEVERE THAT OVER
SEVENTY PERCENT OF WILDLIFE
TESTED IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO RODENTICIDE IT'S.
RODENTS SIZE POSE AN
UNREASONABLE RISK TO CHILDREN.
ACCORDING TO SAFETY CALCULATIONS
FROM THE EPA THE ESTIMATED CHILD
EXPOSURE FROM TAKING JUST ONE.
FIVE GRAMS BITE OF RODENTICIDE
BAY GREATLY EXCEEDS POSSIBLE
SAFE LEVELS.
RODENTICIDE POSE AN UNREASONABLE
RISK TO PAT'S AND DOMESTIC
ANIMALS AS WELL.
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED PETS
NEEDLESSLY DIE EACH YEAR DO
RODENTICIDE EXPOSURE.
SINCE THE CONSUMER BAD OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN DFW AND WHILE CARE
THROUGH A GRANT FROM DPR HAVE
CONTINUED TO MONITOR SUSPECTED
POISONING CASES.
IN THEORY THE USE OF A SECOND
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT SHOULD
HAVE DROPPED THE NUMBER OF CASES
BUT IN REALITY WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS CONTINUED. POISONING OF NON
TARGET WILDLIFE FROM SECOND
GENERATION WHERE WE SHOULD HAVE
SEEN NONE AN INCREASE FROM FIRST
GENERATION OF ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE OF NON TARGET
WILDLIFE.
MOST FAMOUSLY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
P. TWENTY TO THE LOCAL LOS
ANGELES MOUNTAIN LINE THAT HAS A
BEEN FOUND IN GRIFFITH PARK.
WAS FOUND WANDERING THE AREA AND
LOOKED TO BE SICK WITH MANGE
PARK RANGERS CAPTURED P. TWENTY
TWO AND TREATED THE COUGAR. AS
WELL AS TOOK BLOOD SAMPLES HE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR MAINLY FIRST
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANTS
THE COUGAR HAD BEEN CLOSELY
MONITORED IN THE AREA BY DFW
OFFICIALS. AND UNTIL RECENTLY
HAD BEEN HEALTHY.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO SIX TO
TAKE STRONGER MEASURES.
PROTECT CHILDREN PETS AND
WILDLIFE FROM UNINTENTIONAL
RODENTICIDE POISONING.
THE USE OF RAT MOUSE AND RODENT
POISONS BY THE GENERALPUBLIC
AND LICENSED APPLICATORS LEADS
TO THE DEATH OF WILDLIFE AND
PETS. AND THE HOSPITALIZATION IN
ILLNESSES OF CHILDREN.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO ALLOWS
FOR COMMONSENSE CONTROLS ON
THESE DANGEROUS POISONS IN ORDER
TO ELIMINATE THEIR USE WHERE
THEY LEAD TO UNNECESSARY
POISONINGS TO NON TARGET
ORGANISMS WHILE STILL ALLOWS A
ALLOWING. FOR THE USE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY AND TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE BILL IS NARROWLY TARGETED AT
FIRST AND SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDE STE
AND SPECIFICALLY EXEMPTS
AGRICULTURAL ACTIVITIES WHICH
ALLOWS FOR A DATA SIZE TO STILL
BE USED TO ADDRESS RODENT
INFESTATIONS. AFFECTING
AGRICULTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES AND IN CASES WHERE
PROFESSIONAL PETS COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO CONTROL THE
RODENT POPULATION THROUGH
EXCLUSION AND SANITATION. AND
HAVE RECEIVED A PERMIT TO USE
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDE FROM
DPR.
NEW ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
AND MORE HUMANE MEANS OF
CONTROLLING RODENT POPULATIONS
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING DEVELOPED
AND SUCCESSFULLY USED BY PEST
MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY.
OFFERING HOPE FOR THE FUTURE.
THE USE OF PESTICIDES ACCEPTED
HIGHLY.
PACIFIC CONTEXT IS NEITHER
JUSTIFIABLE NOR IS IT SUPPORTED
BY THE PUBLIC.
A FURTHER RESTRICTIONS CALLED
FOR IN AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO
WILL NOT ONLY OFFER PROTECTIONS
FOR PEOPLE IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT WILL FURTHER STIMULATE THE
DEVELOPMENT AND APPLICATION OF
ALTERNATIVE ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE CONTROLS GIVEN THE
OVERWHELMING HARM THAT IS POSED
BY ROTE TENNIS RODENTICIDE. AND
THE AVAILABILITY OF COST
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES THESE
POISONS MUST BE BETTER REGULATED
TO PROTECT CHILDREN PETS AND
WILDLIFE.
I'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WITNESSES JANET PROPOSER AND. TO
VAUGHN FRASER FROM UCLA.
VERY GOOD TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. CLICK.
CHAIRMAN AND THIS.
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF OF PROJECT COYOTE AND
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION IS A
PART OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWO.
AS YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN OUT OF CONCERN
FOR THEIR NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT THE DPR TOOK A
NUMBER OF ANTICOAGULANTS OFF
CONSUMER SHOUTS.
BUT WITHOUT A SIMILARLY
RESTRICTIVE RIVER THAT SIMILARLY
RESTRICTING THE USE BY THE PEST
CONTROL INDUSTRY. AS A
CONSEQUENCE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS HAVE CONTINUED THE
ROUTINE USE OF ANTI COAGULANT
THAT'S AND NOT SURPRISINGLY NOT
TARGET EXPOSURES AND DEATHS HAVE
NOT DIMINISHED.
IF THAT THEIR INCREASING AT AN
ALARMING PACE. AT FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT AND NOW
ALLIANCE AT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE DOCUMENTED
ANTICOAGULANTS.
IN THE LIVER TISSUE OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIVE OF THE HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN.
CLIENTS TESTED THAT'S NINETY
FIVE PERCENT.
IN ANOTHER STUDY UP BY YOU SEE
DAVID SCIENTISTS OVER A FOUND
OVER SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE
ENDANGERED. NORTHERN SPOTTED OWL
HAD BEEN AND HAD LIKELY BEEN
EXPOSED HER AGAIN TO SITES.
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC FROM A
CONSERVATION STANDPOINT.
ARE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
RODENTICIDE EXPOSURE IN RARE AND
THREATENED SPECIES INCLUDING THE
FISHER. A LARGE MEMBER OF THE
WEASEL FAMILY THAT LIVES IN THE
REDWOOD FORESTS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IMPALED SAN JOAQUIN FOX.
IT MAY BE IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND ANY
SPECIES A PREDATOR THAT HAS NOT
BEEN NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
REAGAN BESIDES.
THE DELETERIOUS IMPACTS OF THESE
DANGERS COMPOUNDS NOT RESTRICTED
TO WILDLIFE EVERY YEAR MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND CHILDREN ARE
EXPOSED WITH POOR CHILDREN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
THE CALASANZ CANCER ACCIDENTLY
POISONED EVERY YEAR IS WELL.
KNOWN QUESTIONS THE NEED FOR
READING CONTROL ONLY THAT MEANS
IN TERMS BY WHICH YOU CAN BE
MOST RESPONSIBLY ACCOMPLISHED
SANITATION SEARING BUILDINGS
MOVING FOOD WATER AND HABITAT.
ARE THE KEY TO EFFECTIVE AND
ECONOMICAL READING CONTROL
METHODS AS IS A LOVELY NATURAL
PREDATORS HAWKS OWLS BOBCATS
FOXES COYOTES COULD YOU WANTED
YOU THEIR OWN JOB TO DO THE ANY
SHIPS OF THE OTHERS. AND HAVE
HER TELL HEADACHES AND IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT EVERY CENT
AND.
VENTURA COUNTY WATERSHED
PROTECTION DISTRICT PILOT STUDY
SWAPPED BAY BOXES FOR POISON AND
THEY FOUND THAT NOT ONLY DID
UMBER WITH BUDGETS REDUCED THEY.
ESTIMATED ANNUAL SAVINGS OF
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER.
AYE LEVY MILE AS EXAMPLES OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALSO USING.
.
ARE NOT HAVE DISCONTINUED USING
ANTICOAGULANTS ARE USING
SNAPCHAT'S AND OTHER METHODS TO
CONTROL RATS INCLUDE DE INSECURE
INEQUALITY PEPPER NINE
UNIVERSITY UC DAVIS THE CITY OF
DAVIS AND TO ADD.
THAT MARIN COUNTY JAPANESE
PESTICIDES OF TWO THOUSAND NINE
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
BOB.
I'LL GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES OKAY.
UP FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FOUR TWO TWO. MY NAME IS DIVINE
FRAZIER AND I AM HERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A LARGE AND
GROWING COMMUNITY OF SCIENTISTS
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS THAT ARE
AWARE. OF.
.
THE DANGERS THAT THESE ANTI QUIT
OR DON'T SITES POSE TO WILDLIFE
AS WELL AS TO HUMANS AND PETS.
I RECEIVED MY DOCTORATE FROM
UCLA IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
DURING WHICH TIME I SPENT
SEVERAL YEARS STUDYING THE
EFFECTS OF THESE TALKS CAN SOME
BBCATS
AND OTHER WILDLIFE.
A RESEARCH TEAM IS VERY DIVERSE
INCLUDES MEMBERS OF THE UCLA
MEDICAL TEAM I'M SORRY MEDICAL
SCHOOL DISEASE ECOLOGIST
WILDLIFE BIOLOGISTS AND NATIONAL
PARK SERVICE SCIENTISTS WHO HAVE
BEEN MONITORING WILDLIFE IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS.
WE HAVE.
PUBLISHED A WEALTH OF PEER
REVIEWED SCIENTIFIC STUDIES THAT
CHARACTERIZE EVALUATE THE
SYSTEMIC SUB LETHAL. AND
SECONDARY EFFECTS OF THESE
POISONS ON NON TARGET SPECIES
WE DOCUMENTED DEATHS OF THREE
MOUNTAIN LIONS.
DO DIRECTLY TO EMERGING
COMPLICATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
EXPOSURE TO RODENTICIDE SO.
THE LATEST BEING IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH IS MORE
THAN YEAR FOLLOWING THE ON
PREVIOUSLY REFERRED TO
LEGISLATION THAT WAS RESTRICTIVE
BUT NOT COMPLETELY PRECLUDE
SERVE FOR THE USE OF THESE
WRITTEN DECIDES.
A MORE RECENTLY LAST SEPTEMBER
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND A MALE
LION WAS LOCATED DEAD. AND WHILE
THE CAUSE OF HIS DEATH COULDN'T
BE DETERMINED TO TO.
SEVERAL DAYS SINCE THE DEATH
OCCURRED.
HE DID HAD POSITIVE TEST
POSITIVE FOR.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
FIRST AND SECOND GENERATION
WRITTEN DECIDES.
WE CONTINUE TO FIND RACCOONS
COYOTES GRAY FOXES THAT ARE
TESTING POSITIVE BILLION DYING
DIRECTLY DUE TO HOW MERGING.
I WE'VE ALSO FOUND OVER SEVERAL
YEARS A VERY STRONG CORRELATION
IN BOBCATS AMOUNT ALLIANCE WITH.
A DISEASE OF MANGE DISEASE.
WHICH HAS NEVER PREVIOUSLY BEEN
DOCUMENTED BECAUSE POPULATION
LEVEL AFFECTS
BUT IN THE BOBCATS IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA HAS CAUSED
PRECIPITOUS DECLINES IN
POPULATION NUMBERS.
OUR MOST RECENT RESEARCH
LOOKING AT THE CELLULAR AND GENE
EXPRESSION EFFECTS NOT TO
JOURNEY SORRY I APOLOGIZE. BUT
WE'VE OBSERVED ON CELLULAR.
FX BUT CELLULAR LEVEL AND THE
LEVEL OF GENE EXPRESSION.
THAT THESE RODENTICIDE HAVE
SEVERE SYSTEMIC IMPACTS ON
IMMUNE FUNCTION AND BOBCATS
WITH.
LOVE I SURE AM WITHOUT.
.
SO TO SAY THAT THE EFFECTS ON
THE IMMUNE FUNCTION CAN HAVE
CASCADING A FAX IN THE FACE OF
INTRODUCED IN DISEASES AND
BECAUSE POPULATION LEVEL
AFFECTS.
IN A VARIETY OF SPECIES
I'M WOULD ALSO LIKE TO JUST
EMPHASIZE THAT THESE METHODS OF
CONTROL AREN'T ANY MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN OTHER METHODS
THAT CAN BE DEVISED.
AND IN FACT WE ARGUE THAT
THEY'RE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE GIVEN
THAT RODENTS HAVE SHORT
GENERATION TIMES CAN DEVELOP
RESISTANCE.
ANTS.
IF YOU AFFECT THE PREDATORS THAT
ARE CONTROLLING THESE THINGS
NATURALLY YEAR CLEARLY GONNA
HAVE A OKAY LESS EFFECT.
OTHER ISN'T IT PLEASE. STAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT AT THAT WILL
HAVE QUESTIONS OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I HAVE A COUSIN OF AS AN AVID
BIRDER IN A CALIFORNIAN.
HERE IN SUPPORT.
AS A GUY ALLEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING ABOUT A THOUSAND
CANNABIS CARS DIDN'T GET OUR
SUPPORT TO THE COMMITTEE ON TIME
BUT WE NEED TO TAKE A POSITION
ONCE COMMUNICATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SOSA MATTER NOT
WITH WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. CURRENT.
ARM IFYOU TWO COULD MOVE TO
THESE TWO CHAIRS.
AND THEN WE COULD HAVE THE
OPPOSITION COME UP.
IT WOULD GO AND TAKE THE OTHER
TWO CHAIRS AND THEN.
IF YOU ALL LOVE WHEN THIS
FINISHES COULD STAY HERE FOR
QUESTIONS I THINK WE'LL HAVE A
INTERESTING DISCUSSION.
ALRIGHT.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST TWO
MINUTES EACH AND I'LL GO TO TWO
AND A HALF IF YOU'RE REALLY?
?
REALLY HAVE TO SINCE I DID WITH
THE OTHER FOLKS GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I'M JUST SLIGHTLY
TERRIFIED SO I HOPE YOU'LL BEAR
WITH ME AYE IF YOU HAVEN'T DONE
THIS BEFORE IT'S A BIG DEAL I
REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME I
TESTIFIED.
I WAS REALLY NERVOUS.
NOT MY FIRST TIME BUT IT FEELS
LIKE THE FIRST TIME EVERY TIME
IN MY NAME IS JIM STATE AND I'M
I'M THE OWNER OF A PEST CONTROL
COMPANY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA. AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT ELECT A
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THE INDUSTRY. IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE.
ARE HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
STRUCTURE BUT FULL SUPPORT OF
ITS INTENT.
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE UNINTENDED EFFECTS OF.
READINESS SIDES ON CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE.
AND I'M WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A.
THE BILL THAT I THINK WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE IN SUPPORTING IT
WITHOUT PUTTING PUBLIC HEALTH AT
RISK.
CURRENTLY AS THE BILL IS
WRITTEN.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE IF YOU
NEED TO USE RIGHT THAT THE
SITES.
FIRST OF ALL THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO THIS
DEEMED THAT THERE'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY.
SECONDLY.
A COUNTY AG COMMISSIONER NEEDS
TO SEND SOMEBODY TO DETERMINE
THAT RODENTICIDE.
ARE A ALLOWABLE PART OF THE
RESPONSE TO THAT EMERGENCY.
SO YOU HAVE NOW IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO CONTROL A RODENT SITUATION
WHETHER BE IN A RESTAURANT HOME
OR SCHOOL.
I YOUR HANDS TIED DOUBLE BACK
BEHIND YOU WITH RED TAPE.
IN WITH.
AT A WITHOUT ANY CRITERIA FOR
MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
A LET ALONE AND THAT IS THE BILL
AS IT'S WRITTEN NOW REQUIRES A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO DO
THAT.
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
VARY GREATLY DEPENDING UPON. THE
AREA.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THEY
MAY NOT HAVE THE STAFF.
TO RESPOND IN A TIMELY MANNER.
WE'VE ALREADY DID HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH THE COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONER'S AND THEY KNOW
THAT BASED ON THE HUNDREDS OR
EVEN THOUSANDS OF REQUESTS THEY
MAY GET PER WEEK THEY WOULD HAVE
A GREAT DIFFICULTY IN RESPONDING
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
SO IT'S A OUR SUGGESTION THAT
AND.
AS POINTED OUT AT PAGE SEVEN OF
THE ANALYSIS FROM YOUR STAFF
THEY ASKED THE QUESTION. WITH
THIS BILL NOT BE BETTER WITH
THIS CONTENT BE BETTER
ADDRESSED.
THROUGH REGULATION AND WE
STIPULATE THAT IT WOULD BE.
IN FACT THAT THAT THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT DP ARE. THE
DEPARTMENT PESTICIDE REGULATION
BE CHARGED
WITH COMPILING AND SOME
PROTOCOLS FOR THE USE.
AND.
RODENTICIDE.
UNLESS THE OTHER WITNESS
DOESN'T WANT TO SPEAK ILL HAFTA
ACCOUNT ALMOST OUT MOST THEIR
SET BY THE WAY YOU BRING UP VERY
GOOD POINTS AND WE ARE LISTENING
GREAT.
AND WE JUST FEEL THAT THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BRING TOGETHER
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS. THAT
WILL GIVE US THE GREATEST
ABILITY TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT PUTTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AT RISK.
WHICH WERE EXTRAORDINARILY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
VERY GOOD.
NEXT WITNESS I'LL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS A DARREN
VANCE TEAM LIKE I WORK WITH A
CLOCK PRESS CONTROL I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS CALIFORNIA.
.
FOR. THAT FROM A PEST MANAGEMENT
PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL IS A AND
GONNA FULLY AGREE WITH JIM I'M
WHILE WHILE VERY WELL
INTENTIONED AND.
IT MAKES.
IT BASICALLY TOTALLY MISSES THE
MARK ON AYE ON ON IMPLEMENTATION
OF IT BUT ONE OF THE POINTS I
WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER WAS THAT.
THAT NATURAL A PREDATOR'S KEEP
OUR CURRENT RODENTS A IN A
POPULATION AND CHECK ON THAT IS
ACTUALLY NOT TRUE.
THE GUY THE THREE PRIMARY ROADS
THAT WE DEAL WITH THEM ARE ALL
INVASIVE SPECIES AND A AND SINCE
WE DON'T HAVE A CARING CAPACITY
WITHIN OUR WITH OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THEIR AT WHILE THERE IS SOME
WILDLIFE AND THAT MAY BE ABLE
TO.
.
TO USE THEM AS AS A FOOD SOURCE
AYE THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO TOO
AGAIN I KEEP THOSE POPULATIONS
ARE COMPLETELY IN CHECK TO WEAR
A. TIE TO WHERE THEY ARE NOT A
PROBLEM.
IN IRVINE AND OR OR WILD AREAS.
A.
I. RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THE CITY
SAN FRANCISCO HAS HAD SOME. KIND
OF A ED IS A UNIQUE AND OR OR
CAN A SIMILAR A.
THAT PROGRAM.
AS TO WHAT THIS BILL IS GOING
FOR.
BUT IT IS A AYE AYE THAT THAT
IS A COMPLETELY UNIQUE A A
PROGRAM TO THAT LOCALITY AND FOR
MULTIPLE REASONS A ONE.
THE.
THAT THE FINANCIAL UNSUPPORTED
THAT THAT THAT HAS AND THAT THAT
PROGRAM HAS THEIR.
THE CITY SERVICES GO A VERY
READILY ADMITS THAT THEY THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO
ACTUALLY I'D DO IT I'M SO SO.
TO PERFORM ALL THOSE
INSPECTIONS SO THEY ACTUALLY A
CHARGE ALL OF THE.
THAT THE PRIVATE AND PUBLIC A
OWNERS OF THOSE BUILDINGS I'M
FOR ALL OF THOSE IT FOR ALL OF
THOSE INSPECTIONS WHICH AGAIN
CONTINUES TO ADD A COST TO PEST
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. ON AND IT
WAS ACTUALLY BROUGHT UP EARLIER
A MIND THAT THE NEXT POINT IS
THAT.
.
THAT THIS BILL.
A UNFAIRLY TARGETS A SEGMENT OF
POPULATION I CAN'T AFFORD OUR
SERVICES AND AND HAVE TO BEFORE
THE SERVICES THEMSELVES AND
THEIR IS.
HAD THERE IS A CERTAIN SEGMENT
OF OUR OF OUR SOCIETY THAT. THAT
DOES NOT HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE NOR
THE EXPERTISE NOR THE RESOURCES
I EITHER.
MONEY OR MATERIALS TO PERFORM
THE A A THE TRAPPING OR THE
EXCLUSION OR THE SANITATION.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THEM.
TO DO NOW IN THE IN THAT IN
THAT SITUATION HOW WOULD.
IT WHAT WOULD THEY DO.
WOULD HOMEOWNER THAN HAVE TO GO
TO A PUBLIC AT PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER AND GET AN EXEMPTION OR
TO USE.
AND I QUITE AGREE GENOCIDE I'M
THIS THIS BILL THIS BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT AT ALL.
.
AND AGAIN.
THIS BILL WE FEEL IS BEST.
IT WOULD BEST BE ADDRESSED.
IN THE REGULATORY AROUND.
THROUGH A REGULATORY AGENCY
THAT THAT REGULATES AS AS THEY
ASSEMBLYMAN SAID.
.
THEIR SALES USE AND A.
BY THE SALES AND USE OF OF THE
YEAR OF THE PRODUCTS IN WHICH
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SIR THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS ASSOCIATION LIKE
TO MAKE ONE COMMENT. AND IT WAS
A PART OF THAT THE TOP VERY
QUICK QUICKLY.
JUST IN LISTENING TO THE OTHER
THE PRESENTATION OF THE BILL AND
AND.
THAT CONCERNS RAISED BY THE PCO
SEE.
THE AG COMMISSIONERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PERCEIVED
ROLE GIVEN TO THEM WITHIN THIS
BILL THE PRESCRIPTIVE DIAGNOSTIC
WORK THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO DO.
A FALLS FAR OUTSIDE OF THEIR
NORMAL COURSE OF DUTIES.
NOW WE JUST WOULD HELP THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL
TODAY MIGHT CLARIFY.
WHAT WE'RE BEING ASKED TO DO AND
SORT OF WHAT THE ROLE IN THE
PROCESS IS FOR THE AYE
COMMISSIONERS I'M VERY GLAD I
GAVE YOU THAT TIME BECAUSE THAT
IS CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT TO AND
WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT I THANK YOU ABOUT JOB THAT
WE? ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOKING UNITS ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION REAL QUICK NOTE
FAMILY BROWN EYES THAT I ALSO
MENTION HIS CLIENTS RISE AND
WESTERN CLINT OPPOSITIONAL SOAP.
YOU CARE MEMBERS JIM JUST ABOUT
THE AMERICAN CANCER COUNCIL ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
HELLO YOU NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
JOINT YOUR MAP THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATIONAL SOAP.
SYLVIA CAN MERE BOARD CERTIFIED
ENTOMOLOGIST AND A DISTRIBUTOR
HERE TARGET SPECIALTY PRODUCTS
OPPOSED.
I GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS BUT YOU'RE STUCK WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WE DON'T HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL
BUT SIMILAR TO OUR COLLEAGUES
BUT THAT COMMISSIONERS WE. HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THE
ROLE OF OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WOULD BE IN THIS
PROCESS AND. JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS THOSE CONCERNS THANK
THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU BOTH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONERS FOR BRINGING YOUR
CONCERNS FORWARD AT THIS TIME.
SO.
I'VE THERE NO MORE SUPPORTERS
ARE OPPOSITION I'LL GO TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE.
.
I MEMBERS GO AHEAD MISTREATMENT.
A QUESTION BUT A COMMENT Y.
JUROR ONE QUESTION WHICH IS WILL
HAD ME AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR.
IT MIGHT COME IN IS IT A FEW
WEEKS AGO I WAS ABLE TO GO TO A
PRESENTATION BY THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA. ABOUT THE PROGRAM THAT
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON TESTING.
COMPARING THE ANTI COAGULANT
AMBER DENNIS SIDES AGAINST OTHER
METHODS AND THEY'VE BEEN TESTING
THIS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
THEY'VE BEEN TESTING IT IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS AND HAVING TO
DO WITH. SHORING UP LEVEES THAT
ARE BEING DAMAGED BY BY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF RODENTS.
AND WHAT THEY FOUND OUT WAS
THAT IN THOSE AREAS THE.
PER THEY WERE PUTTING PURCHASE
UP TO ATTRACT ARM HAWKS AND OWLS
AT THE HAWKS AND OWLS OUTPERFORM
THE RODENTICIDE.
ABOUT OVER MOST OF A ONE TO TWO
HUNDRED PERCENT.
AND THEY DID REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE STUDIES OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND THEY IN THE.
I HAD A VERY WELL DESIGNED.
A STUDY METHODOLOGY IN THE THAT
THEY THEY THAT WAS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE AND IT WAS
INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE AND BY THE
WAY THE OWLS BEAT THE HAWKS
ALMOST TWO TO ONE SO. IF YOUR
WANTING TO ATTRACT SOMETHING I'M
THERE THEY'D BE A GOOD ONE AND
WHAT THEY FOUND FOR THE ACT
FOLKS ALMOND.
YOU MAY ALREADY KNOW THIS BUT
BECAUSE THE CRITTERS WERE MORE
LIKELY TO EAT THE CROPS AND THE
BABY WAS REALLY DOING NOTHING.
WHEREAS THE HAWKS IN THE OWLS
ARE OUT WORKING TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY DOING NOTHING BUT
RODENT CONTROL.
.
A I THINK IT'S REALLY
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT WERE
ALLOWING OUR WILDLIFE BE
POISONED IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
DOGS AND CATS TO BE POISONED IN
THIS INCREDIBLY INHUMANE. WAY
IT'S GOING ON FOR YEARS AND WE
THROW OUR WHOLE SYSTEMATIC
BALANCED WHERE NOW WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE.
THE PREDATORS TO KEEP THIS
POPULATION IN CHECK WHICH ADDS
TO THE THE PROBLEM.
I'M VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S A LONG
TIME IN COMING.
I'LL DO WHATEVER I CAN TO HELP
YOU GET THIS THROUGH AND I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT THE DISTRICT
IN WHICH P. TWENTY TWO LIVES.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT IN LOS
ANGELES THERE'S A LOT OF LOVE
FOR THAT BIG CAT. AND WHEN THE
PHOTOS OF HIM BEING POISONED
WERE SHOWN ALL OVER THE MEDIA
PEOPLE WERE OUTRAGED.
SO I'M RESIDENTS. ARE VERY AWARE
OF THIS I HEAR ABOUT THIS ISSUE
CONSTANTLY FROM PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT SO THIS IS A OF LOCAL
CONCERN FOR ME AND I THINK IT IS
FOR. A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE PAYING ATTENTION AND LOVE
THE ANIMALS THAT THEY LIVE
ALONGSIDE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
VERY GOOD.
ANYONE ELSE
SKINNER SUTURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IDEA.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE.
DESIRE TO PROTECT.
ANIMALS
AND AND AND PATS.
.
HOWEVER AYE GOING. OUT HAVE A
HARD TIME IMAGINING.
YOU KNOW HOW HAWKS AND OWLS CAN
YOU BE USED ESPECIALLY IN URBAN
SITUATIONS TO.
WE KEEP OUR OUR RODENT
POPULATIONS AND IN CHECK AND SO
YEAH I.
WANTED TO.
YEAH I I HEARD YOU TALKING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
ALTERNATIVES TO THE.
ANTI COAGULANT.
RODENTICIDE SO WHAT WHAT ARE
THE MOST. COMMON AND.
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE
ALTERNATIVES
ROUGHLY FLAT APPLYING.
FINE THEN THE ENVIRONMENT IN
TERMS OF SANITATION AND THAT
REMOVING HABITATION SUCH AS
EDUCATION. WHERE RATS CAN BREED?
THAT SANITATION METHODS TAKE IT
KEEPING DANCERS CLOSED UP.
BEYOND SNAPCHAT'S A VERY
EFFECTIVE AND THEY HAVE TO BE
CHECKED MORE OFTEN UP BECAUSE
ABOUT TO SET A WANDERING OFF TO
DIRE. DAD THERE I HAVE TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE TRAPS OF MORE
MAN HOURS.
ARE INVOLVED GENERALLY BE DE
AND IRAQ THERE ALSO ELECTRIC CAT
RATHER CATERS IS WHAT THEY'RE
CALLED WHERE THE HECK RAT ENTERS
AND IS GONE HE REALLY LIKES
QUICKLY DONE.
ELECTROCUTED.
AND I I JUST I KNOW THAT DAD
THAT IN THE INSTANCES WHERE AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AT.
AT COMMERCIAL ENTERPRISES HAVE
MOVED FROM THE USING PAPER
POISON TO USING THE SNAP TRAFFIC
SPREAD PRIMARY DEFENSE.
THERE I IN MY INTERVIEWS WITH
PEOPLE WHO OF YOU SAYS THAT
PATSY NO COMPLAINTS OF ANYTHING
THEY FOUND THEY HAD BETTER
READING CONTROL. WHICH IS WHY A
CITY OR A COUNTY LIKE MARIN
COUNTY WHICH IS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE NOT USED ANY
POISON ON HAS BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL
EVEN THOUGH THEY INVADE MANAGED
A FACILITY SUCH AS THAT UNIT
THAT FRANKLY RIGHT.
COMMUNITY CENTER WHICH HAS A LOT
OF THEM.
EVENTS AND FOOD ORIENTED AND
OCCASIONS THERE THERE STILL I'M
FINDING THAT WITH THE AND THE
COMBINATION OF THE AYE
SANITATION AND.
I HABITATION AND THAT STEPPED
OUT SO THEY HAVE BEEN VERY AND
HAVE NOT HAD A PROBLEM HAVE NOT
HAD A SINGLE REQUEST COME
FORWARD IN TEN YEARS ALMOST FOUR
AND EIGHT TO USE PESTICIDES.
OKAY.
ARMED.
SO IT'S PRIMARILY THAT THE
THE FACT THAT TRAPS NOT TRAPPED
IN OUR AND ENVIRONMENTAL.
MITIGATION OKAY AND AN EGRESS
KIT PREVENTING RATS FROM
ENTERING.
SITES WE DON'T WANT A A
SCREENING PGA.
AYE ENTRIES TO A TO HOMES.
BY FILLING HOLES. OF THE CAN
ALLOW INGRESS THAN AN EGRESS.
ARE THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE
FOR UP FOR RODENT CONTROL ALWAYS
REMOVING VEGETATION AWAY FROM.
THE.
SO IT'S NOT UP AGAINST A HOUSE
OF THICK VINES THAT GROW NEARBY
ARE FREQUENTLY.
A BREEDING GROUNDS FOR RODENTS
THESE ARE UNPROVEN A AND VERY
EFFECTIVE METHODS.
I THOUGHT WE HAD A MENTION OF
THE.
A LECTURE GOTTA A RADICULAR
LIKE VIEWS DATA THOSE OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AT AT MY HOME
THEY'VE PROVEN VERY EFFECTIVE
BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
THEM AND.
IS HAVE BEEN REFERENCED IN THE
DISCUSSION HERE IS THAT THEY
HAVE.
ACTUALLY GONE THROUGH SEVERAL
GENERATIONS OF IMPROVEMENTS
UP TO THAT EQUIPMENT AND.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK WE CAN
EXPECT TO SEE AS WE MOVE DOWN
THE PATH OF IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS. IS.
A A A A MORE INNOVATION AND
DATA USING PROVEN STRATEGIES
THAT DID NOT INVOLVE USING
POISON.
I CAN YOU KNOW MISTER BLOOM AYE
I'M A.
PRODUCT OF THE SEVENTIES AND
MAYBE I WATCHED TOO MANY OF
THOSE MOVIES OF OF RATS THE.
TAKEN OVER AND COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN I WAS READING
THE. ANALYSIS OF THE THE THE
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. RODENTS WITH
THE BONNET PLAGUE.
.
BEEN DEAD DO I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S SOME PROVISION ABOUT.
A PUBLIC HEALTH EXCEPTIONS GOOD.
THERE ARE AND AND OF COURSE WE
ALWAYS ESPECIALLY IN THIS DAY
AND AGE HAVE TO BE. A
CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT TO
SEPARATING FACT FROM FICTION.
OF ME WHEN I HER A OF BOTH THAT
REPRESENTING HOLLYWOOD UP AND I
THINK YOU HOPE.
WERE PRETTY GOOD STEP OF BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT. BUT.
.
THE.
IMPORTANT THING TO REMEMBER HERE
IS I THINK WHAT THE GOAL IS AND
THAT IS REDUCING ACCESS IN THE
USE OF ACCESS TO IN THE USE. OF
FOR OF POISONS I'M NOT SURE IF
I'M ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT LOVE THE.
.
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS. RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE VAGUENESS OF.
PETITIONING FOR EXCEPTIONS IN
THE CASE OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS.
NECESSITIES YES.
AND THAT PROVIDES ME WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THAT OF
COURSE WE WILL.
CONTINUE DISCUSSING GO WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT PROVISIONS
IN THE IN THE BILL I THINK THERE
ARE SOME PLACES WHERE WE CAN.
HOPEFULLY FIND SOME LANGUAGE
THAT TOOK A OF THAT WE CAN ALL
LIVE WITH AND IMPROVE THE BILL.
WE ACTUALLY.
A MEETING TO THE UP AS
CONTROL OPERATORS WHO HAVE TRIED
TO SIT DOWN WITH US WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO FIND THE TIME TO DO
THAT THAT IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT.
I FREQUENTLY POINT OUT WHEN THE.
OPPONENTS TO BILLS HAVEN'T MADE
AN ATTEMPT TO MEET WITH US THIS
IS ACTUALLY AN A A A SITUATION
WHERE THEY HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
MEET WITH US AND WE JUST HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO. COORDINATE TO
THIS POINT SO. COMMITTEE.
CONTINUIDAD WHO DIG COMMIT TO
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
.
BEFORE YOU CLOSE ARM.
I THOUGHT I HAD A QUESTION BUT I
THINK ACTUALLY YOU ASKED IT SO
WELL I KNOW WHAT IT WAS I JUST
TO MENTION THAT YOU HAVE GIVEN
AN EXEMPTION TO AGRICULTURE.
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT HERE IS PRIMARILY WHAT
AREAS.
WHERE WHERE YOU PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED URBAN AREAS SUBURBAN
AREAS SO I I I THINK A?
OF THIS IS OF INTENSE INTEREST
IN. OF FOR EXAMPLE IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS.
AND.
A AREAS THAT ARE LARGELY
SUBURBAN.
AT SOME SOME WHAT RURAL.
VETERAN OF THE.
AT ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WERE
COMFORTABLE ALLOWING FOR AN
EXEMPTION FOR AGRICULTURE IS
THAT THEY'RE ALSO OF. A
PROFESSIONALS IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH PAST
ISSUES FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME
THERE ALSO GROWING FOOD
UNDERSTAND THE NEED O KEEP FOOD
SEPARATE FROM. POISONS.
AND REDUCING THE USE JUST A
STATE OF OUR REDUCING THEIR
DEPENDENCE ON FERTILIZERS UP AND
MOVING TOWARDS IN MANY CASES
NATURAL ALTERNATIVES THIS IS
REALLY A CONTINUATION. OF THAT
SAME REFOCUS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
AND THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M SO
ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM I ACTUALLY
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
USED.
OF THESE TYPES OF A CHEMICALS I
GUESS IF YOU'LL ARE PAID FOR
THESE RODENTS BECAUSE.
IT'S.
IT'S DEADLY FRANKLY F. IF A
CHILD GETS A HOLD OF IT OR.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD DOG OR CAT
MEAN I GET IT I DO UNDERSTAND I
DON'T HAVE ANY IN MY HOME AND
OUR HOME BACKS. TO A VAST CANYON
WE HAVE LOTS OF CRITTERS BACK
THERE AND THEY'RE ALWAYS RUN
INTO MY BACKYARD.
BUT I DON'T HAVE THAT TYPE OF
OF BAIT IN MY HOME MY THERE WE
HAVE.
SOME.
LITTLE GLUE TRAPS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT IT IS A PROBLEM
FOR FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME WERE. YOU
KNOW IN THAT TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT
THAT YOU'RE HOME BACK JUST THAT
SORT OF THING AND WHEN WE HAVE
SPOKEN WITH OUR PEST CONTROL
COMPANY. THE THE COST DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
USING THE TRADITIONAL METHOD OF
GETTING RID OF WRITERS AND AS
OPPOSED TO THE NEWER METHODS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEVICE LIKE THE
TRAPS AND THINGS LIKE THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT AND FOR MANY PEOPLE
THEY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO.
AFFORD THAT.
I AND I HAVE SOME CONCERNS OF
THAT JUST MIGHT NOT BE FEASIBLE
IN SOME SITUATIONS I'M NOT
NECESSARILY IN A RESIDENTIAL
AREA BUT IN SOME OTHER
COMMERCIAL AREAS WHERE. IT JUST
WON'T WORK I THINK MOST PEOPLE
PROBABLY THEY WANT THE QUICKEST
AND CHEAPEST WAY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM AND IF THAT'S.
IS SOME OF THE WAYS THAT YOU
SUGGESTED THEY'LL THEY'LL DO
THAT BUT SOMETIMES THAT'S THAT'S
NOT THE CASE.
AND AND I I HAVE TO AGREE THAT
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
ABOUT THE ROLE THAT WILL BE
CHANGING NOW IN IN YOU KNOW
WHO'S GOING TO DECIDE WHEN
THESE.
TYPES OF.
.
RODENTICIDE CAN BE USED IN WHEN
THEY CAN'T IS I THINK CONCERNING
FOR IT FOR GOOD REASON I'M SURE
YOU WOULD AGREE WITH THAT TOO IN
IS TO A CERTAIN EXTENT.
ESTO I.
FOR THOSE REASONS.
THOUGH I'M WITH YOU IN CONCEPT
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
IT SAY THAT PERHAPS AS YOU GO IF
YOU GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
THERE MAY BE SOME CHANGES AND I
MIGHT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT BUT
I AM I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS.
THANK YOU I HOPE TO EARN YOUR
SUPPORT AND TOOK I WOULD JUST TO
ADD AND I THINK YOU ACTUALLY
TOUCHED ON THIS BUT YOU SAID.
QUICKEST AND CHEAPEST A BUT YOU
TALKED ABOUT SIXTY.
INITIALLY IN YOUR REMARKS AND I
THINK PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR
QUICK AND EXPENSIVE.
BUT SAFE.
ALL RIGHT. UP ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT.
IF YOU COULD GIVE ME ONE MINUTE.
I'M OF THE BILL ALRIGHT.
MANY NEW BY MISS FRIEDMAN SECOND
BY MISTER MURATSUCHI.
.
SO THERE'S A LOT GOING ON HERE I
HEARD FROM THE LOCAL AGENCIES.
BUT THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
GUIDELINES AND AYE I KNOW THE
AUTHOR WILL WORK WITH THEM ON
THAT THAT'S.
AND.
YES YOU SEE AND HE HAS AGREED
ARE SO AND HE IS GOING TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WELL I HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE THAT WE CAN MOVE
AHEAD. US SOMETHING ELSE WAS
RAISED IN THE.
.
ANALYSIS WHICH IS THE QUESTION
OF.
IF YOU REGULATE.
THE ANTICOAGULANTS THEN THERE
OTHER POISONS OUT THERE.
AND I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT.
WHAT YOU DO WITH THOSE AS WELL
AND WORK WITH THE?
PEST CONTROL AGENT.
WHAT YOU WHAT WHAT I WORRY ABOUT
IS THAT YOU MAKE IT DIFFICULT
USE ONE SUBSTANCE?
AND THEN IT BECOMES.
PEOPLE FIND SUBSTITUTES.
SO I I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'VE REALLY GOT TO THINK
ABOUT VERY CAREFULLY ISABEL
MOVES FORWARD NOW I KNOW YOU
WELL.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE IS.
JUST.
.
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT NOW.
OUR VICE CHAIR AND I UNDERSTAND
WHY SHE HAS HER CONCERNS.
I WILL SAY OR CAN YOU KNOW THE
ONE OF THE BIGGEST.
PEST CONTROL AREAS I KNOW ABOUT.
THEIR IT THEIR APPROACH ENTIRELY
IS SEAL UP THE HOUSE FIRST.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T DO THAT.
POISONS TRAPS
NOTHING WORKS.
THEN WHEN YOU SEAL UP THE HOUSE.
IT'S JUST AS EASY FRANKLY AND
PROBABLY AS CHEAP TO USE TRAPS
AS TO USE POISON.
AND.
IT ONE THING FOR SURE WITH
TRAPS AS YOU'D LEAST YOU KNOW
WHERE THE ANIMAL IS AND IT
DOESN'T END UP ON YOUR WALL
SOMEWHERE.
SO AGAIN WITH I THINK THE.
IN OTHER MANY LARGE INSTITUTIONS
NOW AND AND THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THAT ARE GOING THIS
WAY HOLE COUNTIES AS.
.
WELL MISS FRIEDMAN SUGGESTED SO
I DO THINK THAT THIS IS FEASIBLE
I DO THINK THERE'S MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND I'M HOPE.
AND WITH THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS YOU'RE ALWAYS GOING TO
HAVE A JOB I KNOW THAT.
WHETHER IT'S STRAPS OR POISON OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
ROADS WILL ALWAYS BE WITH US.
SO.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
WHO'S BEEN HERE THANK YOU FOR
THE PAST CONTROL OPERATORS FOR
WORKING THANK YOU FOR THE LOCAL
AGENCIES FOR ASKING FOR WHAT YOU
NEEDED IN TERMS OF GUIDANCE.
I THINK WE'RE WELL ON OUR WAY
TO GETTING A VERY GOOD BILL HERE
THANKS TO ALL THE WITNESSES ALL
OF THE SPEAKERS.
AND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND SO
WE CAN ASKED TO CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO BLOOM
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND REAR
FOR TO THE COMMITTEE ON WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELINDA SNOW AROUND THE LAND.
WROTE.
FRIEDMAN I
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
WHAT I TO DO?
BUT IT'S WHAT SHE.
THREE TWO ONE YEAH IT IS THREE
TO ONE AND WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT
FROM OUR MEMBERS BUT YOUR BILL
IS ON CALL THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH AGAIN TO EVERYONE WHO WAS
HERE TODAY THANK YOU ALL.
BUT AGAIN I PERSONALLY.
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT.
ALRIGHT SO THE NEXT BELL IS ONE
OF MY FAVORITES.
.
BLOOM A JUVENILE PRODUCTS FLAME
RETARDANT MATERIALS AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY EIGHT.
WITH THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S
ALWAYS CHECK INTERFERE THAT.
YOUR BILL IS A FAVORITE OF THE
CHAIR.
HOPEFULLY THAT THAT MEANS THAT
A OF A FAVOR TO SUPPORT AS
OPPOSED TO.
DOT SUPPORT OF AB AND WE'LL
FIND OUT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
EIGHT OF THE SEVERE PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS BY
PROHIBITING THE SALE OF JUVENILE
PRODUCTS JUVENILE PRODUCTS.
MATTRESSES AND UPHOLSTERED OR RE
UPHOLSTERED FURNITURE THAT
CONTAIN FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICALS.
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXPOSED TO TOXIC FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICALS.
WHICH ARE IN SOAP IS THE SOAP AS
WE SIT ON THE MATTRESSES WE
SLEEP ON. AND IN THE TOYS THAT
OUR CHILDREN PLAY WITH.
OVER TIME THE ACCUMULATED OUR
BODIES AND IN THE ENVIRONMENT
CAUSING A VARIETY OF ADVERSE
HEALTH AFFECTS INCLUDING AND THE
CRANE AND THYROID DISRUPTION.
CANCER AND HARMFUL NEUROLOGICAL
FUNCTION.
ALTHOUGH FLAME RETARDANTS ARE
DANGEROUS TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
THEY POSE A PARTICULARLY HIGH
THREAT TO SPECIFIC POPULATIONS
INCLUDING CHILDREN AND
FIREFIGHTERS.
INFANTS ARE OFTEN OFTEN EXPOSED%
TO FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS
THROUGH CONTAMINATED DUST AND
BREAST MILK AND HAVE BEEN FOUND
TO HAVE THESE CHEMICALS IN THEIR
BODIES AT LEVELS. THREE TO FIVE
TIMES THE LEVELS IN THEIR
MOTHERS.
FIREFIGHTERS ARE ALSO EXPOSED TO
THESE CHEMICALS. AND THEIR
DERIVATIVES AT HIGHER LEVELS
THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC
WHEN FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS
BURN THEY RELEASE CARCINOGENIC
SUBSTANCES KNOWN AS DIOXINS AND
FURANS.
THESE CHEMICALS ARE INHALED BY
FIREFIGHTERS AND EVEN LINGER ON
PROTECTING A PROTECTIVE CLOTHING
LONG AFTER A FIREFIGHTER LEAVES
THE SITE OF A FIRE. AS A RESULT
WE'RE SEEING HIGHER RATES OF
CANCER MONTHS FIREFIGHTERS THAN
EVER BEFORE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING TOXIC THESE
CHEMICALS ARE ALSO A NECESSARY
TO MEET FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS
LET ME REPEAT THAT THESE
CHEMICALS ARE. UNNECESSARY TO
MEET FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS.
AND THIS IS WHY MANY
MANUFACTURERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE VOLUNTARILY PHASE IN
ABOUT.
HOWEVER STRAGGLERS CONTINUE TO
REMAIN AND WE CANNOT AND SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO PROTECT UP WE
CANNOT. OF BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC WITHOUT A RESTRICTION
ON THE SALE OF SPECIFIC
PRODUCTS.
CONTAINING THESE CHEMICALS
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT
PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS BY FACING THESE
CHEMICALS OUT FOR GOOD.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE OF A CAR WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. ALVARO CASANOVA ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
AND EMILY LOW AYE CAPTAIN
THE CITY OF DAVIS FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
ALL RIGHT ARM I CAN GIVE YOU A
MINUTE HAVE FEATURES THAT WORK
OKAY AND I'LL DO THAT FINE.
ALRIGHT.
YOU HAVE MEANT HALF.
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS EMILY
LOW AND A CAPTAIN WITH CITY
DAVIS FIRE DEPARTMENT
I AM ALSO THE MOTHER OF TWO
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT
FOCUSES ON ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
CONCERNED IN THE FIREFIGHTING
PROFESSION FOR DECADES THE
CANCER RISK BASED BY THE
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE JOB. EVERY
YEAR CALIFORNIA AT ANYWHERE FROM
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY NAMES TO THE
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS MEMORIAL
IN THE CAPITAL PARK.
MANY OF THEM ARE VICTIMS OF JOB
RELATED CANCER CAUSED BY
PROLONGED EXPOSURE TO THE
CARCINOGENS ON THE JOB.
AS MANY AS ONE IN THREE
FIREFIGHTERS IS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER AND STRONG DATA LINKS
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE JOB EXPOSURE
TO FLAME RETARDANTS. TO ADVERSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES.
BIO MONITORING STUDIES SHOW THAT
THE BODIES OF FIREFIGHTERS CARRY
GREATER LOADS OF THESE FLAME
RETARDANTS WHEN COMPARED TO
AVERAGE POPULATION.
FOR EXAMPLE ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
OF THE FIREFIGHTERS IN ONE STUDY
TESTED POSITIVE FOR FLAME
RETARDANT SUCH AS PBDES AND THE
BY PRODUCTS PRODUCED WHEN FLAME
RETARDANTS BURN.
FIREFIGHTERS CARRIED THESE
CHEMICALS IN CONCENTRATION TWO
TO THREE TIMES GREATER THAN THE
LOW CARRIED BY THE U. S.
POPULATION.
WE BELIEVE IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
TOXINS CONTAINED ITHIN THIS
CHEMICAL FLAME RETARDANTS AND
THOSE COMPOUNDS RELEASED WHEN
THEY BURN CONTRIBUTE TO A HIGH
RATE OF CERTAIN CANCERS AMONG
FIREFIGHTERS.
EVERY TIME A FIREFIGHTER'S
ENTERS A STRUCTURE FIRE THEY ARE
CONFRONTED WITH HAZEN TOXINS IN
COMPOUNDS RELEASED BY SMOLDERING
FINER FURNITURE. EASE GASES
SEEPS INTO OUR PROTECTIVE
CLOTHING SOMETIMES PENETRATING
THE BREATHING APPARATUS
FIREFIGHTERS ALSO INHALED THEM
DIRECTLY DURING THE OVERHAUL AND
MOP UP OPERATIONS WHEN THEY ARE
WEARING THE BREATHING APPARATUS.
EVEN FIREFIGHTERS BACK IN THE
STATION ARE EXPOSED BECAUSE A
TOXIN STAY IN THE PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
NOT ONLY ARE THESE TALKS AS
DIRECT THREAT TO THE STATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
FIREFIGHTERS THEY POSE A SERIOUS
THREAT AND HEALTH AND SAFETY TO
THOSE.
WE ARE SWORN TO PROTECT
ESPECIALLY THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION OUR CHILDREN.
ALL THESE CHEMICALS DO IS CREATE
A HEALTH RISK FOR THE CONSUMERS
WHEN THEY DON'T BURN AS SERIOUS
TOXIC EXPOSURE RISK WHEN THEY
DO.
THEY DON'T PREVENT FIRES THEY
REALLY ONLY DO ONE THING AND
THAT IS TO MAKE MONEY FOR THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY.
THE AMOUNT OF ADDITIONAL
PROTECTION PROVIDED BY THESE
TOXIC RETARDANT IS MINIMAL FIRES
BURN HOTTER THAN THEY USED TO.
AND THE MATERIALS USED TO MAKE
FURNITURE CAN RENDER THESE
RETARDANTS ALMOST USELESS.
I BECAME A FIREFIGHTER KNOWING
THE DANGERS INVOLVED BUT NONE OF
US KNEW THAT WE WILL BE EXPOSED
TO SOMETHING THAT HAS NO REAL
PURPOSE.
AS A FIREFIGHTER A MOTHER AND
THE CONSUMER I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED
LEGISLATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOU TO DO THE SAME. THANK
YOU.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S A
MCCARTNEY IT'S AN ASTM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ABDULLAH BUT
I SUSPECT SOME OF THEM I AM THE
POLICY MANAGER AT THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
I'M HERE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE NINETY EIGHT TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES FROM TOXIC FROM
RETURNING CHEMICALS IT'S OF NO
EFFECTIVE PURPOSE AND FURNITURE
CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS AND
MATTRESSES.
FOR OVER TEN YEARS A CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAS BEEN
WORKING TO ROTECT PEOPLE FROM
THE PROVEN HEALTH THREATS OF
TOXIC FROM RETARDANT CHEMICALS.
INDEED PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES AND MANY FLAME
RETARDANT CHEMICALS INCLUDING
THOSE ADOPTED A SAFER
REPLACEMENTS ARE TOXIC TO
PEOPLE.
OFF TO OFTEN WE DISCOVER THAT
THE REPLACEMENT FOR MATERNA
CHEMICALS CAUSE MAJOR HEALTH
PROBLEMS SUCH AS REPRODUCTIVE
HARM TO BOTH WOMEN AND MEN.
DECEPTION TO THE BODY'S HORMONE
SYSTEM DECREASED IQ IN CHILDREN.
CANCER AND IMMUNE DISORDERS.
MANY OF THESE CHEMICALS.
FOR EXAMPLE EXEC A O'DONNELL HOW
JAY FROM RETARDANTS ARE ADDED TO
PRODUCTS MIGRATE INTO THE DUST.
AND LEAD TO CHRONIC IN HOME
EXPOSURE TO CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
I MUST ALSO KNOW.
EXPOSURE THESE TOXIC FROM
TURNING CHEMICALS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY STUDIES IN THE UNITED
STATES AND UNITED CLEAN UP
KINGDOM CLEARLY DEMONSTRATE
THREE ESSENTIAL FACT FAX
ONE.
AS USING FURNITURE JONES
PRODUCTS MARIN IF YOU COULD JUST
SOME ARE I WILL.
THESE THESE CHEMICALS DO NOT
PROVIDE ANY FIRE SAFETY.
ARE NOT NEEDED TO MEET THE
ABILITY STANDARDS AND PUT OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS THAT AT RISK
THANK YOU. ALRIGHT MINUTE NAP.
JEFFERSON QUIRK AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS OUT OF THE CAR I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE TWO
NINE NINE EIGHT.
AS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER CASANOVA
MENTIONED.
PLIMMERTON CHEMICALS ASSOCIATED
WITH MARRIED ADVERSE HEALTH
EFFECTS AND CALIFORNIANS ARE
ROUTINELY EXPOSED TO THESE
CHEMICALS TO PRODUCTS IN THEIR
HOMES.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS EXPOSURE
PERSISTS EVEN WHEN THESE
CHEMICALS DO NOT SEVER USEFUL
PURPOSE.
IN THE PRODUCTS.
CALIFORNIA'S BUREAU OF HOME
FURNISHINGS AND THERMAL
INSULATION HAS PREVIOUSLY FOUND
A FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS. DO
NOT PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL FIRE
SAFETY BENEFIT AND FURNITURE.
THE BUREAU REVISED IT'S TIME
ABILITY STANDARD TO PROVIDE FIRE
SAFETY WITHOUT FLAME RETARDANTS.
THE BUREAU HAS ALSO EXEMPTED
JUVENILE PRODUCTS COVERED BY THE
BILL FROM FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS
BECAUSE THE PRODUCTS DO NOT POSE
A SIGNIFICANT FIRE SAFETY RISK.
THE CONSUMER PRODUCT SAFETY
COMMISSION FEDERALLY ALL WHICH
SETS FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS FOR
MATTRESSES HAS STATED THAT FLAME
RETARDANTS ARE NOT NEEDED TO
MEET THAT STANDARD.
TESTING INDICATES THAT THE
MAJORITY OF PRODUCTS IN EACH OF
THESE CATEGORIES ARE ALREADY
BEEN PRODUCED WITHOUT FLAME
RETARDANT CHEMICALS.
UNFORTUNATELY A SIGNIFICANT
MINORITY OF LAGGARDS IN THESE
PRODUCT CATEGORIES CONTINUES TO
EXPOSE CALIFORNIANS DO THESE
DANGEROUS CHEMICALS.
THAT'S WHAT AB TWO NINE NINE
EIGHT AIMS TO ADDRESS AND THAT'S
WHY IT IS NEEDED.
WE ASK FOR A AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WE ARE CO SPONSORS
OF THIS FILM VERY PROUD TO BE IN
SUPPORT AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THEY GIVE.
DANIEL SO YOU KNOW ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL YOUR
BEHALF OF SITTING COUNTIES
HARRIS'S GOT SUPPORT.
ALEX ONLY SOME BEHALF OF THE
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY IN
SUPPORT.
AND DRIVEN HER WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT FOR THE
REASONS STATED AND BECAUSE THESE
CHEMICALS WERE BECOMING EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS IN OUR WATER.
MOURNING GARB ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
FILL OUT LEO ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT.
LISA VAN FLEET BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
JUST RUN WITH A SEVENTH
GENERATION ADVISES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARM WERE NOW GOING TO
BRING UP THE OPPOSITION IF TWO
OF YOU CAN STAY UP HERE AND TAKE
THE TWO CHAIRS CLOSER TO ME
WHICHEVER TO PREFER THAT.
I PREFER TO STAY AND THEN WE'D
BRING UP AND LET TWO CHAIRS FOR
THE OPPOSITION.
VERY GOOD.
ALRIGHT PLEASE JACK COME UP LISA
STARK TESTIMONY GREAT THANK YOU
SIR.
MY NAME IS JAY WESTON I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE PERHAPS
GET A LITTLE CLOSER AND
MICROPHONES.
THE LAKE HERE TO CONTEND.
YOU CAN MOVE THE MICROPHONE
TOWARDS YOU THAT'LL MAKE IT A
LITTLE EASIER.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE NORTH
AMERICAN FLAME RETARDANT LIGHTS
OF THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL IN WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
SOME FIRST AS A POLICY MATTER WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS OVERLY
BROAD AND AND IT'S HARD ANTI
INNOVATION. THE DEFINITION OF
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICAL IN THIS
BILL WOULD NOT ONLY TO RESTRICT
THE USE OF FLAME RETARDANTS
CURRENTLY ON THE MARKET. BUT IT
WOULD RESTRICT THE USE OF ANY
FRAME WHICH HARDEN IN THE
FUTURE.
THE BILL WOULD RESTRICT
SUBSTANCES THAT HAVE YET TO BE
CONTEMPLATED REGARDLESS OF THEIR
CHEMICAL COMPOSITION. THEIR
HAZARD PROPERTIES ANY EXPOSURE
POTENTIAL.
YOU COULD DESIGN THE GREENEST
MOST SUSTAINABLE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE FLAME RETARDANT
SUBSTANCE IMAGINABLE AND THIS
BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT AND NEVER
SAW THE LIGHT OF DAY.
WE BELIEVE THAT MANUFACTURERS
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE MOST
MODERN APPROPRIATE FLAME
RETARDANT TECHNOLOGIES IS PART
OF THEIR OVERALL FIRE SAFETY
TOOL BOX IN THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
THAT IMPOSSIBLE.
SECONDLY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCT
PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM REQUIRES PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS TO ANALYZE THE USE
OF SUBSTANCES IN THEIR PRODUCTS
AGAINST POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES.
THE PROCESS HAS TO INCLUDE LIFE
CYCLE ASSESSMENT WHICH MAKES
THEM HAVE TO CONSIDER TRADE OFFS
SUCH AS GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AIR AND WATER QUALITY IMPACTS
PRODUCT FUNCTION PERFORMANCE
WASTED END OF LIFE DISPOSAL.
ALONG WITH HAZARD AND EXPOSURE.
UNDER THE NEW PROGRAM ARE UNDER
THAT DTS YOU PROGRAM THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO HAS BROAD
AUTHORITY TO APPROVE IMPOSE A
VARIETY OF RISK MANAGEMENT
MEASURES RANGING FROM
PROHIBITIONS TO LABELING AND
NUMEROUS OTHER OPTIONS THAT THEY
SHOULD CAN DENY SO SORRY.
YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW THAT DTS HE
IS ACTIVELY CONSIDERING FLAME
RETARDANTS UNDER THEIR PROGRAM.
IN JULY OF LAST YEAR THEY BEGIN
A PROCESS TO EXAMINE THE USE OF
TO FLAME RETARDANTS IN
CHILDREN'S PADDED SLEEPING
PRODUCTS.
AND IN THEIR RECENT DRAFT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWENTY WORK PLAN
BELA SEVERAL PRODUCTS CATEGORIES
AND CHEMICALS THAT THEY MAY BE
THAT MIGHT BE USED IN THOSE
CATEGORIES SORRY. AND FLAME
RETARDANTS ARE AMONG THOSE
CHEMICALS SO FLAME RETARDANT
SOME PRODUCTS ARE SQUARELY IN
DTS SEES FOCUS.
AND THEN FINALLY MY LAST POINT.
THIS BILL IS ALSO UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S FURNITURE
LABORING LAW GIVES CONSUMERS THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE FLAME
RETARDANTS ARE NOT.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW THAT
REQUIRES LABELING ON RESIDENTIAL
FURNITURE TO INFORM CONSUMERS OF
WHETHER THEIR PURCHASES INCLUDE
FLAME RETARDANTS ARE NOT.
BOB COMPANIES CAN BE FINED FOR
NOT PRODUCED PROVIDING THE
CORRECT INFORMATION AND NOT
KEEPING THE CORRECT RECORDS WHEN
INSPECTORS COME AROUND.
.
SO JUST IN SUMMARY ON THIS POINT
THE FURNITURE LABELING LAWLESS
STREETS WHY THIS BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY. BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATORS ART ESTABLISHED A
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE CONSUMERS
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PRESENCE OR ABSENCE OF FLAME
RETARDANTS AND MAKE THEIR OWN
CHOICE. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY AND WE URGE YOU TO.
HAVE A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
A GERMAN COURT MEMBERS THE
CANADIAN MY NAME IS ANDY
HAPPENED HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE PRODUCTS MANUFACTURES
AND.
ECHO SOME OF THE POINTS THAT
WERE MADE EARLIER BUT.
OUR INDUSTRY HAS MOVED AWAY
FROM FLAME RETARDANTS WHETHER
NOT TECHNICALLY NECESSARY WE'VE
WORKED WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ON TV ONE SEVENTEEN
TO HAVE JUVENILE PARKS EXEMPTED
EMBOSS WERE PRETTY TSC TO MAKE
SURE THAT INFORMATION AND AND
OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE
MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE.
UNDERSTAND IN AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION OUR PRODUCT
CATEGORIES AND WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THIS LEGISLATION
AS REGARDS TO STATEWIDE
UNIFORMITY HAS MENTIONED WORKED
WITH. DGSE AND.
WITH.
THE STATE ON TV ONE SEVENTEEN.
YOU MIGHT BE AWARE THAT SAN
FRANCISCO HAS MOVED FOR WITH AN
ORDINANCE IN THIS AREA AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL HAS
EXEMPTED SPECIFICALLY CAR SEATS
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO MEET
CERTAIN FLAME RESISTANT
STANDARDS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
LEVEL UNDER NHTSA. AND ALSO
EXEMPTED ELECTRONIC COMPONENTS
TO HAVE TO MEET UL STANDARDS
GENERALLY WOULD REQUIRE FLAME
RETARDANTS TO MEET US
PERFORMANCE CHARACTERISTICS.
THIS BILL EXEMPTS THOSE THOSE
SPECIFIC COMPONENTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
STATE WHAT UNIFORMITY ON THAT
ASPECT SPECIFICALLY SAN
FRANCISCO DOES NOT ADDRESS
ELECTRONIC COMPONENTS WHICH HAD
BEEN BEEN ADDRESSED IT PERFECTLY
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM IS TAKEN.
SO WE'D ENCOURAGE OUR TO BE SOME
APPRECIATE THE TIME TODAY AND
KANSEN QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARM AND YOU.
BOTH TOOK JUST FOR OUR FOUR
MINUTES AND FIFTEEN SECONDS
CONGRATULATIONS YOU WERE FIFTEEN
SECONDS DATA.
A SHORT AT LAW SHORT YEAH
IT'S GREAT.
A.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MELISSA HONOR ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
PAT RILEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
JOHN KEPT YOU BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATIONAL SOAP.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOM SHE HE HERE
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL SLEEP
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
THE. NATIONAL YOU COULD TAKE A
MINUTE OR TWO I LIKE HOW YOU
COULD TAKE TAKE ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS THANK YOU BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU HAVE A PARTICULAR CONCERN UP
BE VERY BRIEF OF THANK YOU.
WE DO REPRESENT THE MATTRESS
MANUFACTURES THE UNITED STATES.
I'M THIS BILL HAS CURRENTLY
CONSTRUED THE DEFINITION OF
FLAME RETARDANT SO BROAD. A MY
MANUFACTURES A TELLING ME THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SELL
MATTRESSES INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE BILL'S
CURRENTLY AMEND.
HIS WERE GONNA HAVE TO WORK ON
THE DEFINITION.
OTHERS PROBABLY NOT TIME RIGHT
NOW TO GO INTO DETAIL Y. DID
HAVE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE OF THESE ISSUES
ARE ON THE TABLE. BOMB I WILL
TELL YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
OUR INDUSTRY STOP USING
BROMINATED FIRE RETARDANTS AND
OTHER CHEMICAL FIREBIRD FIRE
RETARDANTS IN THE FOAM
MATTRESSES WERE THE MAIN ENERGY
SOURCES. WE STOP USING THOSE
YEARS AGO UP AND THE TO THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE USED OUT TO
KEEP THE PHONE FROM IGNITING.
DON'T INVOLVE THE TYPES OF TOP
TOXIC MATERIALS THAT WE BELIEVE
THE AUTHOR IS ZEROING IN ON THIS
BILL. SO IN SUMMARY WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THE
DEFINITION OF FLAME RETARDANT SO
BROAD WE WILL BE ABLE TO SELL
OUR PRODUCT IN THE ST LOUIS IT'S
REFINED. AND WE DON'T USE THE
TYPE OF CHEMICALS TO STOP FIRES
FROM IGNITING OUR MATTRESSES
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TARGETING IN
THIS BILL. AND OUT WE WOULD OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
ALRIGHT THOUGHT QUESTIONS.
MISTER MURSHID TREAT YOU
QUESTION. YES YOU ALWAYS GO AND
MY MIND.
.
SO.
IT WAS ONE OF HERE EL.
INDEED THE POINT MADE ABOUT HER.
BANNING ANY.
ATTENTIONAL FEATURE.
ARE.
* INSTEAD.
MAYOR MAY NOT BE A TOXIC OR
HARMFUL.
TWO FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER AND
AND JUVENILES.
I THINK THE FIRST QUESTION WE
HAVE TO ASK IS WHETHER THERE IS
ANY RETARDANT THAT'S NECESSARY
IN ANY OF THESE PRODUCTS. AND
THE UNDERSTANDING I HAVE IS THAT
THERE IS NO NECESSITY. ON IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO DRAFT LANGUAGE
OF ABOUT SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT SOME FUTURE PRODUCT.
.
AND AS SOON AS WE OPENED THAT
DOOR.
YOU COULD BE INVITING. OF OUR
ANY CHEMICAL CHANGE.
THE ARE TO BECOME A NEW PRODUCT
RIGHTS IF YOU CHANGE THE
FORMULATION OF WHAT IS CURRENTLY
BEING USED IN LIMITED.
OF A PRODUCT'S TODAY BUT IF YOU
WERE TO MAKE.
A CHEMICAL CHANGE THEN IT
BECOMES A NEW.
SUBSTANCE.
OUT SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
DRAFT AROUND THAT I'M WILLING TO
TRY AND I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THE CHAIR IS INTERESTED IN
WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT IT. AND I
WANT TO KEEP THE DOOR OPEN TO A
ARRIVING AT SOME LANGUAGE BUT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO.
.
A TO FIND A LIE IDEA A A A.
AWAY OF A OPENING THE DOOR TO
INNOVATION.
THAT IS NARROW ENOUGH
SAID THAT IT DOESN'T INVITE
REFORMULATION THAT WOULD OF WHAT
WE KNOW TODAY IT'S TOXIC.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
OF.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS DAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES
AND THOSE WHO SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE.
ARM YOU MAY CLOSE.
A OF THERE BUT AND NUMBER OF
FOLLOW UP UP POINTS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION THAT INVOLVE A.
ISSUES OF DRAFTING AND REFINING
LANGUAGE A A COMMIT TO CONTINUE
A SPEAKING TO OPPOSITION ABOUT.
HOPEFULLY FINDING CA LANGUAGE
THAT EVERYONE CAN LIVE WITH.
A.
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY RECALLING
PCA CAPTAIN LOW'S.
REMARKS BECAUSE AS SHE WAS
MAKING HER REMARKS AT FTA A AND
IT MADE ME REALIZE THAT WE HAVE.
TWO GROUPS THAT WERE PRIMARILY
INTERESTED IN HERE CHILDREN AND
FIREFIGHTERS WHO ARE EXPOSED TO.
A A A TO THESE CHEMICALS UP IN
THE CASE OF FIREFIGHTERS.
THEY ARE EXPOSED AS CHILDREN.
AND AS FIREFIGHTERS SO THEY
REALLY EXPERIENCE THIS OF TWICE
THAT KIND OF A DOUBLE WHAMMY FOR
THEM.
OF THIS IS A VERY REAL ISSUE WE
KNOW THAT RESPONSIBLE
MANUFACTURERS ARE NO LONGER
USING THESE CHEMICALS. AND IT IS
TIME TO END THE USE ENTIRELY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I ASK
FOR YOUR OF THE.
OKAY. ARM A COUPLE OF THINGS
FIRST OF ALL FOR THE MATTRESS
FOLKS.
OF WHAT IT SAYS IS THAT IT IS
THAT THEY'RE SPANNING A
CHEMICAL.
THAT'S IN THE DATA SHEET AND I
DON'T THINK THAT WHAT YOU DO
WITH MASTERS HIS WILL EVER BE IN
THAT AS A CHEMICAL IN THE DATA
SHEET BUT.
A WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE OF THAT
BUT THIS. YOU KNOW THAT WHAT
THEIR BANNING ARE CHEMICALS THAT
SHOW UP AS FLAVORING TARGETS IN
THE DATA SHEET I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT.
THAT'S AN ISSUE BUT WE SHOULD
DEBT TAKE A LOOK AT THAT'S MORE
AND JUST MAKE SURE.
IN REGARD TO.
MEETING FEDERAL STANDARDS AND I
GUESS WHAT YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
IS THAT FEDERAL STE FIRST WELL
TWO THINGS.
YOU'RE WORRIED THAT.
CHAIRMANSHIPS GO IS NOT
ALLOWING.
PEOPLE TO MEET THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS
FOR ELECTRONICS
AND.
IS THAT CORRECT
SO THIS SAN FRANCISCO ORDINANCE
IS NOT ON DOES NOT HAVE THE SAME
EXCLUSIONS THAT TO THE
BILL THAT'S PENDING HERE HAS.%
AS OF ELECTRONIC.
I'M THERE GONNA REQUIRE PETITION
PROCESS SUMMER UNCERTAIN ON
WHERE THAT'S GOING TO TAKE US.
FIVE SO IF WE COULD MAKE
SEPARATE SISTER RETROACTIVELY
CONSISTENT OR WE PROVIDED
LANGUAGE TO TRY TO TO GET TO THE
ISSUE OF HAVING ONE STATEWIDE
STANDARD. WHERE THESE TWO
PRODUCT CATEGORIES THAT ARE
REQUIRED?
VIA THE FEDERAL STANDARDS TO
HAVE SOME FLAME RETARDANTS
CONTENT QATARIS I KNOW.
YOU KNOW ON THE BAG ISSUE AND
OTHERS WE'VE HAD THAT'S KIND OF
CONCERN. AND AGAIN I I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR COULD NOT
WORK WITH THAT AND THAT WILL
PROBABLY NEED TO TALK WITH
PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO BUT I
THINK. THE WAY HE HAS DONE HIS
BILL IS CORRECT AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN BRING SAN FRANCISCO ALONG IN
THIS.
WITH REGARD TO.
A FUTURE BREAKTHROUGH.
I THINK THERE IS A WAY TO DO IT
AND THAT WOULD INVOLVE THE
FIREFIGHTERS SAYING.
WE NEED SOMETHING THAT IT IF THE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE COME UP.
WITH SOMETHING THAT DOES THE
JOB.
THAT THE FIREFIGHTERS THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
AND THEY COME FORWARD AND SAY WE
NEED THIS I THINK THAT IS A
REASONABLE WAY TO LOOK AT IT.
AND THEN.
WE WOULD THEN HAVE TO PROVE
THAT IT'S SAFE.
AND AGAIN I WOULD ASK THE
MANUFACTURES TO PAY FOR THAT
PROCESS.
I THINK THAT THAT'S ONE WAITED
TO DRESS THIS THERE COULD BE
OTHERS. ARM AND I JUST ASK THAT
YOU KEEP UP THAT OPEN WITH ME
AND I KNOW YOU WELL. AND EITHER
CONVINCED ME THAT THIS ISN'T A
CUT PROCESS HERE THERE'S ANOTHER
PROCESS THAT GUTTER THERE IS NO
PROCESS.
I I'M I'M CERTAINLY VERY OPEN ON
THIS SIDE LIKE TO INVOLVE THE
MANUFACTURERS AS WELL.
I DO THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO.
LEAVE THE WAY OPEN BUT NOT IN A
WAY THAT POISONS FIREFIGHTERS.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIND.
OR OR CHILDREN OR ANYONE ELSE SO
THAT'S A LOT TO ASK AND.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN DO IT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT UP COULD EVER MOTION.
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION ALRIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY CALLED CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT BLOOM
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACYAND CONSUMER PROTECTION.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
MELENDEZ.
ARAMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MURATSUCHI I.
MATTEUCCI I KNOW THREE WELL IT
UNANIMOUS BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MEMBERS TO GET IT OUT SO
I THINK YOU MISTER KIT WILL SEE
HOW IT GOES AND DATA.
I'M PRETTY SURE WE'LL GET IT OUT
IN THE END.
ALRIGHT.
MISTER HOLDEN.
OUR YOU HAVE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY
.
YOU MAY NOT FIRE WHEN READY
MISTER HOLDEN OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE A THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PERCENT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TODAY.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
STATE WATER. RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO ADOPT REQUIREMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT CHILD CARE CENTERS
DRINKING WATER IS LEAD FREE.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS ALL
LICENSED CHILD DAYCARE
FACILITIES TO BORROW NO INTEREST
LOANS
TO PAY FOR LEAD CLEANUP. AND
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
IMPROVEMENTS.
DRINKING WATER AT MOST CHILDCARE
CENTERS IS NOT TESTED FOR LEAD.
THIS IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE MANY
WATER PIPES FAUCETS AND FIXTURES
STILL IN USE CONTAIN LEAD.
AND OVER TIME THIS LEAD CAN
LEACH
INTO THE DRINKING WATER.
YET WE KNOW YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
THE MOST HARMED BY LEAD BECAUSE
THEY ABSORB MUCH.
OF THE LEAD THEY INGEST.
ACCORDING TO MAKE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
IN CHILDREN.
LEAD IS A SEVERE NEUROTOXIN.
EVEN MINUTE AMOUNTS OF LEAD IN
THE BODIES OF VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN CAUSE HARM TO THEIR
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEMS. AND
THIS HARM APPEARS TO BE
IRREVERSIBLE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY WILL
HELP KEEP YOUNG CHAU YOUNGEST
CHILDREN SAVED BY ENSURING THEY
ARE NOT IN JUSTIN LET THROUGH
THE WATER THEY DRINK.
I HAVE WITH ME ANDREA VENTURA
FROM CLEAN WATER ACTION AND
SALUTE SUSAN LITTLE FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
OUGHT TO JOIN ME IN PRESENTING
THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVALS LOOK THE BILL.
SECOND.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS SUSAN
LITTLE AND WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AS YOU KNOW EXPOSURE JUST AS TO
JUST A TINY AMOUNT OF LEAD CAN
REDUCE A CHILD'S IQ AND
COGNITIVE ABILITIES. AND YOUNG
CHILDREN ABSORB FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE LEAD THEY INGEST.
IF THERE MARK IF THEY'RE
MALNOURISHED THEY ABSORB EVEN
FASTER
SO IT'S NOT A SURPRISE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH STATES THAT EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF LEAD POISONED
CHILDREN. COME FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND THESE FAMILIES
OFTEN RECEIVE SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE.
BECAUSE CHILDCARE CENTERS DON'T
HAVE TO TEST THEIR DRINKING
WATER FOR LEAD WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW. IF THERE WATER CONTAINS A
NEUROTOXIN BUT TESTING THAT HAS
BEEN DONE. INDICATES THAT SOME
CENTERS HAVE A PROBLEM.
RECENTLY THE DRINKING WATER ONE
EAST OAKLAND CHILDCARE CENTER
WAS SHOWN TO HAVE SEVENTEEN
TIMES. THE ALLOWABLE LIMIT OF
LEAD.
AND A PILOT PROJECT PERFORMED BY
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
INVOLVING ELEVEN CENTERS IN FORT
ST IN FOUR STATES.
FOUND THAT A THIRD OF THOSE
CENTERS HAD DRINKING WATER WITH
LEAD LEVELS WELL ABOVE THE EPA
STANDARD.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY REQUIRES
DSS TO ENFORCE THE EXISTING
DRINKING WATER REQUIREMENTS.
AND ALLOWS CENTERS AND
FACILITIES
TO YOU TO USE AND UNDER UTILIZED
NO INTEREST LOAN PROGRAM TO PAY
FOR LED REMEDIATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
TIGER HEAD GASKET TWO AND HALF
MINUTES SHE WAS FAST. PERFECT
THANK YOU.
HI I'M ANDREA VENTURA I AM THE
TOXICS PROGRAM MANAGER FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION. OF OUR
ORGANIZATION WORKS TO PRESERVE
AND PROTECT DRINKING WATER.
AND WATER RESOURCES AND WE ARE
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
COALITION CALLED THE LET'S
SERVICE LINE COLLABORATIVE.
WHICH ARE NGOS PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES AND WATER AGENCIES
TRYING TO ELIMINATE LEAD FROM
OUR WATER OUR DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS.
AS MS A LITTLE JUST ALLUDED TO
IN A WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN IT
TURNS OUT THAT CHILDREN. UNDER
THE AGE OF TWO YOU ARE PRETTY
DOT HEARD PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE.
BECAUSE YOUNGER CHILDREN.
APPS ACTUALLY ABSORB MORE LEAD.
AND ALL OF THE GROWING BRAINS
ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO CHANGE.
FORMULA FED INFANTS
ARE EVEN A GREATER RISK ARE THEY
CONSUME THE MOST WATER PER BODY
WEIGHT AND SIXTY PERCENT OF
BABIES ARE EXCLUSIVELY FORM
FORMULA FED SO THEY'RE CONSUMING
UP TO FOUR.
OF WATER A DAY.
NOW WHAT WE DO HAVE A LEAD AND
COPPER RULE IN CALIFORNIA THE
PROTECT DRINKING WATER SOURCES.
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IS IT'S THE
CONNECTIONS WITHIN THE BUILDINGS
THAT ARE CAUSING THE
CONTAMINATION IN THE PROBLEM AND
EXPOSURES.
AND OUR CURRENT REGULATORY
PROGRAM CANNOT OVERSEE ALL OF
THESE BUILDINGS.
ABOUT LAST YEARS SIMPLY BILL
SEVEN FORTY SIX AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER BEGAN TO ADDRESS THIS
CONCERN BY REQUIRING TESTING.
OF TAPS AT SCHOOLS BUILT BEFORE
TWENTY TEN.
THAT TESTING IS HAPPENING AND
WE'RE FINDING THAT FIVE PERCENT
OF THE TYPES THAT HAVE BEEN
TESTED THUS FAR.
ARE ABOVE THE OFFICIAL
DETECTION LIMIT OF FIVE PARTS
PER BILLION. AND.
AND AS MANY HAVE UP TO FIFTEEN
PARTS PER BILLION SO THE PROBLEM
IS VERY REAL WE BELIEVE THAT THE
RESULTS OF TESTING TO DATE
WARRANT. THE EXPANSION OF THE
TESTING REQUIREMENT TO INCLUDE
ALL LICENSED DAYCARE CENTERS TO
PROTECT THOSE THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR POPULATION.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE HERE AND
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
OKAY NOW THERE'S IN SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH OUR CAN YOU
SEE P. CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
AND SUPPORT.
DANIEL SILVINO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION.
DOES NOT LOOK LIKE IT.
ALRIGHT. ARM ON MISTER HOLDEN
SPELL WHICH IS.
TESTING FOR LAND IN CHILDCARE
FACILITIES.
MADAM VICE CHAIR DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WE REDO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
WHAT DO YOU WANT US TO GIVE YOU
A MINUTE NOW SEE?
YEAH GIVE ME A MINUTE I DID YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS MISS
FRIEDMAN.
ALRIGHT WE'LL JUST WAIT TO YOUR
READY DON'T DON'T RUSH YOURSELF.
WE'VE GOT TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APOLOGIZE FOR I'M HAVING A STEP
OUT BRIEFLY SO.
.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT IN
IN THIS CASE.
.
PARENTS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO ARE
ASKED
TO PROVIDE.
A BLOOD TEST
FOR THEIR CHILD.
TO THE.
CHILD CARE FACILITIES ARE
CRACKED.
A FIGURES ON MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE ASK IF THEIR CHILD
HAS BEEN TESTED HER. AND IF
THEY'VE BEEN TESTED THEN
OBVIOUSLY.
PROVIDING.
THE RESULTS OF THAT I DON'T KNOW
IF WE'RE.
ACTUALLY REQUIRING.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IF THE
THERE WOULD BE A QUESTION ASK
BECAUSE YOUR CHILD. BEEN TESTED
FOR BLOOD POURS.
OKAY AND THAT EXPLOSION
EXPOSURES.
SO IF IT'S. I GUESS IF IT'S NOT
REQUIRED THEN.
.
APART BE HARD TO TRACK HER
IDENTIFY IF. OR EITHER IF THERE
IS A PROBLEM IF THERE ISN'T
RIGHT.
ITS THAT'S THE POINT OF THIS I
THINK. IS TO FIGURE OUT WHERE.
WHICH
CHILDREN ARE HAVING IN IT
ELEVATED LEVEL OF LEAD IN THEIR
SYSTEMS THAT MAY BE FROM THEIR
WATER SUPPLY IN SO WE WANT THE
TESTING TO BE DONE SO WE CAN.
RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT OKAY.
AND SO IF THEY'RE NOT.
.
REQUIRED TO DO THE TEST THEN I
GUESS IT'S HARDER TO.
I GUESS FOR ME I FEEL LIKE I
DON'T KNOW IF I COULD BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS AND
REASON WHY.
THE BILL ALSO CALLS OUT THE.
LOWERS LOW INTEREST LOAN THAT'S
AVAILABLE IS SO THAT THE. THE
OPERATORS COULD ALSO BE RESPOND
BOSS WILL BE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR ENSURING THAT THERE'S THAT
THAT THEY CAN DO THE REPAIRS IF
THERE HAS REPAIRS THAT ARE
NECESSARY WHERE THROUGH THE
PIPES THE FAUCETS.
IF THERE WAS SOME TESTING DONE
TO. THE EFFORT STRUCTURE
DETERMINED THAT THERE IS LED.
IN THE PIPES THAT IT COULD LEADS
INTO THE WATER. THEN THERE'S A
FINANCIAL.
SAFEGUARD WE WILL.
TO ALLOW FOR THOSE OF PROVIDERS
TO BE ABLE TO. MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE.
.
IMPROVEMENTS.
I GUESS I'M I'M.
AS A PARENT WHO'S HAD KIDS GO
THROUGH NOT DAYCARE BUT
PRESCHOOL.
.
WHY ARE WE NOT JUST?
SAYING TO THESE FACILITIES YOU
MUST HAVE YOUR WATER TESTED.
ANNUALLY YEAR BIANNUALLY RATHER
THAN.
PUT THE BURDEN ON THE PARENTS.
TEST TO MAKE SURE THAT.
EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY FUNNY.
PLEASE DO.
SO THE BILL HAS ESSENTIALLY TWO
PARTS ONE IS THE PART THAT
REQUIRES THE FACILITIES TO TEST
HER WALK WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY.
IT'S REQUIRED DSS TO FIGURE TO
ESTABLISH A TESTING REQUIREMENT
FOR WATER IN THAT CHILD CARE
FACILITIES.
AND THAT'S TO KICK THAT'S TO
ENFORCE THE EXISTING.
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY HAVE TO
PROVIDE NON CONTAMINATED WATER
TO THE CHILDREN.
SEPARATE FROM THAT AND STE AND
SIMILAR TO WHAT SIX OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE AS WELL AS THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO.
IT REQUIRES THE FOR PROVIDERS
JUST TO CHECK IN WITH THE
PARENTS AND
ASK THEM IF THEY'VE GOTTEN.
THERE HAD THEIR CHILD BLOOD LET
TESTED MANY OF THESE PARENTS
OUR PARENTS RIVERS AND ONE CAL
WORKS AND THERE THAT CHILDCARE
VOUCHERS SO THEY WOULD BE THEIR
CHILDREN IDEALLY.
SHOULD BE HAVING THEIR BLOOD
LIKE TACITUS AT LEAST UNDER ARM.
CURRENT STATUS OF TESTING
PRACTICES.
SO.
WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE DONE AND
WHAT THIS AGAIN IS PROPOSING TO
DO IS TO? HAVE THE PROVIDERS
ESSENTIALLY BE A SORT OF A POINT
OF CHECKIN.
IT'S NOT THAT THE CHILD CAN
STILL BE ENROLLED IN THE
FACILITY IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD
THEIR BLOOD LEAD TESTED AND WHAT
AND.
IF THEY IF THEY HAVE.
THAT'S FINE IF THEY HAVEN'T THAN
ALL THE BUILD REQUIRES THE
PROVIDER TO DO. IS TO HAND OVER
INFORMATION TO.
PARENTS ABOUT BLOOD BLOOD
TESTING SO AT THE END BLOOD LEAD
AND SHE'S BEEN LED WRISTS.
.
SO WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
IS THEY.
THE IS THEY COLLECT FROM THE
PARENT THEN SOME SORT OF CALM.
PROOF PAPER DEMONSTRATING THAT
THERE WAS A TEST IF THAT.
TAKES PLACE IF THAT HAS HAPPENED
ON THIS BILL ITSELF ISN'T
REQUIRING THAT RIGHT NOW IS IT
REQUIRING THE DOCUMENTATION.
JUST SIMPLY THE VERBAL CHECKIN.
BUT THERE OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
THE DOG REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION
AS PART OF IT.
YEAH THAT CAME.
I MIGHT SAY THAT THE VICE CHAIR
WE HAD A VERY LONG HEARING. ON
THIS ISSUE SHALL ARE KIDS WHO
ARE ON.
.
MEDI CAL A WEEK'S PROGRAM.
INFERIOR REQUIRED
TO HAVE THIS TEST DONE ON SOME
DO AND SOME DON'T AND WE WERE
TRYING TO GET OUT. AND AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THEY
TYPICALLY LIVE IN OLDER HOMES
WHERE THERE'S A POSSIBILITY OF
LEAD CONTAMINATION NEED DURING
THE PIPES OF THE PAINTER BUT
EVER.
BUT THERE ISN'T.
GREAT COMPLIANCE NOW AGAIN ON
TO THOSE PROGRAMS IF THE TEST IS
PAID FOR.
SO WE'RE NOT PUTTING A BURDEN ON
THE PARENTS IN THIS IS JUST
ASKING FOR A CHECK AND. SO ARM.
DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING AND IF
THEY ARE.
.
NOT CAPABLE OF PAIN THAT CHANCES
ARE THE KIDS ARE ON THE PROGRAM
THAT WILL PAY FOR IT CHAU.
A I THINK WHERE I THINK I THINK
WE YEAH AND I HOPE THAT RESOLVES
THE ISSUE IN YOUR MIND.
OKAY SORT OF LARA.
I'M LIKE YEAH ANY CONCERN YOU
HAVE IS A CONCERN OF MINE.
OKAY THANK YOU. PAM I THINK YEAH
I JUST.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY HAVE ANY
CONCERNS. ABOUT. THAT AND WE'RE
DEBT.
OKAY.
NOW I.
AGAIN WITH MANY OF THE BILLS
THAT HAVE COME THROUGH TODAY I I
AM IT WITH YOU. AND AND THE AND
THE CONCEPT I JUST HAD SOME
CONCERNS I'M STILL A LITTLE
HESITANT SO MAD AND AND MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE WANTS TO.
CHINA MANNER DO JERRY CHINAMEN.
NOW BOY HERE OUT OF AND WHAT IS
YOUR WHAT IS THE CONCERN
EXACTLY.
WELL I ALSO AND I DIDN'T RATE IT
IT'S.
HERE IN MY ANALYSIS ARE
DIFFERENT AND HAS TO DO WITH.
.
THE STANDARDS THAT ARE BEING
SAID IT IS IT THE SAME AS. THE
STANDARD FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
AS FAR AS THE PARTS.
A THE PBS WOULD THE PARTS PARTS
PER BILLION YET PERSON.
IS IT THE SAME STANDARD OF
TESTING.
UP BECAUSE I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT IT'S NOT BUT
MAYBE MISSED THE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION WHERE YOU SAID IT IS.
IT IS ACTUALLY WHAT IT'S DOING
ITS DIFFERENCE.
DIFFERENT FROM THE LEAD TESTING
IN SCHOOLS REQUIREMENTS WHERE IT
WAS ALL LAID OUT IN THE BILL.
THIS BILL IS REQUIRING DE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE WATER BOARD
TO DETERMINE HOW THE TESTING IS
GOING TO TAKE PLACE WHICH
INCLUDES THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
IS LEAD SAFE.
SO IT'S NOT FOLLOWING FEDERAL
GUIDELINES FOR OTHERS LAKE
GUIDELINES FOR KEY THROUGH TRIAL
AND AND THAT IS WHY. BY IT
SPECIFICALLY JUST WE DECIDED IT
WAS BETTER PROP BE BECAUSE.
THAT ISSUE THE THE QUESTION OF
WHAT IS.
THIS THIS SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD FOR
THE CHILDCARE FACILITIES ISLAM.
IT'S SUBJECT TO.
THE WATER BOARDS RIGHT
DETERMINATION AS TO WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE SO YOU'RE LEADING
EXPERTS DECIDE EXACTLY WE'RE
LETTING THE EXPERTS MAKE THAT
DECISION AS TO WHAT SHOULD BE IN
THERE AND AND. AND THE WATER
BOARD IS ACTUALLY. LOOKING AT
THE LEAD STANDARD FOR WATER
RIGHT NOW AND SO WE DON'T WANT
TO LEGISLATE THEN. IN THE BILL
NAM.
AND THINK IT'S JUST BETTER THAT
THE REGULAR TO REGULATORS TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT SAID IN THIS REGARD
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE. YET
TWO YEARS OUT BEFORE THE TESTING
IS ACTUALLY REQUIRED.
I THINK SHE MIGHT HAVE HAD
SOMETHING THAT I JUST WANTED YOU
HAVE SINCE I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY THAT.
I THINK IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO.
.
HAVE THE EXPERTS LOOK AT THIS
BECAUSE THERE IS AS I IT
TESTIFIED WE ARE FINDING THAT
LED IS MOST TOXIC TO CHILDREN
UNDER SIX AND EVEN MORE TOXIC TO
CHILDREN UNDER TWO. UM AND
INFANTS AND BABIES BECAUSE THEY
ARE CONSUMING MORE WATER AND
OBSERVED AND ABSORBING MORE LEAD
SO THERE MAY BE AN AGE
DIFFERENTIAL. THE EXPERTS WOULD
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT.
FOR.
SO I I THINK WE'VE PRETTY WELL
DEFINED AT I DON'T KNOW IF.
THE VICE CHAIR IS.
.
HAPPY OR NOT BUT.
BUT AT LEAST I THINK WE'VE
DEFINED ENOUGH FOR YOU NOW OKAY
GOOD.
ALRIGHT. ARM.
SEE YOU HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION
YET.
YES YES OKAY.
ALRIGHT THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION
AND A SECOND.
I'D LIKE YOU TO CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
THE CONVERSATION I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT.
I AM ALWAYS A
SERVE SHOCK SOMETIMES WHAT I SEE
ISSUES THAT HAVE NOT ALREADY
BEEN ADDRESSED THROUGH
LEGISLATION OR SOME TYPE OF.
ABOUT ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS IN
THIS IS ONE OF THEM. WHEN YOU
THINK THAT YOU HAVE SO MANY OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO. ARE IN
SHOCK FOR CHILDCARE FACILITIES
EVERY SINGLE DAY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEY'RE EXPOSED OF THIS BECOMES
A VERY NECESSARY BILL TO PUT A
LIGHT AND.
ATTENTION IN A VERY IMPORTANT
AREA AND START TO TREAT OUR
YOUNGEST AS WE TREAT OUR OLDEST.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE I'VE
OF.
TORRENT. ARM I'LL GIVE YOU THE
I'VE OF.
PURCHASE OF MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY HOLDEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS IN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN IS NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
PEROT.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN I'VE HOLDEN AYE MATTEUCCI
NOT HERE SAID THREE VOTES.
HOLD IT OF.
ALL RIGHT ARM IS ANYONE'S DO WE
HAVE ANY AUTHORS BESIDES ME WERE
HAVING PRETENDED YET.
OKAY WELL WHEN MEASURED
MURATSUCHI COMES BACK WELL HAVE
HIM PRESENT HIS BILL.
ARE IN THE MEANTIME I WILL START
PRESENTING MY BELLS.
.
SO.
I WILL.
IF YES I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE.
AT THE GAVEL HERE
ALRIGHT I'LL TAKE MY OF BILLS IN
NUMERICAL ORDER. TOP FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE.
THE STAFF HERE AND IN MY OWN
STAFF.
THIS IS NOT AN AREA WHERE I
LEGISLATED UNTIL I BECAME A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. AND I'M
VERY PLEASED NOW.
TO WORK IN THAT.
MISTER MURSHID SHOULD YOU WANT
TO PRESENT BEFORE I DO OUR NOW
YOU'RE OKAY CHAIR ALRIGHT.
IF
IF YOU. NEED TO.
YOU CAN INTERRUPT ME AFTER
ANYONE OF THE BALES IF YOU NEED
TO.
PRESENT SO.
WE'LL START NOW WITHOUT MY FIRST
BILL.
.
OKAY SO.
MADAM VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
MOSQUITO SURVEILLANCE AND
RESEARCH PROGRAM.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN IS CAL
SERVE OPERATES AS A CENTRALIZED
DATABASE USED BY LOCAL MOSQUITO
AND VECTOR CONTROL AGENCIES.
UNIVERSITY RESEARCHERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
CAL SERVE IS CURRENTLY MANAGED
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
THOUGH CAP THROUGH CAL SERVE
THIS GROUP MAY COLLABORATE SHARE
INFORMATION TRACK MOSQUITO
POPULATIONS THAT POSE.
PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS SUCH AS ZECA
OR WEST NILE.
MISKITO SURVEILLANCE IS CRUCIAL
FOR TRACKING ELIMINATING AND
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
MOSQUITOES AND THE DISEASES THEY
CARRY.
BY ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ADMINISTER CAO
SERVE.
NOW WHY WOULDN'T YOU JUST KEEP
IT THE UNIVERSITY AND THE ANSWER
IS.
PROFESSOR HAS BEEN DOING THIS
HAS RETIRED.
AND THERE IS NO ONE AT THE
UNIVERSITY TAKEOVER THAT
PROGRAM.
THIS WAS ORIGINALLY A PROGRAM IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HOWEVER ARE WHEN THE.
I I HAVE TO BE CAREFUL EXACTLY
Y. PUT IT BUT WHEN WE HAVE ALL
THE BUDGET.
I WAS GONNA SAY SOMETHING HIT
THE FAN BUT WE HAVE ALL THE
BUDGET PROCESSES.
WHERE WE HAD NO MONEY AND WE'RE
CUTTING BILLIONS IT BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS?
THEY JUST DECIDED TO ELIMINATE
THIS PROGRAM AND THE PROBLEM IS.
IT'S IT'S IT'S A LARGE DATABASE
THAT HAS MANY YEARS IN THE
MAKING AND NEEDS TO BE
PRESERVED.
SO THERE WAS A PROFESSOR AT YOU
SEE WHO IS WILLING TO TAKE IT
OVER.
SO BY ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ADMINISTER CAL
SERVE THIS BILL LEGITIMIZES THE
EFFORTS IN RESEARCH BEING DONE
THROUGH CAL SERVE. AS A
NECESSARY PLATFORM FOR IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND RISK REDUCING MOSQUITO AND
OTHER VECTOR BORNE DISEASES.
WITH ME TODAY IS GENERAL BUCKNER
GENERAL MANAGER FOR THE PLASTER
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
DISTRICT.
AND BANESCO QUE HINA. WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF OUR
SPONSORS THE MOSQUITO AND VECTOR
CONTROL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
.
IRATE WONDERFUL THANK YOU MISTER
QUIRK ABOUT WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF ASKING HIM
I WITH KITTY PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF MOSQUITO VECTOR
CONTROL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. RIPLEY'S TO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
MOSQUITO SURVEILLANCE AND
RESEARCH PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS CAL SERVE IN STATE STATUTE.
THE BILL SIMPLY RECOGNIZES THIS
AND CODIFIES EXISTING
OPERATIONS.
CAL SERVICE A PROGRAM THAT
STRANGELY MANAGED BY UC DAVIS
AND ECAC. AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IT PROVIDES CENTRALIZED DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND STORAGE
RELATED THE PRESENCE OF
MOSQUITOES AND MISKITO BORN
DISEASES AROUND THE STATE. TOLD
SO PROVIDES LOCAL MOSQUITO
CONTROL AGENCIES WITH REAL TIME
INFORMATION ON WHERE MOSQUITOES
MIGHT EMERGE SPEAKING BEST
COMBAT THEIR SPREAD.
THE STATE HOUSE SUPPORTED
MOSQUITO RESEARCH IN THE PAST
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WE'VE BEEN WITHOUT THAT SUPPORT.
THE DIFFERENCE NOW IS THAT WE'RE
FACING NEW NON NATIVE SPECIES OF
MOSQUITOES TO TRANSMIT REALLY
BAD STUFF LIKE ZECA DENGUE
CHIKUNGUNYA AND ELLOW FEVER.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE WORK
THAT OUR MEMBERS ALREADY DO TO
COMBAT WEST NILE WHICH HAS BEEN
PRESENT IN CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS
NOW AND CONTINUES TO AFFECT
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE EVERY YEAR.
BEING ABLE TO TRACK AND MONITOR
THE PRESENCE OF DISEASE
TRANSMITTING MOSQUITOES AND
THERE EXISTS KEY COMPONENT TO
PREVENTING DISEASE OUTBREAKS AND
CONTROLLING MOSQUITO
POPULATIONS.
THE CELTS ARE PROGRAMS WHERE THE
MOST CUTTING EDGE SYSTEMS
AVAILABLE GLOBALLY TO DO THIS.
AND BASS OF MOSQUITOES HAVE BEEN
DETECTIVE IN OVER TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY CITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND TWELVE COUNTIES
INCLUDING POPULOUS URBAN AREAS
WHERE THE UP OPPORTUNITY FOR
DISEASE TRANSMISSION IS PRESENT.
TODAY I AM JOINED BY JEWEL
DETENER THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
THE PLOTS MOSQUITO AND VECTOR
CONTROL DISTRICT COOL DISCUSS
THE IMPORTANT WAYS THE CALCIUM
HELPS LOCAL MOSQUITO CONTROL
DISTRICTS ACTUALLY GET AHEAD OF
THEIR WORK.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHT NINETY TWO
SIMPLY CODIFIES CAL SERVES
CRITICAL ROLE IN PUBLIC HEALTH
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
ADVOCACY ON THIS AN OUNCE
TRIGGER A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TEXT
WITNESSES ALRIGHT THANK YOU ARE
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS JOE OPENER
I AM THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
PLASTER.
YOU DON'T VECTOR CONTROL
DISTRICT.
MY DISTRICTS BEEN USING CAL SIR
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX
AND AT WE IS IT ON A DAILY BASIS
AND NOT TO SAY IT'S A.
FANCY DATABASE MIGHT BE OUR
UNDERSTANDING SOMEWHAT.
IT'S REALLY APPOINT A
COLLABORATION FOR OVER FIFTY TWO
AND AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
MITT CURRENTLY HAS THAT AS OF
THE END OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN.
ALMOST A ONE AND A HALF MILLION
RECORDS OF.
MISKITO COLLECTIONS ABOUT THREE
AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND I HAD A
TEST FOR THE WEST NILE VIRUS OR
THE VECTOR BORNE DISEASE AND A
WHOLE SLEW OF OTHER INFORMATION.
ON YOU KIND OF THINK OF IT AS A
AYE IN ORDER TO TO INTERPRET A
WEATHER REPORT YOU NEED TO KNOW
WHERE IT'S RAINING. AND IT'S NOT
AS EASY AS JUST LOOKING OUTSIDE
WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS DATA FROM
ALL THESE DIFFERENT PLACES IN A
STANDARDIZED AN EASILY
ACCESSIBLE MANNER. AND THAT'S
WHAT COUNTS OR DOES IT GIVES US
A WAY TO PUT IT AND.
IT EXPOSES THIS DATA TO A
NUMBER OF RESEARCHERS AND OUR
FOLKS MUCH SMARTER THAN MYSELF
WHO CAN MAKE SENSE OF IT A AND
THEN REPORT BACK TO US REALLY
I'M.
SIGNIFICANT DATA THAT WE CAN
USE TO MAKE THE BEST DECISION
THE TERMS A CONTROLLER
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH ON A
DAILY BASIS.
ON THIS THIS WORKS WHETHER OR
NOT YOU'RE A LARGE DISTRICT WITH
LOTS OF RESOURCES ARE TO ME AND.
OPERATION NAM IN SOME PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA IF YOU PUT THE
MOSQUITOES AND IF YOU PUT THE
DATA AND YOU CAN GET OUT
INFORMATION.
THAT'S RELEVANT TO YOU.
MOSQUITOES DON'T TERM.
I RESPECT POLITICAL BOUNDARIES.
SO. THE CALCIUM HELPS US DEAL
AT THAT TIME I IT OPENS THE
ABILITY FOR A GROUP TO DISTRICTS
TO TAKE ON A REGIONAL APPROACH.
I MYSELF USE THAT DATA SHARING
WITH THE ABOUT SACRAMENTO COUNTY
IN SUTTER YUBA COUNTY BECAUSE
OUR MOSQUITOS MOVE AROUND ALL
THAT AREA WITHOUT THAT'S I WOULD
ONLY KNOW THAT MY DISTRICTS
COLLECTING. AND WOULD BE A
CUMBERSOME PROCESS TO GO AROUND
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON BEYOND OUR BORDERS SO
WE CAN BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
WE CAN PUT OUT LESS PESTICIDE
WHEN WE NEED IT AND WE CAN PUT
IT OUT WHEN WE DO NEED IT AND WE
CAN KEEP OUR PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
PUBLIC HEALTHY.
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS I AM I
URGE YOU TO GIVE US AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO.
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL ABOUT SAM'S ARM ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION AND URGED HER
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CLEARLY ONE REPRESENTING THE
BLOOD CENTERS ARE FAR CALIFORNIA
WHERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM OKAY ARE THERE
ANY.
MEMBERS HERE WISH COME FORWARD
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SO NOW OR FOREVER HOLD YOUR
PEACE. OKAY NO ONE AND THAT'S A
GOOD SIGN AND SO WE WILL BRING
IT UP HERE TO THE DYESS FOR ANY
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS IF THERE
ARE ANY MOVE TO PROVE.
MOTION AND A SECOND NO COMMENTS
MISTER QUIRK WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE.
NOW.
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE MADAM
CLERK WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE.
THIS IS ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY TWO QUIRK THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK.
I QUIRK I.
MELENDEZ AYE MELINDA'S AYE.
ARAMBULA.
BROKE.
BRO I.
FRIEDMAN I
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
BUT IT'S A JEEP AYE ROOTS WHICH.
SIX.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU NOW LIVE
GOODNESS SINCE THEN GRADUATION
VOTING ON TO THE NEXT ONE YOU
HAVE ITEM FIFTEEN AB THREE ZERO
ZERO NINE.
YES.
WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN'T MAKE THIS
ONE COME BY A TWO.
OKAY.
BOB.
JOE NOW MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THREE ZERO ZERO NINE
WOULD ENACTED DOLLAR PER GALLON
FEE ON PAINT MANUFACTURERS FOR
ALL PAINT SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MONEY FROM THIS FEE WOULD GO
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
WOULD THEN PROVIDED TO RESIDENTS
OF SINGLE FAMILY AND OR MULTI
FAMILY HOMES. FOR THE PURPOSES
OF CLEANING UP LEAD PAINT THAT
HAS CONTAMINATED OR HOW.
THE BET BILL STATES THE FEE WILL
ONLY BE IMPOSED IF INITIATIVE
PASSES THE STATE. THAT LEAD
PAINT IS NOT A PUBLIC NUISANCE
AND THAT DOES THE ACTION OF THE
COURTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE FEE WOULD BE
USED TO PAY FOR THE BOND INSTEAD
OF USING GENERAL TAXPAYER MONEY.
THAT WOULD ALSO THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE GO TO FUNDING
EDUCATION HEALTHCARE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY.
LET HAS BEEN LISTED UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S PROP SIXTY FIVE
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS A
SUBSTANCE.
THAT CAN CAUSE REPRODUCTIVE
DAMAGING BIRTH WELL YOU'VE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT LAND.
WE CAN GO TO THE NEXT PARAGRAPH
HALF.
HOUSE SOLD PAINT THAT CONTAIN
LEAD WAS SOLD IN YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES LEAD
PAINT.
LEAD BASED PAINT REMOVAL COSTS
ARE ESTIMATED EIGHT TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS A SQUARE FOOT.
REMOVING ALL LEAD PAINT FROM A
HOUSE OF TWELVE HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET WAS RUN AS
MUCH AS TEN TO THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THE AVERAGE REMOVAL PROJECT.
WOULD BROWN WITH OF SMALLER
HOUSES THAT ARE PRE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT'S WHEN THE.
.
REGULATIONS WERE PUT OUT TO FOR
DEAD LET DEATH PAIN HOMES. THE
STATE THAT DOES NOT HAVE A
DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE TO
PROGRAM THE SUFFICIENTLY
EQUIPPED TO REMEDIATE THEIR
ABATE THE LEAD PAINT AND HAMS.
STATEWIDE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AFTER THIRTEEN YEARS OF
LITIGATION.
SANTA CLARA SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
JAMES.
OUR KLEINBERG FOUND THAT PAINT
MANUFACTURE SOLD LEAD
CONTAMINATED PAINT. KNOWING THAT
OPPOSED TO SERIOUS HEALTH RISK
TO RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT PAINT MANUFACTURERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAINS REMOVER
ABATE THE LAD.
IT OBVIOUSLY IT'S
REMOVAL IS NOT THE ONLY SOLUTION
OF SAILING THE PAIN AS WELL AS A
SOLUTION. AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
CHEAPER THAN.
.
THEN REMOVING IT.
AND SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
CO WAIT I'VE GOT MORE.
CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
ISSUED DECLINED TO HEAR THE
APPEAL OF SOLIDIFYING THE TRIAL
COURT'S JUDGMENT AND CONTINUING
TO HOLD PAINT MANUFACTURERS
RESPONSIBLE.
IN SPITE OF THE COURT'S FINDING
LEAD PAINT MANUFACTURERS ARE
PROPOSING INITIATIVE IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATEWIDE BALLOT
THAT WERE REVERSED THE COURT'S
RULING.
PACIFIC LEE THE INITIATIVE WOULD
REALLY PAINT MANUFACTURERS OF
LIABILITY.
I AND UNDER THE ACTION BY
MULTIPLE COURTS AND PUT THE SOLE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY ON
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS IN THE
STATE.
GENERAL FUND FOR CLEANING UP
LEAD CONTAMINATED PAINT AB THREE
ZERO ZERO NINE. CONTINUES TO
HOLD THE LEAD PAINT MANUFACTURER
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONTAMINATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE ARRIVAL OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
YOU HAVE A WITNESS HERE TO TEST
OR YES FORRESTER BELARUS ARE
ALEJO I ALLOW IT WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
THERE ARE ELEVEN LED RELATED
BILLS IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR SIX.
NINE IN THIS HOUSE AND TWO IN
THE SENATE'S YOU'RE HEARING A
LOT ABOUT LEAD. WELL JUST
BRIEFLY SAY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ADJECTIVE TO USE ABOUT THIS BILL
IT'S A CLEVER OR IT'S
APPROPRIATE BUT IT'S JUST THE
RIGHT RESPONSE IN THIS CASE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT OF THE LEAD PAINT
COMPANIES PAY FOR ANY
REMEDIATION NOT CONSUMERS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WISHING TO COME FOR IN
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. PLEASE
COME FOR EATING MC THE TABLE
HERE.
A GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M LAURIN DE
VALENCIA HERE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN CUTTING ASSOCIATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA UP PAINT COUNCIL.
I RESPECTFULLY HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE THOUSAND
AND NINE. AND.
A CA IS A VOLUNTARY NONPROFIT
TRADE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS OVER NINETY PERCENT
OF THE TOTAL DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
OF PAINTS AND COATINGS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN PERCENT
OF A SERIOUS DOMESTIC CUTTINGS
MARKET AND THAT INCLUDES I'M
FIFTEEN.
COATINGS MANUFACTURES WITH
FACILITIES CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA PINK COUNCIL IS
THAT AN ADVOCACY NETWORK OF EASY
REPRESENTING. BOTH BIG AND SMALL
MANUFACTURERS.
I'M SO.
AC NCPC HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY
OF SPONSORING AWARENESS EFFORTS
IN EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THE SAFE AND PROPER ACTION
RELATED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURES. ARISING FROM OLD
DETERIORATED PAINS I EASIER HAS
ACTIVELY FOLLOWED AND ADVISE THE
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
PROCESS ON THESE ISSUES AND
SUPPORTS INDUSTRY COMPLIANCE ON
LEAD BASED PAINT.
AND WE DO THIS THROUGH REQUIRE
TESTING PRODUCT LABELING AND
OTHER CONSUMER SUPPORT EFFORTS.
IN ADDITION OVER THE LAST HALF
CENTURYTHE PAINT INDUSTRY HAS
WORKED WITH MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
ON THE DANGERS OF CHILDHOOD LEAD
POISONING. AND THE CITY FOR
REMOVAL OF THE LEAD BASED PAINT
FOR RESIDENTIAL HOMES.
SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT AB THREE
THOUSAND NINE ONLY GOES INTO
EFFECT IF THE INITIATIVE PASSES.
HOWEVER ECA NCPC DO NOT SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THAT IS CRAFTED TO
FOCUS SOLELY ON A SINGLE
IDENTIFIED PATHWAY OF LEAD
POISONING BY IGNORING THE
MULTIPLE SOURCES OF LEAD
EXPOSURE. AND THAT OF THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO IDENTIFIED HEALTH
RISKS
ANY REMEDY AND THE REQUIRED
FUNDING MUST BE BASED ON ACTUAL
UNDERLYING PUBLIC HEALTH DATA.
AND ANY APPROACHES THAT FOCUS
SOLELY ON LEAD BASED PAINT OR
CONCERNING.
EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
HAVE BOTH DEFINE THE PROBLEM AND
ACTIONABLE REMEDIES FOR
ADDRESSING LEAD BASED PAINT
HATTER HAZARDS INCLUDING. THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDHOOD LEAD
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
USE OF THESE REMEDIES AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES HAVE PRODUCED
MEANINGFUL REDUCTIONS IN LEAD
EXPOSURE ARISING FROM PAIN
SOURCES.
HOWEVER IN MANY CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY LED SORT LED FROM
OTHER SOURCES I AM SUCH AS THOSE
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED EARLIER
TODAY LIKE I'M DRINK WHAT
DRINKING WATER DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS. HAVE BEEN A MORE RECENT
CONTRIBUTOR TO LEAD EXPOSURE.
AND SO AB THREE THOUSAND NINE
APPLIES ENTIRELY TO ONE INDUSTRY
FURTHER THE BILL NEGLECT TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE NATURE THAT THE
PAIN OF THE PAINT INDUSTRY OR
THE FACT THAT MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES. ON MAY NOT HAVE
ACTUALLY MANUFACTURE LEAD PAINT
OR EVEN BEEN IN EXISTENCE PRIOR
TO THE BAND USE AND SALE OF
CONSUMER LEAD BASED PAINT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WISHING INCOME FOR AND TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
NOPE A CASE WILL BRING IN
APPEARED TO THE DIET IS FOR
DISCUSSION ANYONE.
ANYONE KNOW.
OKAY QUESTION.
MR. SO UP AND MISTER CHAIR I
IDEA.
NOT SURE IF I MISS THIS BUT.
I KNOW THAT I A COMMON ARGUMENT
OF A. OF THE INDUSTRY IS IS IS
THAT.
.
AND THE.
A.
HE IS GOING TO BE JUST PASSED ON
TO THE CONSUMER. HERE YOUR
RESPONSE THE WELL THAT'S UP TO
THE PAINT COMPANIES AND THAT'S
NOTHING HERE RAISES THE PRICE.
BOB.
SO. THAT'S MY ANSWER.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SIR.
MAKING THE POINT ABOUT AB THREE
THOUSAND NINE WOULD APPLY TO THE
POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLE THAT.
SEEMS LIKE THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
THE BEST THING TO DO.
IS.
UP FIRST WHILE MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT THE OPPOSITION SAID
ARE TRUE THERE MANY SOURCES OF
LEAD.
OUR BUT WHAT WE HAVE OUR THREE
PAINT COMPANY.
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO PASS THIS
ON.
TO THE TAXPAYERS NO I UNDERSTAND
AND ALL THEY HAVE THEIR DO.
I TAKE CARE OF THEIR CONCERNS IS
JUST
ALL DROPPED THIS BILL.
IF THEY DROP INITIATIVE.
AND IT IS THOSE THREE PAINT
COMPANIES THAT ARE CAUSING
COMPANIES THAT PERHAPS DID NOT.
OF YOU ARE DISTRIBUTING A LEAD
PAINT. TO HAVE TO PUT A FEE ON
THERE BUT.
TO HAVE THESE COMPANIES.
TRANSFER THEIR LIABILITY TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS SOMETHING
I WILL NOT TOLERATE.
AND NEITHER WOULD I THINK ABOUT
YOU BUT I'M ASKING CALL HIM
WHETHER THIS BILL.
NIGHT.
YEAH I THAT'S UP TO THEM.
OUR THINKING.
ANYTHING FURTHER RISK MURATSUCHI
NOW NOW OKAY ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY EX
WITHOUT.
RIGHT I HAD SOME COMMENTS FIRST
BEFORE WE GET TO WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEONE WANTS TO MAKE A MOTION.
I.
I HAD TO BE HONEST WITH YOU IP
SO I'M WITH YOU ON THE FACT THAT
IT'S REPREHENSIBLE THAT. I'M
SOME OF THESE THE THREE PAINT
COME IN COMPANIES DID WHAT THEY
DID.
AND THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO PUSH
THAT RESPONSIBILITY OFF ON
SOMEONE ELSE.
BUT I AGREE WITH OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBER THAT THAT BURDEN SHOULD
NOT THEN BE FURTHER PLACED ON
THE CUSTOMER WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT THAT PAIN COMPANIES THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO ABSORB THAT COST IS
GOING TO BE PASSED ON TO YOU AND
ME AND ANYONE ELSE WHO BUYS
PAINT.  BY THE WAY I'M NOT
THE ONE TO PUT THE LEAD IN THE
PAINT SO I DON'T SEE WHY I STEP
TO PAY FOR IT. AS WELL AS ANYONE
ELSE WHO'S PURCHASING PAINT OUT
THERE PROBABLY FEELS THE SAME
WAY SO I'M WITH YOU THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE ALIVE I GET WHY
YOU'RE DOING IT.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THE WAY THE
WAY THE BILL IS STRUCTURED THE
PEOPLE END UP PAYING ARE. THE
PEOPLE HER WALKING INTO YOU KNOW
HOMEDEPOT OR LOWES OR WHEREVER
IT AND PURCHASING PAINT SO. I'M
FOR THERE'S REASONS
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE DAY.
PARTNER SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
KNOWING.
SO WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND
IF THIS BILL IS TO MOVE FORWARD.
SECOND WAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TEHAMA MADAM CLERK WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WAIT I
DIDN'T BEHIND IT ARE YOU WANTING
LOS SURE ESR WANNA CLEAN USUALLY
YEAR SO BRIEF IN YOUR PRESENCE.
YOUR BILL YEAH I I JUST WANNA
PUT FORWARD SHOW YOU SAY THAT IT
WILL BE CONSUMERS THAT PAY FOR.
THE PROBLEM IS IF WE DON'T HAVE
THIS FEE.
IT'LL STILL BE THE TAXPAYERS OF
THE STATE. AND THAT MEANS LESS
MONEY FOR HEALTH AND WELFARE
PROGRAMS AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO PREVENT HERE. AND
AGAIN I WOULD VERY MUCH* THE
OTHER PAINT COMPANIES TO OPPOSE.
THIS INITIATIVE BY THE THREE
PAINT COMPANIES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY HIGH MADAM CITY MADAM
CLERK.
IT'S IS ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
THREE ZERO ZERO NINE QUIRK THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELINDA'S NO
MELINDA'S NO. ARAMBULA.
BROKE.
BRUNO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MAURIZIO CHEAP HIGH.
MURATSUCHI I.
FOR TWO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
.
ALRIGHT NOT LEAST ITEM SIXTEEN
A. B. THIRTY FOURTEEN.
ALRIGHT CHAU.
MADAM VICE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY FOURTEEN PROVIDES A
NARROW EXCEPT
DECEPTION.
REGARDING COPPER AMOUNTS IN
BRAKE PADS FOR HIGH PERFORMANCE
AND TRACK CAPABLE VEHICLES.
IN TWENTY TEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED S. B. THREE FOUR SIX KEY
HOW. THAT BEGAN TO RESTRICT THE
AMOUNT OF COPPER USED IN MOTOR
VEHICLE BRAKE PADS.
VEHICLES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
CANNOT CONTAIN MORE THAN FIVE
PERCENT COPPER IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE.
AND NO MORE THAN POINT FIVE
PERCENT IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH EXCESS
AMOUNTS OF COPPER FROM AUTO
BRAKE PADS WERE AFFECTING FISH
AND OTHER ORGANISMS SPECIFICALLY
AND URBAN WATERSHEDS.
WHILE THE AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY IS
WORKING TO ACHIEVE THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GOAL.
IT HAS BECOME CLEAR THAT SUCH AN
EXEMPTION MUST BE MADE.
ONLY
FOR HIGH PERFORMANCE AND TRACK
CAPABLE VEHICLES.
THESE VEHICLES WHICH CAN MEET
THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOALS BUT
ARE NOT ABLE TO MEET THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE GOALS.
THESE VEHICLES WHICH ARE
TYPICALLY VEHICLES THE CAN BE
DRIVEN ON BOTH THE ROAD IN A
RACE TRACK.
SPECIALIZED PARTS THAT MAKE THEM
CAPABLE OF BEING DRIVEN AT HIGH
SPEEDS ON A TRACK.
ALEC.
THANK YOU.
I ADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT
BEEN DEVELOPED TO PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO COPPER BASED
BRAKE PADS.
THAT WILL BE COMPLIANT WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND I DEADLINE
A FIVE PERCENT OR LESS.
THERE FOR A BE THIRTY FOURTEEN
PROVIDES THESE TRACK CAPABLE
VEHICLES.
WITH A NARROW EXCEPT
EXEMPTION FROM THAT DEADLINE
BUT CONTINUES TO HOLD THESE
VEHICLES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. DEADLINE.
THESE MANUFACTURERS ARE.
BEING.
I THINK VERY RESPONSIBLE
TELLING US AHEAD OF TIME WHAT
THEY CAN AND CAN'T DO AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE.
P. AYE TOUGHER STANDARD THEY
WILL MEET IN TIME.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
EXEMPTION AGAIN WOULD ONLY APPLY
THE HIGH PERFORMANCE IN TRACK
CAPABLE VEHICLES.
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
FORM.
A PROPER DEFINITION FOR SUCH
VEHICLES TO ENSURE THE EXEMPTION
DOES NOT APPLY TO A BROADER
RANGE OF AUTOMOBILES.
AND WITH ME TODAY AND
TESTIFYING SUPPORT IS A BEEF
AVE B. THIRTY FOURTEEN. IS
MICHELLE.
RUPERT COLVILLE.
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MUCH SUBTLER GOV ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTO ALLIANCE THE
ALLIANCE IS A TRADE ASSOCIATION
OF TWELVE ON MANUFACTURERS AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY
FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTY FOURTEEN
PROVIDES AN ARAB EXEMPTION FOR
HIGH PERFORMANCE TRACK CAPABLE
VEHICLES AND THE BREAK FRICTION
MATERIALS USED ON THESE
VEHICLES.
FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INTERMEDIATE DEADLINE.
THE ALLIANCE WAS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF WORKING WITH LOCAL WATER
DISTRICTS AND OTHERS TO PUT THE
CURRENT PROVISIONS OF LAW AND
PLACE BACK IN TWENTY TEN.
SINCE THAT TIME OUR MEMBERS HAVE
WORK TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF
LAW AND HAVE SUCCESSFULLY DONE
SO IN ALMOST EVERY INSTANCE.
HOWEVER AS THE ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS BIRTH REGARDS TO
HIGH PERFORMANCE TRACK READY
VEHICLES HAS BEEN CHALLENGING.
AYE ONE HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THE ALLIANCE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS AND IN
SOME CASES BE AHEAD OF THE FINAL
DEADLINE SET FOR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. HOWEVER FOR THIS SMALL
SUBSET OF CARS WE WOULD SUPPORT
THE EXEMPTION GRANTED IN AB
THIRTY FOURTEEN AND ASK FOR YOUR
IBOOK.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NOW IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO STE TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL TWEENER HERE TWEENER
OKAY TWEENER SPURS.
YOU'RE TOO WIENER.
OKAY TWEENER IS GOING UP THE
COMMITTEES AND A LOT OF TIME BUT
IF WE'RE GONNA DO TWEENER IS
WHICH ORDINARILY WE DON'T AFFORD
THE TWO MINUTE TIMEFRAME TO IF
YOU COULD KEEP IT A VERY BRIEF
WE'D APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT MORE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE. CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WE WERE A CO SPONSORS OF THAT
MEASURE.
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
AND.
PART OF THE EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT TOOK PLACE ON
THAT BILL TO FIND THAT DELICATE
BALANCE.
AND.
BECAUSE OF COURSE IT'S THE CITY
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF.
OF.
COSTS FOR OUR TMDL THAT WE'RE
FACING.
I'M BUT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS CAME TO US EARLY. ON TO
TRY AND TALK ABOUT THIS
EXEMPTION.
AND.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE THINK THAT WE CAN.
WHAT WE HAVE OUR DUE DILIGENCE
THAT WE NEED TO TO WORK THROUGH
TO SEE HOW MUCH WIGGLE ROOM WE
HAVE WITHIN OUR TMDL? AT THIS
POINT.
BUT WE.
WE THINK THAT WE CAN NOT FIND
THAT SWEET SPOT SIR.
TO NARROW THE DEFINITION EVEN
FURTHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER EXEMPTION IS PROVIDED
ULTIMATELY THAT IT'S AS NARROWLY
DRAWN AS POSSIBLE SET UP YOU WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ISSUE THAT IS THERE
SOMEONE ELSE HE WANTS TO TESTIFY
IS BETWEEN US OUR STATE EVOLVING
FROM SUSTAINABLE. CONSERVATION
THE OTHER CO SPONSOR OF S. B.
THREE FORTY SIX I WOULD ECHO
WHAT MS TOP SAID. PAPA ARE
CONCERNED IS ONCE AGAIN THAT THE
THIS THIS EXEMPTION BE AS NARROW
IT NARROWLY TAILORED AS
POSSIBLE.
AS ALL OF THE INFORMATION S. B.
THREE FORTY SIX WAS THE RESULT
OF A PROCESS THAT TOOK OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS. TO DETERMINE THE
PROPER SCIENTIFIC AND AND.
POLICY ARE LEVELS OF THINGS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS EXEMPTION AS WAS THE CASE
WITH THE OTHER EXEMPTIONS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN THE BILL IS BASED
ON THE ACTUAL. AMOUNT OF COPPER
THAT THESE CARS GENERATE SO IT'S
BOTH THE IT'S SO THAT WE HAVE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION ON BOTH
THE THE PERCENTAGE OF COPPER IN
THE BRAKE PADS IN THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES THAT ARE AVAILABLE SO.
SO THAT WE GET A PROPER
ASSESSMENT ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT
OF THIS MIGHT BE BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD VERY MUCH TO WORKING
WITH WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS OF WE WE WORK WITH A
M..
WHAT GETTING THE BILL PASSED AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO IT AGAIN?
AREN'T WE HOPE WON'T TAKE
FIFTEEN YOUR SYSTEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS.
FOR THE LAST TWO CAN OF MIND
BILL ALLEY ENVIRONMENT WORKING
GROUP ARE CATCHING UP TO THIS
BILL WE HAVE CONCERNS.
BY A NUMBER QUICK CRUNCH FOR US
JUST RECENTLY WAS THIS COULD BE
ABOUT SIX PERCENT OF
AUTOMOBILES.
OUT THERE SO IT MAY NOT BE SUPER
NARROW AND LASTLY A WASHINGTON
STATE US INFORMATION ABOUT
COOPER FREE BAKED BRAKE PADS ARE
WORKING WELL NOW SILVER DISCS
ARE ABOUT. OPENING UP THE
EXEMPTION. WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
AND I'LL JUST REITERATE THE I
MAN THREE OF ENTER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION I'M ALSO CATCHING
UP ON THE BILL SO OPEN TO UP TO
LEARNING MORE BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS I HAVE EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON TEAM DEALS
PARTICULAR ON SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
AND AFTER A LENGTHY OVER A
DECADE PROCESS TO TRY TO NEVER
THE STAND WHERE A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT. THE EXPENSE AND
THE.
.
THE THE TIME AND RESOURCES IT
TOOK TO COME UP WITH THE TEAM D.
L. TO PROTECT FISH IN THE BAY
THAT IS REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW.
THAT WE MAY BE GETTING IN THE
WAY OF THAT AND WE'RE NOT CLEAR
YET WE'RE NOT THERE YET AS TO
WHY. WE COULD ACCEPT AN
EXCEPTION EXEMPTION BUT OPEN TO
TALKING TO YOU FURTHER ABOUT IT.
I THINK IT'S GOOD IF UP TMDL WAS
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES HERE ARE
WHICH I WOULDN'T BE WILLING TO
GIVE A DEFINITION.
SURE HER FEATURE A TEAM DE OUR
TOTAL MAXIMUM DAILY LOAD IS.
UNDER THE CLEAN WATER ACT IF IT
WILL PUT AWAY IS IMPAIRED BY A
CONTAMINANT IN THIS CASE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COPPER BUT IT
COULD BE ANYTHING ELSE. UP WHAT
IS THE LEVEL OF THAT THAT WATER
BODY COULD MAINTAIN AND STILL.
.
HONOR AND AND.
AND STUFF I FELL IT'S
BENEFICIAL USES IN THIS CASE IT
WOULD INCLUDE FISH AND FISHING.
AND SO.
UNDER THAT THE STATE IS
REQUIRED TO COME UP WITH A PLAN
THAT. WOULD BRING THAT WATER
BACK INTO COMPLIANCE WITH WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS UNDER THE
CLEAN WATER ACT.
AND REPORT A CLUMP THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
SEE WE HAVE ONE MORE PERSON HE
WANTS TO ADD HIS NAME AND ANY
MARIN ON THE OFFICE HERE
CALIFORNIA.
WE DON'T HAVE VISION YET BUT
THE SPEAKERS NICELY CAPTURED OUR
CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE GREAT
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE CAN BRING IT BACK UP
HERE TO THE DIET IS FOR ANY
DISCUSSION FOR MEMBERS
MISTREATMENT.
I HAVE A QUESTION MAYBE FOR THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE AUTO
INDUSTRY.
I TRACK CAPABLE WHEN I HEAR
TRACK CAPABLE. I THINK OF RACE
CARS BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
HI IN BMWS AND LEXUS'S THAT KIND
OF VEHICLE CRACKED SO THEY'RE
AUTOMOBILES THAT MAY LOOK LIKE A
REGULAR ON A BILL BUT THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT PARTS AND EQUIPMENT
THAT DO ALLOW THEM TO BE. RACE
TYPE CARS THAT ARE ABLE TO RUN
ON A TRACK AND GO UP TO THOSE
SPEEDS THAT. YOU WOULD THINK OF
AS A RACE CAR WITH THAT THESE
CARS ARE SOLD THOUGH AS PEOPLE'S
PRIMARY MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
AROUND TOWN. THEY'RE BOTH ROAD
READY IN TRACK READY SO YOU
COULD DRIVE THEM ON THE FREEWAY
YES.
BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND WITH THESE VEHICLES
ARE HOW MANY OF THE OF THE SIX
PERCENT OF THE CARS ON THE ROAD.
I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER I
CAN GET IT TO YOU BUT IT'S.
.
IT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF A
VERY SMALL SAID MANUFACTURERS
NOT ALL THE MANUFACTURERS DO
THEM THE ONES THAT DO IT'S A
VERY SMALL IT'S IT WOULD BE LIKE
YOUR FERRARIS. THOSE TYPE OF
VERY HIGH PERFORMANCE. ARE YOU
SURE BECAUSE MY FRIEND BOUGHT
WE'LL GET YOU KNOW I'M W. THAT
S. U. V.. THAT HAS A POWER MODE
THAT MIGHT THAT THAT I THINK
MIGHT UNDER YOUR DEFINITION
QUALIFY AND I THINK THAT'S KIND
OF GOES TO WHAT I THINK SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ARE AT LEAST FOR ME
AND I THINK TO THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENT WE ARE GOING TO. DEFINE
A LOAN OR LOOK INTO DEFINING
WHAT IS ATTRACT READY YOUR TRACK
CAPABLE VIA YEAH IT'S TO MAKE IT
AS NARROW AS POSSIBLE.
RIGHT AND AND CLEARLY WE'VE GOT
TO GET THAT NUMBER DOWN.
YOU CAN.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE FROM THE
COMMITTEE HAVE A COMMENT NOW
OKAY SO THEN WILL NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WE DO HAVE IT. ABROAD DID I
DIDN'T HEAR YOU STINK IN THERE
OKAY. OKAY SO THEN.
WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A.
B. THREE ZERO ONE FOUR QUIRK.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK HIGH.
QUIRK AYE MELINDA'S AYE.
MELINDA'S AYE. ARAMBULA.
BROKE.
BRO I.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
WELL THAT'S WHAT SHE AYE.
MOVEMENT.
FAIR FIVE
ZERO.
THAT'S OUT ALRIGHT BANG TO SHOOT
THAT WITHOUT ALL RIGHT AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM MISTER
MURATSUCHI IN THE MEANTIME. IF
THE SERGEANTS COULD GET MISTER
ARAMBULA HERE. OF WILL NEED HIM
TO LIVE ADD TO THE ROLE.
A FEW MINUTES.
YEAH BEST A LOT ANYHOW YEAH.
POP DOT PATTERNS AND I LOOK LIKE
A
MY MY WINDOW THAT.
SO WAS JUST A LITTLE LESS TO
MAKE IT CLEAR.
THIS COULD.
THE
.
BOTH.
AFTER.
WE.
OKAY SERVICES FOR ALL OTHER.
I. MEAN.
THE COMPUTER.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
IS HERE IN AND A NUMBER OF YEARS
OF PAIN HERE.
VIRTUALL THE WHOLE TIME SHALL.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
.
ALRIGHT. OUR LAST BILL DEATH
MR MARIS YUCHI BACK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
HERE TO.
AND IT A PRESENTER AB. THIRTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
.
WHICH BASICALLY SEEKS TO MAKE
THE MAC INCREASE THE MAX MONTHS.
ADMINISTRATIVE A PENALTY YOU.
FROM TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER.
PER DAY FOR ANY CALIFORNIA
ACCIDENTAL RELEASE PREVENTION
PROGRAM VIOLATION.
WELL AS MANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KNOW.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME
A PARTICULARLY IN MY DISTRICT
THAT TORRANCE REFINERY AYE
HANDLES.
ONE OF THESE HIGHLY TOXIC
CHEMICALS THAT THE.
CAL A. R. P. OR CAL ARE. A
PROGRAM ADDRESSES THE THE HIGHLY
TOXIC CHEMICAL OF HYDROCHLORIC
ACID. THAT IF A RELEASED A COULD
POTENTIALLY THREATEN THE LIVES
OF HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE LIVING WITHIN THE
VICINITY OF THE REFINERY. AND SO
IT IS PRECISELY FOR THIS KIND
OF.
A HIGHLY TOXIC CHEMICAL THAT THE
CAL A. R. P. IS DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS TO TO ENSURE THAT THAT
WE CAN.
PROVIDED THE.
SIGNIFICANT DETERRENCE
TO.
ACCIDENTAL RELEASES OF THESE
TYPE OF.
TOXIC OR FLAMMABLE CHEMICALS.
RIGHT NOW THE TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS A. AND SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN THE BUCKET.
FOR FOR MANY OF THE TARGETS OF
THESE.
CAL A. R. P..
VIOLATIONS THAT THE COOPERS OR
THE CERTIFY UNIFY PROGRAM
AGENCIES GO AFTER.
WE NEED TO. INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE THAT DETERRENT EFFECT
I'M HERE.
WITH THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE COOPER HAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MULLIN
FOR THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTIVES THAT WE REPRESENT THE
COOPERS AND VERY VERY QUICKLY WE
JUST WANNA SAY WE TRY TO BRING.
SOME OF THESE FINES AND
PENALTIES UP TO A MORE
REASONABLE LEVEL.
YOU MAY RECALL THIS COMMITTEE
VOTED ACT AND YOU CARRIED THE
BILL THAT INCREASE THE FINES AND
PENALTIES TO SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO THIS IS A LOT LESS
THAN THE HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND
WE DEALING WITH SOME OF THE
VERY.
VERY S. SIGNIFICANT CHEMICALS
HERE I THINK YOU ANALYSIS WAS
EXCELLENT AT REALLY LAID IT OUT
AND WE DO HAVE SOME SMALL
AMENDMENTS THAT. A THE
OPPOSITION WANTED US TO TAKE
RANDY WILL EXPLAIN THOSE
AMENDMENTS HERE BUT WITH THAT.
WE HAPPY AND WE HOPE THAT YOU
YOU'LL SUPPORT BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN QUIRK IN
THEM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
BASICALLY AND MY NAME IS RANDY
SAWYER I'M I'M THE CHIEF
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH AND HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS OFFICER IN CONTRA
COSTA CANYON.
I I'M REPRESENTING THE IN
CALIFORNIA IF I PROGRAM AGENCY
FORMER COOPER FORUM.
I WHICH SAYS THAT WOULDN'T
STATED WITH A REPRESENTS EVERY
LOCAL HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AGENCY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO BASICALLY THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE PROPOSED THEIR PROPOSED
ARE.
BASED ON WHAT NOW WE HAVE IT UP
TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY IS
THE MINIMUM. THAT WOULD INCREASE
THAT TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY THERE WOULD BE INCREASED TO
FIVE THOUSAND A. AND THE SECOND
SECTION WHERE IT NOW SAYS NO
ONLY AFTER REASON ONE NOTICED.
IT COULD BE GO UP TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE MINUTE WHICH TRACK AT STRIKE
OUT THE AFTER RECENTLY NOTICED
ANDTHAT WOULD BASICALLY MEAN IF
THEY KNOWINGLY MAKE IT HAVE A
VIOLATION WHICH THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO KNOW.
IT WOULD INCREASE UP TO TWENTY
IT COULD INCREASE UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THERE'S OTHER OTHER TO ONE
OTHER. PIECE IT'S AMENDED IT
WILL ALSO EXEMPT TO PIECES OF A
TWO SECTIONS OF THE.
THIS ARTICLE DATA COVERS A
CALIFORNIA EXTENDS PREVENTION
PROGRAM.
PUT EM BASED GOOD POINT SECTION
TWENTY FIVE FIVE THREE SIX POINT
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE BY THREE SIX
POINT SIX.
THIRTY SIX POINT SEVEN BASICALLY
WAS IHAD TO DO WITH CONTRACTORS
SAFETY. WHICH IS KIND OF MIXED
WITH THAT CALLOSUM. AND THE
LOCAL COOPER IS AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR SOMETIMES WHO MIGHT HAVE
JURISDICTION. AND AND THIS WOULD
THIS WOULD TAKE THAT PIECE OUT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR FOR THE REST OF
THE ARTICLE.
AND IN TWENTY FIVE.
TWENTY FIVE BY THIRTY SIX POINT
SIX HAS TO DO WITH. A BILL THAT
WAS PASSED LAST YEAR.
I MET MISTER MISTER YOUR MARRIED
SHE WAS A THE ART THERE FOR WITH
HAVING TO DO WITH COMMUNITY
WARNING SYSTEMS. AND IT
BASICALLY WOULD.
THIS WOULD EXEMPT.
LOCAL AGENCY WHO WERE AMPLE WHAT
COLOR EMPLOYMENT AGENCIES FROM
THESE PENALTIES AND FINES AT TO
IMPLEMENT THAT THAT SECTION OF
IT.
I WE'RE OAK AND INTO COOPER FORM
BOARD IS OKAY WITHIN MINUTES IF
THE AUTHORS OKAY WITH AMOUNTS OF
MIA.
SO THOSE ARE ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH THE WITH
RESPECT TO ASK FOR. THAT IS
CORRECT.
YEAH I KNOW BUT TWO OF THEM
ACTUALLY HELP YOU OUT SO.
ARE THEY WERE VERY GENEROUS.
RIGHT.
.
OTHERS ARE IN SUPPORT.
AND NO ONE ELSE ALRIGHT ANYONE
AND NOW I'M HOPING OPPOSITION
THAT WAS REMOVED.
OUR BY WHISPER WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS DOES ANYONE ELSE HAVE
A CONCERN MISTER CHAIR I I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY SHARED I I DID
HAVE A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH THE.
OF REPRESENTATIVES OF OF THE
OPPOSITION AND.
WHILE WE HAVE NOT ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENT SALAS POINTS.
WE.
HAVE COMMITTED TO. THAT MADE A
GOOD FAITH COMMITMENT TO THE
OPPOSITION AND AND TO TAKE UP
THE AMENDMENTS.
.
BUT SHOULD THIS BILL MOVED TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SO WE ARE HIGH I DON'T IT QUITE
UNDERSTAND.
YOU WILL TAKE THE AMENDMENTS IN
JUDICIARY OR YOU KNOW ARE
CONSIDER TAKING THEM WE WILL I
WILL CONSIDER TAKING THEM OKAY
THAT'S FINE. THANK YOU.
THEN WE STILL HAVE OPPOSITION
AB OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
AT EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WE
APPRECIATE THAT CONVERSATION
WE'VE HAD APPEAR.
.
WE WOULD SAY WE OBVIOUSLY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A COMMITMENT TO HAVE
THESE.
AMENDMENTS TAKING COMMITTEE OUT
IF THE SPONSORS OF THE BELL.
DON'T FIND A PROBLEM WITH THAT
WE WOULD CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE
THOSE I'M TO BE COMMITTED TO
TODAY. I'M SHORT OF TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS WE DO HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE BELL.
ODD THE WAY THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
AS
HAS BEEN EXPLAINED INCREASES THE
MAXIMUM PENALTY TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OP PER DAY.
THE FOR THE VIOLATION.
.
WE WOULD ALLOW WE'VE BELIEVE
THAT THE WAY THAT THIS.
IS RIGHT AND THE PROPOSED
CHANGES.
REALLY DO.
EQUATE THEY THEY ELIMINATE ANY
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES AND A
CRIMINAL PENALTY I'M WE. IN GOOD
FAITH HAVE SAID IF THE CUBANS
FEEL LIKE THEY NEED TO HAVE THE
NOTICE PROVISION REMOVED WHERE
MORE THAN COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT RETAINING
THE KNOWING PROVISION IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. I'M
STRIKING BOTH OF THOSE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED UNDER THE
BELL.
DOES BECAUSE THIS SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS SO IT WE HOPE THOSE CAN
BE ADDRESSED IN THE WE CAN GET A
COMMITMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND FROM THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO
TAKE THOSE IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE.
JEAN URBAN ON BEHALF OF ENDEAVOR
I'M.
YES WE OFFERED AMENDMENTS THEY
WORK ACT CORRECTLY DESCRIBED
THEY WOULD REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE TO OPPOSE A
BILL THAT ARE RACES. THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN MINOR
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS AND KNOWING
BY.
FOR WHICH WE RECEIVED NOTICE I
MEAN WE CAN'T AT IT I JUST DON'T
THINK IS APPROPRIATE POLICY. TO
IT AT EQUATE ALL VIOLATIONS WITH
THE SAME PENALTY THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE ASKED THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER PRESERVATION OF THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
PENALTIES AND KNOWING VIOLATIONS
WE'VE AGREED TO RAISE THE AMOUNT
AND THEN WE'VE AGREED I THINK
THIS FOR SOME SURGICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR ABOUT FOR.
FOR PROVISIONS TO WHICH THESE
PENALTIES WERE NEVER INTENDED TO
APPLY.
SO I WOULD URGE THE AUTHOR TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS SOONER OR
LATER I'M BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF
THAT WE HAVE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
AS WRITTEN.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
ON KHAKI MCCUE CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE EVEN. AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I WOULD
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS I WITH THE
PRIOR SPEAKERS A LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS HOPEFULLY TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR TOM JACOB ON
BEHALF OF THE CHEMICAL INDUSTRY
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE NOT SIGNATORIES TO THE
LETTER THAT REACHED YOU AND I
BECAUSE WE ARE ABOUT A HALF HOUR
LATE PHONING IN.
BUT.
WE DO SUPPORT IT.
THE AMENDMENTSAS OFFERED AND
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS IF
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO SATISFACTORILY
AMEND THE BILL THANK YOU.
THEY GET CHAIR ADAM RIGHTLY ON
BEHALF OF CAL CHAMBER WERE ALSO.
AT THIS TIME OPPOSE WITHOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THINK.
GOOD EVENING PEAK MONTGOMERY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA OR SEE
JACK AND ALSO THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL ACC OPPOSE THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION. ARE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
ARE YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
I.
JUST RECEIVED IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MY OFFICE
JUST RECEIVED THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS YESTERDAY. AND I'M
SURE WITH THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL A.
INDICATING THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH THAT.
I.
AND CONFIDENT WE CAN FIND A
RESOLUTION.
.
BUT AS A CAREFUL LAWYER I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ALL THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE PROPOSAL
BRIGHT AND THAT YOUR BILL.
SO IT. BILLS BELONG TO THE
AUTHOR NOT THE SPOT HUTCH.
AND AYE STOUTLY STAND BEHIND YOU
ON THAT ONE OUT WE ALSO RECEIVED
FROM LATE. A WE WILL QUITE HAPPY
THIS IS A LANGUAGE WHICH IS
REALLY IN OUR BAILIWICK BUT
THERE JUST WASN'T TIME TO WORK
WITH YOU WHEN THE OPPOSITION ON
IT.
AND SO I RESPECT YOUR OB
RELUCTANCE TO TAKE IT WITHOUT
WORKING ON IT WE PLEDGE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS.
AND.
I REALLY HOPE WE CAN REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION THAT YOU NOW THERE'S.
THERE'S NOTHING THE LEGISLATURE
IS.
HAPPIER TO SAY THAN ALL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED.
ALRIGHT ARE WITH THAT.
I'D LIKE TO RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE.
AND.
LET'S SEE WE HAVE A MOTION YET.
OKAY.
THEN. WHAT IT MADAM SECRETARY?
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN A.
B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT MORE
AT SO CHEAP.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOT VOTING BRO.
BRUNO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN YES.
HOLDEN.
YES OKAY I WOULD AT CITY HIGH
HIGH LA THAT VERY GOOD. FOR.
YEAH YOUR BILL IS OUT OUT.
SO WE NOW NEED TO GO THROUGH.
THE VEILS AND HAVE ADELINES.
CAN.
ALRIGHT WE NEED TO GO THROUGH
EVERY BELL SO WE'LL JUST TAKE
THEM IN NUMERICAL ORDER.
.
MADAM SECRETARY JUST PROCEED
FROM ONE BILL TO THE NECK.
ALRIGHT YES.
SO I'LL START WITH THAT CONSENT.
CALENDAR SO.
I AM. WE HAVE FOR SO MANY ITEM
WILL NOT FIGHT FOR CONSENT.
BRO.
BROKE MY.
HOLDEN.
CONSENT.
HOLDING CONSENT.
I.
SO AT SEVEN SO WE'RE DONE WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY THIS IS.
ITEM ONE AB TWENTY FIFTY
CARILLO.
I THE VOTE IS A FOUR TO ONE. I'M
GLAD I
ARAMBULA I.
BROKE.
BROTEN.
ITEM TWO AB TWENTY SIXTY EL
WATER THOUGH GARCIA.
THE VOTE IS AT FOUR ZERO
ARAMBULA I ARAMBULA I.
BRO.
BROUGH AYE.
WELL THAT'S WHAT SHE AYE.
BUT SWITCHING
SO ONCE SEVEN SIR.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE SANTIAGO.
THE VOTE IS THAT
FIVE ZERO. ARAMBULA AYE AYE
ARAMBULA AYE BROKE.
BRO I.
SEVEN ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY HOLDEN.
THE VOTE IS THAT THREE ZERO.
ARAMBULA PARTY.
BUT OVERLOOKED BY BRO.
BROUGH NOT VOTING.
MURATSUCHI I MATTEUCCI.
LET'S.
MULLIN THIS WAS NOT VOTING.
WHEN CHEN TO TIE SURE.
SO MELENDEZ IS I.
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
TWO BLOOM.
THE VOTE IS AT THREE TWO ONE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOT VOTING.
BROKE.
BRUNO.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX
FONG.
THE VOTE IS AT THREE ZERO.
I'M THREE ZERO ARAMBULA.
TWENTY SIX OH SIX IT IS TWENTY
SIX OH SIX FONG ARE.
I.
WROTE.
ITEM SEVEN IS AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN.
VOTERS AT FOUR ZERO.
ARAMBULA OPENED.
NOT VOTING INVALID BROKE.
BRUNO.
I'M SORRY.
MELENDEZ SO WAS NOT VOTING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CHANGE ABOUT. A NO
VOTE OKAY.
MULLIN THIS IS NO ON A. B..
.
TWENTY SIX FORTY EIGHT.
NO.
I'M SORRY.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT CHEN.
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO
ARAMBULA.
I'M SORRY HIGH I.
ARAMBULA I
BROKE.
BRO I.
THAT WAS AN EX.
SEVEN ZERO.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE KALRA.
VOTERS AT FIVE ZERO.
ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA AYE.
BROKE.
BROUGH AYE.
ZERO.
THIS IS.
ITEM NUMBER TEN IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH THREE LIAM ONE.
THE VOTE IS THAT FOR ONE.
ARAMBULA AYE AYE ARAMBULA AYE
BROKE.
BROWN.
THIS IS ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY TO DALLY.
VOTERS AT FIVE ZERO. ARAMBULA
ALLEN ARAMBULA I. BROKE.
BROUGH.
TURN.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY TWO QUIRK.
A WE HAVE A VOTE OF SIX ZERO
ARAMBULA HIGH NUMBER ICE
SEVEN.
ITEM FOURTEEN IS AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY EIGHT BLOOM.
VOTERS AT THREE ZERO.
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S NO. ARAMBULA BY.
ARAMBULA I BROKE.
BROWN.
FORTY SEVEN OUT.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN YES ARE.
FIVE TWO.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB THREE ZERO ZERO
NINE QUIRK.
THE VOTE IS AT FOUR TO.
ARAMBULA BY.
ARAMBULA I.
NOW LIKE TO CHECK.
YES WHAT A TO CHEAT.
NOT VOTING
WHAT TO DO NOT VOTING.
ITEMS
SCHEME A BE THIRTY FOURTEEN
QUIRK.
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO.
ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA AYE.
BRITAIN'S.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU ARE EVERYONE WHO
PARTICULARLY WAS HERE FOR THE
WHOLE TIME OR MOST OF IT IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY.
A LOT OF GOOD WORK ALL THE
BILL'S GOT OUT.
AND I'M GONNA CALL THIS SESSION
AND AND